ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES.
FOR JUST EFFORT CAMBIADO JANE
DALY DODD THE ROUTE SO GALGIANI
GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE.
HERTZBERG HILL WITH SO MURTADA
JACKSON JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE
MITCHELL MONNING MORE LOCKED.
MERRELL NIELSEN PAN. PORTANTINO
ROTH RUBIO SKINNER STERN STONE
NUMBER WHY KATHY WIENER WILK.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME I REQUEST
WE ALL OBSERVE A MOMENT OF
SILENCE FOR THE VICTIMS OF THE
DIVE BOAT ACCIDENT THAT
OCCURRED OFF TO SANTA CRUZ
ISLAND THIS WEEKEND
. THANK YOU.
WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LEAD IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN SISTER LIBBY
FERNANDES ARE AS KIM FOUNDER
MERCY. AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING AND WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE BY
SENATOR LEYVA. AS WE BRING
OURSELVES INTO GOD'S PRESENCE
TODAY LET US PRAY FOR ALL THOSE
WHO SUFFER. FOR ALL WHO SUFFER
AND STRUGGLE ALONE. MAY THEY
RECEIVE HEALING AND SUPPORT.
FOR ALL WHO EXPERIENCE IN
JUSTICE AND PERSECUTION. MAY
THEY RECEIVE STRENGTH AND
COURAGE. FOR ALL THOSE WHO
PERPETRATE VIOLENCE ON OTHERS
MAY THEY LEARNED THE VIRTUE OF
EMPATHY AND COMPASSION. FOR ALL
WHO GRIEVE AND MOURN MAY THEY
RECEIVE COMFORT AND PEACE. GOD
A MANY NAMES ALL THE DAYS OF
OUR LIVES ARE IN YOUR HANDS.
HELP US TO KNOW YOUR PRESENCE
IN EACH UNFOLDING EVENT. YOUR
ACTIVE ENABLING GRACE IN EVERY
CIRCUMSTANCE. AND YOUR IN
DURING CALL TO FOLLOW YOU EACH
DAY WITH COURAGE AND GRATITUDE
AMEN. PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA AND TO THE REPUBLIC
FOR WHICH IT STANDS ONE NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR FROM
THE PRO TEM. ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION MENTAL
PRO TEM. WHAT THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I'M GONNA TAKE A
MINUTE AND SEE IF A FEW OF OUR
COLLEAGUES HERE COME IN AND
WANT TO JOIN US. I REALLY WANT
TO TAKE A MINUTE AND RECOGNIZE
SOME PEOPLE THAT ARE VERY.
SPECIAL TO US. OUR A AND SO I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
HERE
. THANK YOU. THERE'S
WONDERFUL MISTERPRESIDENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU KNOW I
FELT LIKE THIS WAS SO IMPORTANT
AND I WANT TO THANK THE
SECRETARY OF THE SENATE FOR
ASSISTING US TO DO A
RECOGNITION TODAY FOR SOME
INDIVIDUALS THAT MAKE OUR
EVERYDAY LIFE MUCH MUCH EASIER
AND TYPICALLY ON THURSDAYS I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT EACH OF YOU I
THINK WE ALL HAVE STORIES
THURSDAYS I HAVE IT DOWN TO THE
MINUTE. IN TERMS OF HOW TO GET
HERE ON TIME AND I WOULDN'T
MAKE IT IF IT WEREN'T FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS BEHIND ME AND I
WANT TO INTRODUCE THEM AND I AS
SHE'S GETTING IN ESTABLISHED
ALL ASK OUR REPUBLICAN LEADER
SHE WOULD LIKE TO JOIN US AS
WELL BECAUSE I WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS. TODAY WE ARE VERY
FORTUNATE COLLEAGUES I RISE SO
THAT WE CAN ACKNOWLEDGE AND
THANKS FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT AS
I'VE SAID ALREADYHAVE MADE OUR
LIVES A LITTLE BIT EASIER EVERY
DAY AND WAVE YOUR HAND WHEN I
ACKNOWLEDGE YOU EVERYONE SHOULD
KNOW YOU BUT LET'S JUST MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO MR LERI LUNA.
ROBERT TIMELINE. MORE UNIA. IN
HIGH ME NEAR A SENSUOUS. YOU
MAY RECOGNIZE THESE NAMES BT
YOU CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THE
FACES THESE ARE THE INDIVIDUALS
AND HELP US GET WHERE WE NEED
TO GO THEY HELP US WITH THE
POOL CARS WE NEED TO GET TO AND
FROM THE CAPITAL SO WE CAN DO
THE PEOPLE'S WORK AND SO WE CAN
GET HERE ON TIME. SO LET ME SAY
A FEW WORDS ABOUT EACH OF THEM
AND MADAM REPUBLICAN LEADER
COME OVER HERE AND JOIN ME I
WILL SHARE THIS MOMENT WITH YOU
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT. ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES APPRECIATE THIS.
ROBERT OMAR IN HIGH ME OR THE
POOL ATTENDANTS WORKING CLOSELY
WITH LARRY. ROBERT HAS BEEN AN
INVALUABLE ASSET TO THE MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE THANKS TO HIS
PROFESSIONALISM ATTENTION TO
DETAIL. AND DILIGENT ADHERENCE
TO HIS DUTIES A NATIVE OF
SACRAMENTO HE JOINS STATES
SERVICE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN.
FUNDING ON WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES TO BECOME
PART OF THE TEAM. MANAGING THE
STATE CAPITOL GARAGE YOUR
GLASSES. WE HOPE. OMAR IS
ALWAYS GIVING IN AS AN
OUTSTANDING COURTEOUS AND
CAPABLE SERVICE BORN IN THE
PHILIPPINES PHILIPPINES HE
MOVED TO SACRAMENTO IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR AND HAS BEEN
WORKING FOR THE STATE FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS. TWO OF THOSE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE GARAGE
AND DISSENT OUTSTANDING PERSON
OVERALL HI AMY. I KNOW I LOVE
THIS GUY HI NEAT HAS BEEN
WORKING FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR TWENTY YEARS AND
YOU CAN ALWAYS EXPECT THE SAME
LEVEL OF PROFESSIONALISM A
SMILE. AND HE'S NOT ONLY ABOUT
A- GARAGE ATTENDANT THAT TAKES
CARE OF YOUR CARS HE'S A
BUSINESS OWNER AN ENTREPRENEUR
OR AND HE JUST HAS A WONDERFUL
ATTITUDE EVERY TIME YOU PULL
INTO THE GARAGE. AND THEN HIGH
MAKING FOR MEXICO HE MOVED TO
THE US IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
AND IS JOIN STATE SERVICE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE. THE
MEMBERS IT'S NOT TOO OFTEN THAT
WE TAKE A BREATH FROM OUR WORK
ON THE FLOOR TO SAY THANK YOU.
TO THE PEOPLE THAT MAKE OUR
JOBS EASIER SO TODAY. AS WE
HAND OUT THE RESOLUTIONS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN EXTENDING A HEARTY
THANK YOU TO LARRY ROBERT OMAR
AND HIGH MAY AND THEIR FAMILIES
WHO JOIN THEM HERE TODAY. THANK
YOU GENTLEMEN FOR ALL YOUR WORK
THAT YOU DO ON A DAILY BASIS
AND IF MEMBERS WANT TO JOIN HIM
IN A PHOTO. SHOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME
. ONE MORE
. DO
YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL FAMILY
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO JOIN THE
PHOTO. ALL RIGHT
. WHAT THE
MELONES WALL DEFENDER FOR THE
GREAT SERVICE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA
. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE SB TWO
SEVEN SIX CENTER PAN ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ IN A BILL
TO SEVENTY SIX BY SENATOR PAN
AND ACT WILLING TO PUBLIC
HEALTH. DR. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT SENATORS SIDE RISE TO
BRING YOU SB TWO SEVENTY SIX
WHICH IS BACK ON CONCURRENT
FOLLOWING AMENDMENTS TAKEN UP
IN THE ASSEMBLY SINCE THIS BILL
LAST WAS VOTED ON AND PASSED
OUT OF OUR SENATE SO WE I'VE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. ON
THE SET OF AMENDMENTS THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAD ANNOUNCED THAT HE
WOULD BE WILLING TO SIGN THE
BILL THE POINT WHEN WE TOOK
THOSE AT ON PASSAGE OF THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE I
WILL SUMMER I WANT TO JUST GIVE
A BRIEF DESCRIPTION OF THE
MAJOR AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
TAKEN FIRST OF ALL THE BILL IS
PARTICULARLY FOCUSED NOW ON.
EITHER SCHOOLS THAT HAVE A
INNOVATION RATE BELOW 95% THE
RATE. THE SERVER COMMUNITY. OR
IF IT'S ISSUED BY A PHYSICIAN
WHO HAS SUBMITTED MORE THAN
FIGHT EXEMPTIONS IN THAT YEAR.
THE BILL ALSO SPECIFIES THAT
PHYSICIANS MAY NOT CHARGE
SEPARATE FEES FOR ISSUING
EXEMPTIONS OR FOR PHYSICAL
PHYSICAL EXAMS RELATED TO
BUNDLE OF TEMPORARY EXEMPTIONS.
THE GUIDELINES ARE ACTUALLY
BROADENED TO ALSO INCLUDE THE
GUIDELINES AND AMERICAN CAD
PEDIATRICS. IN STANDARD OF CARE
WHICH BASICALLY MEANS AS LONG
AS A REASONABLE POSITION WHAT
ISSUE SUCH AN EXEMPTION IT
WOULD BE ACCEPTABLE. IF AN
EXEMPTION IS DECIDED TO BE
REVOKED CHILDREN MAY CONTINUE
ATTENDING SCHOOL FOR THIRTY
DAYS BEYOND THAT DECISION. AND
CHILDREN CAN CONTINUE EXEMPTION
TEND SCHOOL WHILE THE EXEMPTION
IS IN THIS BOTH REVIEW AND
APPEAL PROCESS SO IN OTHER
WORDS ONCE EXEMPTION SUBMITTED
THAT IS VALID UNTIL IT IS
REJECTED FINALLY. I WOULD ALSO
POINT OUT THAT WE'VE CREATED
ADDITIONAL INDEPENDENT EXPERT
REVIEW PANEL SO IT'S NOT ONLY
REVIEWED BY PUBLIC HEALTH THEY
CAN THEN APPEAL TO AND FEEL
PANEL. OF PHYSICIANS PRACTICING
PHYSICIANS APPOINTED BY THE
SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES THEY'LL DO THE FINAL
REVIEW BASED ON THE CHEN
STANDARD OF CARE. SO THOSE ARE
THE A MAJOR AMENDMENTS SOFTLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE WITH ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY DISCUSSION DEBATE. SENATOR
STONE. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES I WAS
A. A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF SB TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN. BEING A
PHARMACIST FOR. ALMOST THIRTY
EIGHT YEARS AS A- GIVEN ME THE
KNOWLEDGE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
IMMUNIZATIONS OF SAVED MILLIONS
OF LIVES NOT ONLY AND THE
UNITED STATES BUT THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD. BUT WHEN WE PASS SB
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN WE MADE SOME
PROMISES. AND THOSE PROMISES
WERE THAT IF YOU HAD A CHILD
THAT HAD AN ADVERSE REACTION TO.
A VACCINATION OR COULD HAVE A
POTENTIAL ADVERSE EFFECT FROM A
VACCINATION THAT YOU COULD.
HAVE A AN APPOINTMENT WITH YOUR
MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL YOUR
DOCTOR. AND IF YOUR DOCTOR
SOLID FOOT UNSATISFIED
APPROPRIATE THAT YOU SHOULD
HAVE AN EXEMPTION THAT HE WOULD
GRANT YOU THAT EXEMPTION. AND
YOU CAN STILL ENROLL YOUR CHILD
IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS. NOW I'LL BE
HONEST WITH YOU THE SIDE
EFFECTS IMMUNIZATIONS. OUR RARE
WHEN YOU CONSIDER THE NUMBER OF
IMMUNIZATIONS THAT ARE GIVEN
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES
AND GIVEN THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
BUT I'LL TELL YOU WHEN I
CHAIRED THE- COMMITTEE MEETING.
WHEN YOU SEE THE MORBIDITY AND
MORTALITY ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE
THAT DO HAVE INCIDENTS. THEY'RE
NOT MINOR. THEIR MAJOR. YOU CAN
HAVE A ONE SIZE FITS ALL. FOR
EXEMPTIONS THE CDC HAS
GUIDELINES BUT WE STILL NEED TO
ALLOW PHYSICIANS TO PRACTICE.
WE NEED TO HAVE POSITIONS HAVE
A PATIENT PHYSICIAN
RELATIONSHIP. NOW AS YOU ALL
KNOW I'M NOT ONLY A PHARMACIST
BUT I'M PRACTICING PHARMACIST
IN I HAVE TO ADHERE TO THE LAWS
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS A
ARE IMPOSED. AND AS THEY ARE
ENFORCED BY THE STATE BOARD OF
PHARMACY. THE STATE BOARD OF
PHARMACY DOESN'T DELEGATE ANY
OF THEIR ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITY.
TO ANYONE ELSE OTHER THAN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IF YOU'RE
FILING CRIMINAL CHARGES AGAINST
A PHARMACIST FOR EXAMPLE.
SELLING MORPHINE OR BY CAN
ENTER OXYCONTIN OUT THE BACK
DOOR. A VERY SIMPLE SOLUTION.
TO THE. ISSUE OF SOME.
UNSCRUPULOUS PHYSICIANS THAT
WILL WRITE AN EXEMPTION FOR A
FEE. IS TO LEAN ON THE MEDICAL
BOARD. THAT'S WHAT THE MEDICAL
BOARD IS THERE FOR. TWO POLICE
IF YOU WELL. THE PHYSICIANS
THAT OUR LICENSE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE THAT
THEY'RE GETTING QUALITY MEDICAL
CARE. LET ME TELL YOU. JUST
BECAUSE I GET A PRESCRIPTION.
FOR OXYCONTIN. DOES NOT ME I
HAVE A MANDATE UNDER LAW TO
DISPENSE THAT PRESCRIPTION FOR
OXYCONTIN. I HAVE TO LOOK AT A
NUMBER OF FACTORS. WHEN A
PATIENT COMES IN IF I NOTICE TO
THE DISCUSS THE PRESCRIPTION
FOR OXYCONTIN THREE DAYS AGO IN
THIS POST IT LAST FALL BABIES I
CAN POLITELY GIVE THE
PRESCRIPTION BACK AND SAY I'M
SORRY I'M NOT GOING TO FEEL
THAT PRESCRIPTION BY LAW. IF I
FEEL THAT PRESCRIPTION. I COULD
HAVE A STATE BOARD OF PHARMACY
INSPECTOR IN MY PHARMACY.
WRITING ME A VIOLATION. HAVING
AN ACCUSATION MIGHT BE AGAINST
ME AND MY PHARMACY. AND THE
POWER OF THE STATE BOARD OF
PHARMACY IS IF YOU DON'T FOLLOW
THE RULES. THEY COULD BE THE
SUSPEND YOUR LICENSE OR IN A
WORST CASE SITUATION THEY CAN
REVOKE YOUR LICENSE. SO
QUESTION THAT ALL OF US HAVE.
IS WHY ARE WE EMPOWERING THE
MEDICAL BOARD TO POLICE THEIR
OWN. TO ME THIS OF ADMISSION.
BUT THE MEDICAL BOARD DOESN'T
EITHER WANT TO ENFORCE THESE
PROVISIONS. OR THEY ARE
INCAPABLE OF ENFORCING THESE
PROVISIONS. BY NOW GIVING THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH. THE
RESPONSIBILITY. OF REVIEWING
WHAT THE MEDICAL BOARD COULD BE
REVIEWING IS BASICALLY TELLING
THOSE. THE ARE STRONGLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR PATIENTS
THEIR CHILDREN'S WELFARE IF
THEY HAVE TWO CHILDREN THAT
HAVE HAD ADVERSE REACTIONS TO.
IMMUNIZATIONS AND I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT A RASH OF TALKING
ABOUT ANAPHYLACTIC SHOCK. IF I
WERE A PARENT I WOULD SEEK. AN
EXEMPTION SO WHAT ARE THE
PARENTS GONNA DO NOW WHEN THE
ANSWER IS NO. THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE TO APPEAL TO A LARGE
BUREAUCRACY AND HAVE TO DEAL
WITH A- CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF VEHICLES PROCEDURE TO
SAFEGUARD THEIR CHILD. IF
THEY'RE GOING TO PUT THEIR KIDS
IN A PUBLIC SCHOOL. AGAIN
FOLKS. I REALLY I BELIEVE IN
IMMUNIZATIONS I BELIEVE THEY
SAVE LIVES BUT THERE ARE RARE
INSTANCES WHERE. A EXCLUSION IS
MANDATED NECESSARY. IF WE HAVE
PHYSICIANS THAT ARE ABUSING
THEIR AUTHORITY IN WRITING
THESE EXEMPTIONS. IN ACCORDANCE
WITH GOOD MEDICAL PRACTICE THE
NOT MEDICAL BOARD TO STEP IN.
SUSPEND OR RE REVOKE THEIR
LICENSES. AND I BELIEVE THAT
THAT WILL CURE THE PROBLEM IF
YOU WILL OF INAPPROPRIATE
EXEMPTIONS BEING GIVEN. BUT
EVERY PATIENT THE GOES TO A
DOCTOR IS UNIQUE THE PRESENTS
WITH VERY UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES.
WE CAN'T DOCUMENT EVERY SINGLE
SIDE EFFECT THAT HAPPENS WITH
EVERY DRUG. BUT WE HAVE AN
ANSWER TO BE READ THE ANSWER TO
ASPIRIN THAT'LL SCARE YOU IF
YOU READ THE ANSWER ON TYLENOL
IT'LL SCARE YOU AS A CLAIMS
OVER FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE'S
LIVES. IN THE UNITED STATES
EVERY SINGLE YEAR. BUT IF YOU
TAKE A NUMBER OF THEM CONSIDER
GIVEN. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND YOU ADVERTISE
THAT TO SEE WHAT THE OVERALL
HERD IMMUNITY. WOULD BE AS A
RESULT. YOU STILL WOULD HAVE
EFFECTIVE IMMUNITY. ARE
PROTECTING. OUR CHILDREN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO. WHILE
I SUPPORT THAT WE GIVE
IMMUNIZATIONS TWO PEOPLE THAT
CAN. SAFELY RECEIVE THEM. MAYBE
SCATTERING. THE SCHEDULE
BECAUSE I PERSONALLY BELIEVE
THAT GETTING TOO MANY
IMMUNIZATIONS AT ONE TIME CAN
OVERWHELM THE IMMUNE SYSTEM
THAT MAY BE THE CAUSE OF SOME
OF THESE ADVERSE REACTIONS BUT
MY FRIENDS WE SHOULD LET THE
MEDICAL BOARD. DO WHAT THEY
WERE APPOINTED TO DO. AND THAT
IS TO OVERSEE THE PRACTICE OF
MEDICINE TO ENSURE THAT QUALITY
HEALTHCARE IS BEING DELIVERED
TO EACH AND EVERY PATIENT
WHETHER IT'S A CHILD OR AN
ADULT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THOSE PHYSICIANS
THE ABROGATE THOSE
RESPONSIBILITIES. AND CHARGE A
FEE TO WRITE AN EXEMPTION
BECAUSE THEY JUST WANT THE
MONEY INSTEAD OF LOOKING OUT
FOR THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
CHILD. THEN THEY SHOULD BE
DISCIPLINED BY THE MEDICAL
BOARD WE SHOULD BE HAVING THAT
RESPONSIBILITY OFF TO A THIRD
PARTY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NAMELY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH THAT'S AN
ABROGATION OF RESPONSIBILITY BY
THE MEDICAL BOARD AND FOR THOSE
REASONS. I THINK COULD VOTE
DOWN SB TWO SEVENTY SIX.
CENTERS CENTER MORLOCK. PLEASE
NO THE PLATOON CHAMBER DINNER
MORE LOCK THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THIS YEAR I'VE
LEARNED A COUPLE NEW WORDS.
WHICH IS KIND OF A HOBBY TO
LEARN NEW WORDS. A ONE IS A
FRESH SHE. BE A GOOD SENATOR
FROM SANOMA CAME UP TO ME
RECENTLY AND SAID. I
SPREADSHEET YOU HAD A PRESSURE
THIS WEEKEND I SAID WHAT IS A
PRICEY THAT IS. A HAIR CUT
RIGHT NO MATTER IT'S IN THE
DICTIONARY. IN OTHER WORDS I'VE
LEARNED THIS YEAR ANAPHYLAXIS
OR ANAPHYLACTIC SHOCK.
COLLEAGUES THAT MANY OF YOU
LIKE MYSELF SLIDE OF SACRAMENTO
IN BACK ON SOUTHWEST AIRLINES
WHEN I STARTED A FEW YEARS AGO
I. SORT OF LOOK FORWARD TO MY
BAG OF PEANUTS. AND IT WAS SORT
OF MY BREAKFAST ON THE WAY UP.
AND SO IT WAS A LITTLE
FRUSTRATING WHEN THEY WOULD
SAVE SORRY WE'RE NOT HANDING
OUT PEANUT CITY BECAUSE SOMEONE
ON THE PLANE. HAS A PEANUT
ALLERGY. AND I KIND OF DIDN'T
REACT WELLS LIKE. WHAT ABOUT MY
**** ONCE IN AWHILE FLIGHT
ATTENDANT WITH HIM YOUR BAG ON
THE WAY OUT. BUT I'M NOT A REAL
FAN OF THEIR PRETZELS. BUT TERM
NOW THEY'RE NOT EVEN OFFERING
PEANUTS AT ALL THE END
OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING HAS BECAUSE
SOUTHWEST AIRLINES TO DO THAT
SOMEWHERE ALONG THE WAY SOMEONE
IN THE ONE POINT 4% OF THE
POPULATION. THAT HAVE A PEANUT
ALLERGY. HAS. GREAT ENOUGH OF
THE STORY THAT WE JUST DON'T
GET PEANUTS WHATSOEVER SO THAT
TO STARTED. ME THINKING SOME
PEOPLE ARE SO ALLERGIC. THAT
ACCORDING TO WIKIPEDIA IT IS
RECOGNIZED AS ONE OF THE MOST
SEVERE FOOD ALLERGIES DUE TO
ITS PREVALENCE PERSISTENCY AND
POTENTIAL SEVERITY OF ALLERGIC
REACTION. PHYSICAL SYMPTOMS CAN
INCLUDE ITCHINESS HIVES
SWELLING EXCIMER SNEEZING
ASTHMA ABDOMINAL PAIN DROP IN
BLOOD PRESSURE DIARRHEA AND
CARDIAC ARREST ANAPHYLAXIS IS A
SERIOUS LIFE THREATENING
ALLERGIC REACTION SO I
APOLOGIZE TO THOSE PEANUT.
INTOLERANT PEOPLE BECAUSE I
COULDN'T HAVE MY LITTLE BAG OF
PEANUTS ON THE WAY TO AND FROM
BUT I CAN'T WATCH A COMMERCIAL
ANYMORE ON THE NIGHTLY NEWS
WITHOUT HEARING WARNINGS ABOUT
THE SIDE EFFECTS ALLERGIC
REACTIONS TO EITHER THE
MEDICATION OR ITS INGREDIENTS.
TERM BY A. DON'T USE IF YOU'RE
ALLERGIC TO TRIM FIRE AVOID USE
OF LIVE VACCINES IN PATIENTS
TREATED WITH FROM FIRE. CHEN
TAKES TO QUIT SMOKING ALLERGIC
OR SERIOUS SKIN REACTIONS SOME
CAN BE LIFE THREATENING. TO
LISTEN HE FOR DIABETES TYPE TWO
IFYOU ARE ALLERGIC TO TREELESS
CITY THERE ARE SERIOUS SIDE
EFFECTS. BEING A MEMBER OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH CAUCUS ARE JUST
COMPLETING A BOOK BY ELLEN
SACKS THE CENTER CANNOT HOLD
IN. ABOUT SCHIZOPHRENIA AND SHE
TALKS ABOUT THE VEIN MEDICATION
SHE WAS TAKING AND THE SIDE
EFFECTS NOW CALLED TARDIVE.
DYSKINESIA THE THINGS HAPPEN
WITH CERTAIN DRUGS SO I AM I AM
NOT OPPOSED. THE VACCINES IN
FACT I'M A FORMER ROTARIAN WITH
TEN YEARS OF PERFECT ATTENDANCE
AND IT WAS OUR MISSION TO IRAQ
TO CAPE POLIO FROM THIS PLANET.
AND SO WE WORK REALLY HARD AND
FOCUSED ON REMOVING POLIO BUT
I. I I'M ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
MEASLES BUT OF LATE MAYBE I
SHOULD BE MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
TYPHOID FEVER WITH SOME OF THE
HOMELESS CAMPS WE SEE UP AND
DOWN THE STATE. BUT I AM
GETTING MISTER PRESIDENT VERY
VERY. INCENTIVE TO ALLERGIC
REACTIONS MY WIFE IS ALLERGIC
TO SHELLFISH SO WE'RE ALWAYS
CAREFUL. AT MEAL FUNCTIONS. SO
WHAT IF AN IMPRINT IS ALLERGIC
TO A VACCINE OR ONE OF ITS
INGREDIENTS. WOOD RIVER WHAT WE
REALLY FORCE AN INJECTION
REALLY. LAST WEEK I HAD MICHAEL
IN MY OFFICE. TWENTY FIVE YEARS
OLD HANDSOME POLITE. BUT ACTED
LIKE A NON VERBAL TODDLER. THE
VACCINE INDUCED AN ANAPHYLACTIC
SHOCK. AND FOR HIM THERE WAS NO
RE BOOT TO NORMAL. MICHAEL'S
PARENTS HAVE LIVE WITH THE
RESULTS IN A BRAISE MICHAEL
LOVINGLY. SO HAVE MANY OTHER
PARENTS. AND THEY WANT TO SPARE
THEIR SIBLINGS OF THEIR
PERMANENTLY IMPACTED CHILDREN.
RAISING A DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED CHILD IS A MAJOR
SACRIFICE AND FRUSTRATING. ALL
THE MORE IF IT COULD HAVE BEEN
AVOIDED. THAT'S WHY THEY COME
HERE BY THE HUNDREDS ON THESE
BILLS. THAT'S WHY THEY EVEN
STAND ON CHAIRS AND CHANT.
COLLEAGUES IF CERTAIN BAD
ACTORS ARE SELLING MEDIC
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS THAN CURRENT
PROCEDURES SHOULD BE UTILIZED
TO WEED THEM OUT AS WAS
ELOQUENTLY STATED BY MY
PHARMACIST COLLEAGUES. THE
SENATOR FROM TO MACULA LET'S
BEEF UP THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
BOARD BUT SCARING. AND LIMITING
MEDICAL PROFESSIONS WHO ARE
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE TRYING TO
PREVENT ANAPHYLAXIS IS IN MY
OPINION LEGISLATIVE MALPRACTICE.
WE SHOULD BE PROTECTING
VULNERABLE INFERENCE NOT
CONDEMNING THEM TO
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED LIFE'S.
COLLEAGUES LET'S RELY ON OUR
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS. IN THEIR
INTIMATE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THEIR PATIENTS. SB TWO SEVEN
SIX ADDRESSES A PERCEIVED ABUSE
OF SIMPSON WITH THE WRONG CURE
THAT'S WHY I'M OPPOSED TO SB
TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK CENTER. CENTER
OUR- FIVE QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR. THE CENTER PANEL YOU TO
QUESTION COURSE OKAY SO I WOKE
UP THIS MORNING. ZARA CAL
MATTERS THE MENTIONED A WHOLE
SLEW OF AMENDMENTS THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAD PUT FORWARD HI TO.
THIS BILL PROPOSED AMENDMENTS I
DATE SEEM VERY REASONABLE TO ME
WHEN I SAW THAT I JUST ASSUME
THAT THIS BILL WOULD BE WOULD
BE COMING UP FOR SEVERAL DAYS
GIVEN THE FACT THAT PRISON WE
NEED TO COMMIT TO OUR SIGNATURE
I JUST WANT TO GET
UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S GOING ON
HERE. WITH REGARDS TO THESE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND YOUR
PLANTS OF THIS BILL. SO FIRST
OF ALL I WOULD INDICATE THAT WE
WORK TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
THERE WAS AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE
ASSEMBLY AND MYSELF AS THE
AUTHOR. ON THIS YEAR'S
AMENDMENTS I JUST PRESENTED TO
YOU FOR CONCURRENCE THE
GOVERNOR IT INDICATED AFTER THE
TOOK THOSE AMENDMENTS AND
ASSEMBLY HEALTH THAT HE WOULD
SIGN THE BILL. WHEN THE BILL
THEN PROGRESS ON TO THE S. TO
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS. THERE
WAS SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT
WHETHER THERE WERE SOME
ADDITIONAL. AMENDMENTS HOWEVER
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DID NOT. FIVE PUT ANY
AMENDMENTS IN THE BILL WHEN IT
LIFTED OUT SUSPENSE. AFTER LEFT
TO SPEND SIDE DID NOT RECEIVE.
ANY CALL OR CONTACT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE INDICATING
THEY STILL WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THOSE AMENDMENTS. AND THEN OF
YESTERDAY OF COURSE THE BILL
WAS PASSED OFF THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. IT IS NOW HERE ON
CONCURRENCE. I WAS WE CANNOT
TAKE AMENDMENTS ON CONCURRENCE.
I CERTAINLY AM ALWAYS OPEN TO
WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WE DID BEFORE WE CAME TO
AN AGREEMENT. THAT'S THE VIRGIN
THE BILL THAT'S BEFORE YOU THIS
IS A BILL THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AGREED TO. AND SAID THAT
THEY WOULD COMMIT TO SIGN
CERTAINLY I AM HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE GOVERNOR AND TRYING TO
WORK OUT SOME OF THE ADDITIONAL
ISSUES THAT HE IS RAISING AND
SO CERTAINLY WE'RE GOING TO DO
THAT. THE EVEN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AS INDICATED IN THEIR-
COMMUNICATIONS THAT THEY WOULD
NOT BE SEEKING TO A MAN THIS
BILL WITH ANY ADDITIONAL.
AMENDMENTS THAT WE WOULD ANY
SORT OF ADDITIONAL CLEAN UP.
HAVE TO BE DONE IN ANOTHER
VEHICLE CELL AGAIN I WOULD URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL I
CONCURRENT. SENATOR BORDERS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
WE'VE WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THE
LACK OF STABILITY IN DISCOURSE
IN WASHINGTON. WE'VE SEEN IT IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT I TELL YOU THE
VIDEO IN COVERAGE THAT I SAW OF
HOW MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO WAS TREATED. HE'S
ABSOLUTELY UNACCEPTABLE. IN
THIS THIS BODY CONVENES PRIOR
IN SOLIDARITY WE STOOD WITH OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO THAT
EVEN THOUGH MANY OF S DISAGREE
WITH THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THIS IS NOT HOW WE DO THE
PEOPLE'S BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA.
IF WE DISAGREED WITH A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WE CAN PASSIONATELY
FINE VENUES TO EXPRESS THAT.
BECOMING PHYSICAL IN TRYING TO
INTIMIDATE OR LEGISLATORS IS
WHAT HAPPENS IN BANANA
REPUBLICS NOT IN CALIFORNIA AND
CERTAINLY NOT THE UNITED STATES.
SO HAVING SAID THAT. I STILL
HAVE RESERVATIONS MY FRIEND ON
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION MY
COLLEAGUE FROM TO MACULA HAD
INDICATED EARLIER THE SAME
CONCERNS THAT I EXPRESS PRIOR.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE ARE
DELEGATING THE RESPONSIBILITY
TO OVERSEE THESE MEDICAL
REVIEWS TO A BUREAUCRATIC BODY.
WHEN THE MEDICAL BOARD IS THE
BODY THAT HAS THE APPROPRIATE
JURISDICTION AND THE EXPERTISE
PROFESSIONAL AM PRACTITIONER
WAS. TO REVIEW WHETHER THESE
EXEMPTIONS HAD BEEN FRIVOLOUSLY
DOLED OUT. BY ANALOGY IF
SOMEONE HAD A COMPLAINT AGAINST
IN A TURNING LICENSE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO SUBMIT THEIR CLAIMS TO
A BUREAUCRATIC BODY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THEY'RE GOING TO
GO TO THE BAR. THE CALIFORNIA
BAR. SO TOO I WOULD SK YOU
EVEN AT THIS LATE STAGE
ESPECIALLY AS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING AMENDMENTS. WOULD YOU
CONSIDER REVISING THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TO TAKE IT OUT OF
THE JURISDICTION OF THE OF THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
CREATE THE VENUE WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD THAT IS THE ONLY
WAY THAT THERE COULD BE A
PROPER REVIEW. OF SOMEONE MISS
APPLYING THEIR KNOWLEDGE AND
ABUSING THE PROCESS OF DOLING
OUT EXEMPTIONS WHEN THEY ARE
NOT APPROPRIATE. I CAN ONLY ASK
THAT YOU WOULD CONSIDER THIS
AND WE'LL SEE HOW THE VOTE
PLAYS OUT TODAY BUT GETTING
BACK TO THE EARLIER POINT. I
CAN DISAGREE WITH YOU. BUT YOU
AND ARE NOT DISAGREEABLE. AND
WE STAND WITH YOU IN OPPOSE ANY
SETTLEMENT THAT TRIES TO
INTIMIDATE A LEGISLATOR FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS FROM DOING
ITS PEOPLE'S BUSINESS.
PICKCENTER SENATOR WINNER. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HI MISTER
PRESIDENT ARE COLLEAGUES I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX I WANT TO EXPRESS
MY GRATITUDE TO THE CENTER OF
IN SACRAMENTO FOR HIS YEARS OF
WORK IN MAKING SURE THAT OUR
CHILDREN IN OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
HEALTHY AND SUSTAINING MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF ABUSE AND THE
PHYSICAL SAW WITH TEST THE
CAPSTONE WE'RE GOING ON FOR
YEARS IN TERMS OF THE
HARASSMENT AND IT IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND AGAIN I WANT
TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. OUR COLLEAGUE THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT SCIENCE AND ABOUT
WHETHER WE BELIEVE IN SCIENCE
OR NOT UNFORTUNATELY IN THE
POLITICS OF TODAY WE SEE THAT
AROUND CLIMATE WE SEE IT HERE
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO TO SPEW
BASIC SCIENTIFIC FACTS AND WE
HAVE SEEN IT ON THE DEBATES
AROUND WE'RE GONNA ACTUALLY TO
REFRAIN FROM YELLING HEARING
THE CHAMBER. WINTER YOU MAY
CONTINUE INTO THE BATES ABOUT
VACCINES WORKS AS A BULLY IN
MISINFORMATION IS CIRCULATED
ABOUT VACCINES AND WHAT THAT
DOES IS DESIGNED TO CAUSE FEAR
AND IT LEADS TO THE ATMOSPHERE
THAT WE HAVE SEEN AROUND THIS
BILL AND IT IS ON ACCEPTABLE WE
CAN PEOPLE ARE ENTITLED TO
THEIR OPINIONS PEOPLE AND BY
ENTITLED TO THEIR OWN STOCKS
AND IT DIANNE IS CLEAR THAT
VACCINES WORK THAT MAKE OUR
COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE. THEY
SAVE ON ACCOUNTABLE LIVES HERE
AROUND THE WORLD AND THAT OUR
CHILDREN NEED TO BE BACK HERE
AGAIN. SEIZE POTENTIALLY DEADLY
DISEASES. AS A THIS IS JUST A
BASIC MATTER OF SCIENTIFIC FACT
AN OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND WE HAVE SEEN.
DIED AFTER SB TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
WAS PASSED THAT WHEN ALL THESE
BOGUS FRAUDULENT MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS WERE GRANTED WE
STARTED TO SEE MORE CASES OF
THE MEASLES. A DISEASE THAT WE
HAD EFFECTIVELY A RADIC HEATED
KEEPS MAKING A COMEBACK BECAUSE
OF THE MISINFORMATION AROUND
VACCINES. I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND ABOUT THIS
BILL. BUT THIS BILL ONLY KICKS
IN WHEN THERE HAS BEEN SOME
SORT OF INDICATION OF A PROBLEM
WHEN YOU HAVE A PHYSICIAN THAT
IS WRITING A LARGE NUMBER OF
THESE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS. IF
THERE IS A HIGH VACCINATION
RATE IN THE SCHOOL OR IF YOU
HAVE A PHYSICIAN WHO IS NOT
WRITING A LARGE NUMBER OF THESE
EXEMPTIONS THIS BILL DOESN'T
EVEN KICK IN THIS IS ABOUT THE
BAD ACTOR PHYSICIANS. AND IT'S
ABOUT SCHOOLS THAT ARE NOT
SAFE. FOR THE CHILDREN WHO
ACTUALLY CAN'T BE VACCINATED
AND THAT'S ANOTHER CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT POINT. FOR THE VERY
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY REQUIRE A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION INCLUDING BABIES.
BECAUSE YOU CANNOT GET. THE
MEASLES VACCINE WHEN YOU'RE A
NEW BORN YOU HAVE TO WAIT. AND
SO THESE INDIVIDUALS WHETHER
SOMEONE WITH A MEDICAL
CONDITION YOU CAN GET BACK
SENATE OR YOU HAVE A BABY.
VISIT PEOPLE ARE EXPOSED AND
WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CHOOSING NOT TO GET VACCINES
AND DOCTORS WHO ARE WRITING
FRAUDULENT MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
YOU ARE DIRECTLY PUTTING IN
DANGER THE PEOPLE AND THE
BABIES WHO CANNOT BE VACCINATED
THIS BILL DOES NOT GET RID OF
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS IT SIMPLY
PUTS SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE SO
THAT PHYSICIANS CANNOT COMMIT
FRAUD. AND SO THAT WE DO NOT
SEE A RESURGENCE OF THESE
DEADLY DISEASES I ASKED FOR AN
IPO. THANK YOU SENATOR MORROW.
THANK YOU HI COLLEAGUES THE OB
MAKE MY COMMENTS BRIEF BECAUSE
I JUST WANNA PICKING OUT OF
BACK ON WHAT A- FEW OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY SAID
BUT THE THING THAT I WANT TO
JUST MY MAIN POINT IS THIS SO
MANY THINGS THAT THIS BODY DOES
YOU KNOW GOVERNMENT THE
CONSTITUTION SPOTS BEING
LIMITED BUT IT SEEMS LIKE THIS
BODY INSERTS ITSELF IN ALMOST
EVERY PART OF THE LIVES OF
AMERICANS TODAY. AND WE
OVERSTEP OUR BOUNDARY I THINK.
TOO OFTEN ESPECIALLY I IT IT
DOES WORRY ME THAT THIS BODY
BELIEVES WRAPS THEY KNOW MORE
THAN PERRANCE IN A DOCTOR. AND
SO WE NEED TO GET BACK LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN TO THE TO THE
PARENTS MAKING THOSE DECISIONS
AND CONJUNCTION WITH THEIR
DOCTOR NOT A BODY OF
POLITICIANS THAT HAVE COME FROM
EVERY WALK OF LIFE. IN FEW OF
THEM THAT ARE IN THE MEDICAL
FIELD SO I RESERVE MY COMMENTS
SIR IT TOOK TO JUST THAT AND I
WILL BE A STRONG. IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL THANKS FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU SENATOR SENATOR
DALLY. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS AYE.
HAVEN'T HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON THIS BILL I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY WHAT WAS HER HERE AND
THEN I CAME TO THE SENATE. IS
MY FIRST OPPORTUNITY I WANT TO.
SHARE WITH THE BODY THAT. I'M
NOT SOMEBODY WHO IS A ANTI
BOXER I MY CHILDREN WERE
VACCINATED. BUT WE DID CONSULT
WITH A DOCTOR AND WE. WE
EXTENDED THE TIMES OUT WE
DIDN'T DO THE SECOND MMR UNDER
HIS GUIDANCE. AND BUT I THINK
IT'S NOT REALLY ABOUT
VACCINATIONS. IT'S ABOUT. THE
FREEDOMS OF INDIVIDUALS IN THIS
STATE TO BE A PARENT AND HAVE A
CHOICE WHETHER THEY CHOOSE HOW
TO RAISE OUR CHILD AND WHETHER
THEY CAN GO TO PUBLIC SCHOOL
NOW YOU MAY SAY YES THEY CAN GO
TO THIS BOARD AND THEY CAN JUMP
THROUGH THE HOOPS TO GET WHERE
THEY WANT TO GO BUT IT'S A
REALLY DETERRING FACTOR FOR A
LOT OF THE CONSTITUENTS I
REPRESENT WHO I SAW OVER THE
WEEKEND YOU RE CONTEMPLATING
LEAVING CALIFORNIA BECAUSE-
THEY DON'T LIKE THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. SO IT'S THEIR
FAULT NAVIN YOU TO SOMEHOW GET
THERE AND WE'RE ALWAYS AFTER
THE BAD ACTOR BUT IN THE TIMES
THAT WE GO AFTER THOSE BAD
ACTORS OUT THERE. OR PEOPLE WHO
ARE ABUSING THE RIGHT. WE
CAPTURE A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE.
THAT ARE TRYING TO BE.
RESPONSIBLE PARENTS AND
SAFEGUARD THEIR CHILDREN IN
THROUGH THEIR CHOICES. TO ME
THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT WE DID
WE HAD SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
WHICH- WAS NARROWLY CRAFTED IN
AND GAVE A EASIER OPPORTUNITY
FOR PARENTS TO BE ABLE TO. HAVE
THAT EXEMPTION. YOU KNOW IT'S A
CHOICE OF WHETHER YOU'RE GOING
TO GO TO A PUBLIC SCHOOL OR
WHERE YOU'RE GONNA HOME WHAT
WERE YOU GONNA DO WITH YOUR
CHILD AND THEY WANT TO GET
EDUCATION THEY PAY TAXES LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE I WANT TO ACCESS
TO SYSTEMS. FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
BUT THIS IS ABOUT PERSONAL.
ADAMS AND THE RIGHT OF A PARENT
THE BILL TO MAKE WHAT THEY
THINK IS THE BEST CHOICE FOR
THEIR CHILDREN SO I THINK THIS
BILL GOES TOO FAR I KNOW THERE
ARE EXEMPTIONS BUT THOSE
EXEMPTIONS ARE TOUGH TO GET
THROUGH. AND SOMETIMES I THINK
THAT THAT'S THE GOAL IS THAT
YOU MAKE IT SO HARD THAT IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT FOR THE LAY
PERSON TO GET THROUGH THE
PROCESS SO YOU END UP GETTING
THE GOAL WHERE YOU'RE
BASICALLY. COMING TO SOCIAL
THREE TELLING EVERYBODY HOW TO
LIVE THEIR LIVES. AND I THINK
THAT'S WRONG. WE WERE HERE THAT
WE'RE HERE TO. MAKE JUST LAWS
WE'RE ALSO HERE TO KEEP
PEOPLE'S PERSONAL FREEDOMS. AND
SO FOR THOSE REASONS I WILL BE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU CENTER CENTER WROTE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I TO
RISE IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
FOR ALL THE REASONS STATED BY
MY COLLEAGUES AND IT'S AN HONOR
TO BE THE REPUBLICAN LEADER
WHEN THEY A SAND SO STRONG
AGAINST SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
ARE BEING SPOKEN ON THIS FLOOR
TODAY ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
BILL I DO HAVE A QUESTION THE
AUTHOR IF YOU WOULD SO KILEY
TAKE A QUESTION. WHEN WE TO
QUESTION FORCE I KNOW THAT
OFTENTIMES AS WITH LEGISLATORS
RIGHT LEGISLATION THERE IS AN
INTENT BEHIND THAT AND I WOULD
HOPE THAT YOUR INTENT IS NOT TO
STOP COMPLETE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS FOR FAMILIES THAT
NEED OF MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS FOR
MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILDREN SO
IN YOUR THOUGHT PROCESSES ARE
YOUR INTENT. WHAT WOULD IT BE A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION. YOU MAY
RESPOND. SO I IF THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR QUESTION FIRST OF
ALL I'D SAY THE INTENT OF THE
BILL IS TO KEEP CHILDREN SAFE.
AND PARTICULARLY CHILDREN WHO
ACTUALLY NEED MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS. BECAUSE IF THEY
RECEIVE A MEDICAL EXEMPTION
MEANS THEY'RE NOT FULLY
VACCINATED. AS OUT FULLY
VACCINATED THEY ARE VULNERABLE.
TO THOSE DISEASES SO WE DON'T
HAVE A HIGH IN A VACCINATION
RATE IN THE SCHOOL. FOUND THEM
THEY ARE AT RISK OF ACTUALLY
GETTING EXPOSED AND CATCHING
THE DISEASE. NOW WHAT THE BILL
DOES AND I'M GONNA DRESS ALSO
THE AMENDMENTS IS THAT WE
ACTUALLY SAY THAT THE VALUATION
OF A MEDICAL EXEMPTION REQUEST
IS BASED ON GUIDELINES
INCLUDING THE STANDARD OF CARE
CENTERS CARES WHAT ANY
REASONABLE PHYSICIAN. WOULD
FIND THAT'S REASONABLE TO GRANT
A MEDICAL EXEMPTION IN FACT I
WOULDPOINT OUT THAT BEGAN MY
PRESENTATION OF THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WHEN THIS BILL LEFT THIS.
FLOOR WE TOOK A MENACE THAT
FIRST OF ALL SAID THAT NOT ONLY
DOES GET REVIEWED BY OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH WHICH WAS IN THE BILL
WHEN WE DEBATED HERE WE
ACTUALLY CREATED A APPEALS.
PANEL COMPOSED OF THREE
PRACTICING PHYSICIANS. BUT
THEY'RE NOT PLEASE OF THE PART
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. THREE
PRACTICING PHYSICIANS WHO
BASICALLY WILL APPLY STANDARD
OF CARE WHICH MEANS IF A
REASONABLE POSITION WOULD GRANT
A MEDICAL EXEMPTION IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE THEN THEY WILL
PROVE THAT EXEMPTION. AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S A YEAH WE
TALK ABOUT DOCTORS AND THIS IS
A GROUP OF DOCTORS THAT
BASICALLY ARE GOING TO SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT THAT SOMETHING
REASONABLE POSITION WOULD DO
THEN THE EXEMPTION WILL STAND.
AND SO THAT IS THE STANDARD IN
WHICHWE HAVE PLACED AND IN
THIS BILL. AND SO I WOULD JUST.
NOTE THAT AGAIN THE PURPOSE OF
THE BILL IS TO KEEP. PEOPLE
SAFE. FOR KIDS SAFE IN SCHOOL
AND WE ARE GOING TO APPLY. A
STANDARD OF CARE WHICH IS AGAIN
WHAT A REASONABLE POSITION
WOULD DO. AND I THINK THAT IF
AN IF WE START TALKING ABOUT
UNREASONABLE ACTS AND THERE I
THINK ONE HAS TO ARGUE. THAT
MAYBE WE DO NEED TO STEP IN
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE THE
RIGHT YOU DON'T THE PRIVILEGE.
OF INJURING SOMEONE ELSE'S
CHILD. LET'S KEEP THAT IN MIND
WE DON'T HAVE THE PRIVILEGE TO
INJURE SOMEONE ELSE'S CHILD.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT. THANK YOU. SO I
APPRECIATE THAT ARE YOU JUST IN
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT BECAUSE
BASICALLY. MY COLLEAGUES AND A
LOT OF THE PARENTS THAT THAT
OPPOSE THIS BILL I THINK THAT
THERE IS NO MANNER OR MECHANISM
IN TWO. AT MEDICAL EXEMPTION
AND THE REASON WHY IS BECAUSE
THEY RECENTLY THERE WAS A
SURVEY DONE OF EIGHT HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO CALIFORNIA
PEDIATRICIANS WHO RECENTLY WERE
SURVEY BY PHONE. THAT ASKED
WHAT WOULD BE A STANDARD OF
CARE MEDICAL EXEMPTION AND NONE
OF THEM COULD COME UP WITH ONE
SO AS A PHYSICIAN. IN YOU IS
THE AUTHOR IN YOUR INTENT AND
YOU WITH YOUR MEDICAL
BACKGROUND I GUESS MY QUESTION
TO YOU IS AS A PHYSICIAN IN
YOUR OWN. THOUGHT AT YOUR
INTENT WHAT WOULD BE A STANDARD
OF CARE EXEMPTION FOR A FAMILY
TO BE ABLE TO GET A MEDICAL
SAYS. EXEMPTION FOR A MEDICALLY
FRAGILE CHILD. WELL ACTUALLY
THERE ARE MANY REASONS FOR
GETTING SENSE AND I'M NOT GOING
YEAH I DON'T KNOW THAT I SPEND
THE TIME HERE GOING THROUGH
EVERY SINGLE OPPORTUNITY. WE'RE
GOING TO ASK YOU TO REFRAIN
FROM YELLING IN THE CHAMBER YOU
WILL BE REMOVED. DOCTOR PAN SO
I APOLOGIZE WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO MATTER MISTER
PRESIDENT. IF YOU YELL AGAIN
AND DISRUPT THE HOUSE AND
DISRUPT THE DECORUM OF THE
HOUSE I WILL SIT DOWN AND NOT
ANSWERED GET THE QUESTIONS
ANSWERED THAT I THINK ARE VITAL
THAT YOU GUYS NEED TO
UNDERSTAND. SO PLEASE RESPECT
THE DECORUM OF THE HOUSE SORRY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO FIRST
OF ALL I WOULD FIND OUT THAT WE
STARTED WITH A SAID THE CDC.
GUIDELINES AND WE ADDED THE
AMERICAN JACQUI AS A GUIDELINE
SO SAMPLES MENTIONED BY. MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM MARCH COUNTY
ANAPHYLAXIS RIGHT IF YOU OF
YOUR CHILD'S HAD AN
ANAPHYLACTIC REACTION OR IS
ALLERGIC TO WE HAPPEN TO DOES
ALLERGIC TO COMPONENT VACCINE.
GALLAGHER NEW MEDICAL EXEMPTION
IF YOU HAVE A SEIZURE AFTER
YOUR D. TAP VACCINE AND WE CAN
ADD THAT A FIVE THE CAUSE OF
THE SEIZURE. RADIO COMPLEX
EASIER THAT WOULD MARCH YOU A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION IF YOU HAVE
FAMILY MEMBERS IN THE FAMILY
MEMBERS TO OUR AND YOUR TOP
PRIZE FOR THE MMR AND VARICELLA
VACCINE DECK INTERVIEW MEDICAL
EXEMPTION. I WOULD ALSO POINT
OUT AGAIN THAT YOUR- SAID AGAIN
STANDARD OF CARE SO SOME PEOPLE
SAID WELL IN ADVANCE OF A VERY
RARE. CONDITION AND I WOULD SAY
IS THAT IF IT'S WITHIN REASON.
THE BOARD WILL SAY THAT YOU GET
MEDICAL SENSE OF SAMPLES YOU
ACTUALLY GOT CHICKEN POX BEFORE
YOU GOT VACCINATED. YOU'LL GET
A MEDICAL EXEMPTION RIGHT
BECAUSE YOU'RE A GOT THE
DISEASE YOU DON'T IF THERE'S
EVIDENCE THAT YOU HAD THE
DISEASE AND NOW YOU. THEN YOU
DON'T NEED TO GET THE MUSICIAN
FACT I MYSELF OF WRITTEN
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS FOR THAT
VERY REASON. AND I'M CERTAINLY
NOT CONCERNED ABOUT THAT BEING
UNDER SCRUTINY BY THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH WHICH
I WOULD POINT OUT. THIS REALLY
IS A PUBLIC HEALTH MATTER
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HAVING TO
REVIEW DONE BY THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH THE ACTUAL REVIEW
OF. VACCINATIONS AND THE NEED
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC IS THE
VENUE IS THE CHARGE OF THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HOUSE. AND SO
AGAIN THOSE ARE JUST SOME
EXAMPLES TO ENSURE WE CAN COME
WITH MANY OTHER EXAMPLES AS
WELL. OF REASONS WHY SOMEONE
WOULD I GET A MEDICAL EXEMPTION
AGAIN THAT'S WE HAVE A THAT'S
WHY WE CREE HAVE THE FARM
PUBLIC HEALTH. WHO DOES CONTAIN
YOU KNOW DO HAVE EXPERTS THEIR
PHYSICIANS AND NURSES. WHO ARE
KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT PUBLIC
HEALTH INFECTIOUS DISEASE IN
FACT WE TRUST THEM. TO FOLLOW
PEOPLE WITH HIV WITH STDS.
OTHER KINDS OF CONTENT
INFECTIOUS DISEASES THEY ARE
THE ONES WHO ARE CALLED OUT TO
HELP OUT. IN OUTBREAKS WHETHER
IT'S HEPATITIS C. MEASLES. AND
TYPHOID ANYTHING ELSE THEY ARE
VERY KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT THAT
AND IF WE DON'T LIKE THEIR
DECISION TO GO SO BOARD OF
PRACTICING PHYSICIANS. WHO SAY
IS THIS A REASONABLE THING TO
DO. AND IF IT IS THEN THE
EXEMPTION WILL BE APPROVED AND
SO I THINK THAT. WE ACTUALLY
CREATE A FAIRLY BROAD
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO GET
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS IF DANGER
YOU I ONLY NEED ONE. I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT I ACTUALLY
BELIEVE THAT THE BOARD WILL.
ESSENTIALLY SAY THAT IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTION. THERE'S ANY
QUESTION SOMEONE NEEDS A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION AND THAT THE
THERE'S A NICHE. THAT BASICALLY
A RULE IN FAVOR OF THE FAMILY.
RIGHT SB IF THAT IS SO YEAH
LET'S BE BLUNT. IF SOMEONE SAYS
WELL I WANT AMERICANS ACTION
BECAUSE MY CHILD HAS AUTISM.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN
BECAUSE WE HAVE. CONSIDERABLE
RESEARCH TO SHOW THAT THERE'S
NO ASSOCIATION BETWEEN THE TWO.
HOWEVER IF YOU HAVE ANY IF
THERE'S EVEN A QUESTION THAT
THERE MIGHT BE AN ASSOCIATION
BETWEEN TWO. I THINK SIR THE
AYE. I THINK THE INCLINATION
WOULD BE TO SAY YOU KNOW WHAT
THAT'S WHAT WE WILL WE WANT TO
OPERATE IN THE BENEFIT OF THE
PARENT AND THE CHILD. THANK YOU
I JUST. WANTED TO FOLLOW UP ON
THE WHOLE FAMILY HISTORY OR IF
YOU HAVE HIS STORY YOU'RE- A
SPECIAL DISEASE CDC
CONTRADICTION IS NOT ALLOWED
UNDER STANDARD OF CARE FOR
MEDICAL HISTORY. SO I THINK
EVEN USING MEDICAL HISTORY. AND
IF THAT'S NOT TRUE I'D LOVE FOR
YOU TO TELL ME WHAT IS TRUE
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN CONTACTED BY
THE- I ASKED THE CDC AND HE
SAID. THAT IS NOT COVERED THAT
MEDICALLY STREETS NOT COVERED
AS THE CDC CONTRADICTION. WHICH
MAKES A LOT OF THE FAMILIES
VERY VERY NERVOUS. THAT ARE IN
THE BACK IN THE GALLERY AND
WATCHING ONLINE BECAUSE- IF
THEY HAVE A CHILD THAT HAD AN
ADVERSE REACTION TO IT IS. TO A
VACCINE ONE OF THE SEVENTY TWO.
THAT WE INJECT OUR CHILDREN
WITH THEM. SO WHEN WE HAVE
THOSE VACCINES INJECTED AND YOU
HAVE A CHILD THAT HAS A MEDICAL
HISTORY. AND IS MEDICALLY
FRAGILE LIKE AUTO WHO CAME TO
TESTIFY. AT THE HEARING THAT WE
HAD IN HEALTH COMMITTEE. WHERE
HE WAS AN AVERAGE EVERYDAY
WONDERFUL TODDLER AND THEN
AFTER A VACCINE. HAD ISSUES
WITH THE SPINAL CORD HIS OCKLEY
AT I A NERVES. AND NOW HE'S IN
A WHEELCHAIR SO. I MEAN I GUESS
WHERE DO WE DRAW THE LINE ON
HIS CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT IN HIS
PARENTS NOT TO. APPLY A VACCINE
TO HIS SIBLINGS IN THE FUTURE.
BECAUSE OF THE ADVERSE REACTION
THAT HE HAD. SO THERE IS THAT.
ANOTHER THING THAT KIND OF
BOTHERS ME THAT I BROUGHT IT
IN. CAN BE AS WELL AS IT THERE
WAS A HOOPING COUGH OUT OUT
BREAK. WESTLAKE SCHOOL I DON'T
REMEMBER THE NAME OF THE SCHOOL
I APOLOGIZE. AND NOT ONE IT
WAS. MET THE VACCINE RATE THAT
YOU HAVE IN THIS BILL FOR YOUR
AMENDMENTS IT MET THE VACCINE
RATE OF 95% THE SCHOOL DID. AND
THE ONES THAT GOT THE WHO
PICKOFF. OUR KIDS WERE
ACTUALLY. EXITED THE AN
ACCIDENT CHILDREN DID NOT GET
THE WHO BEEN COUGHING WHEN I.
WOULD BE COVERED WHEN I ASKED
YOU ABOUT. COMMITTEE YOUR EXACT
RESPONSE WAS. THE VACCINE.
WORKS THE WAY TO THE BACK AND
IS SUPPOSED. BURKE. I DON'T
AND- I DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT
AND I APOLOGIZE AND- AND AGAIN.
I WOULD ASK FOR A NO VOTE AND I
THINK THE PRESIDENT'S. SINCE
YOU KNOW WHEN YOUR PARENTS THAT
THEY FEEL. FROM THE DEPTHS OF
THEIR SOUL THAT THEY'RE
FIGHTING FOR THEIR CHILDREN'S
LIFE. AND THEIR EXISTENCE TO BE
HAPPY HEALTHY KIDS AND ADULTS.
I AM I WOULD EXPECT A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT BURST I WOULD NEVER
CONDONE AND I CAME OUT WITH A
PRESS RELEASE. ABOUT YOU BEING
ATTACKED BUT I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THAT INDIVIDUAL IS NOT
PART OF THIS GROUP. HE HE IS.
HE IS SOMEONE WHO DISAGREES
WITH THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT I HAD
COUNTLESS PEOPLE REACH OUT TO
ME. I POSTED THE PRESS RELEASE
ON FACEBOOK. AND SEVERAL PEOPLE
CAME OUT THAT OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THAT DENOUNCED WITH THAT MAN
DID TO YOU. SO IT'S NOT
EVERYBODY THAT'S UP IN THE
GALLAGHER WATCHING AGAIN THESE
PEOPLE ARE FIGHTING WHAT THEY
BELIEVE FROM THE DEPTHS OF
THEIR SOUL AS A PREVENTATIVE.
DETRIMENTAL HARM TO THEIR
CHILDREN AND SO THAT'S WHY
THEY'RE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
AND SO ON MY. THANK YOU SENATOR
SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I. OFFICIATE
ON THE DEBATE I'M ON WAS STRUCK
BY THE REPEATED REFERENCE TO
PERSONAL FREEDOMS. AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT ALL OF US THAT
WE- NOT CHAU BOAT. BUT ON THE
FLOOR ON THE RED CARPET THAT WE
HAVE HONEST CONSISTENT
CONVERSATION. BELIEVE IN TERMS
OF RESPECTING EACH OTHER HAS
RESPECT SHOULD BE HAS TO BE
EARNED. SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
PERSONAL FREEDOMS. A WOMAN'S
RIGHT TO CHOOSE. END OF LIFE
OPTION ACT. WHEN WE ARE THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY HAVE TAKEN
POWER AWAY FROM THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH BECAUSE WE KNOW BETTER
ABOUT SENTENCING CRIMINALS AND
SO WE'VE VOTED ON HUNDREDS OF
SINCE ENHANCEMENTS. THE HELMET
REQUIREMENT LAW SEAT BELT LAW.
MINIMUM DRINKING AGE VOTING AGE.
AND SO AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY WE
DEBATE. PERSONAL FREEDOMS ON A
REGULAR BASIS THIS IS NOT BRAND
NEW AND WE SHOULD NOT ACTIVE
SUCH. WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
A COLLECTIVE ONE TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND THAT'S THE
FUNDAMENTAL POINT. THIS SERIES
OF BILLS THE PROTECTION OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IS IT EASY NOW.
ARE THESE DEBATES IMPORTANT IS
IT IMPORTANT FOR US TO FLESH
OUT FACT FROM FICTIN YES ARE
THESE EMOTIONAL ISSUES YES. ALL
OF US ARE US WHO ARE PARENTS
SHOULD UNDERSTAND THAT. AND AS
A PARENT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
ME THE SERVICE BUDGET YEAR AND
FOCUS ON THE BUDGET FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND HOW
MANY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF THE
TWO A TO FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET ARE DIRECTED TOWARDS
CHILDREN. ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
FOR EVERYBODY'S CHILD.
EDUCATION FUNDING EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION FUNDING PULLING
AND LIFTING CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN NOT A DEEP POVERTY.
THOSE ARE CRITICAL ISSUES THAT
WE ALL SHOULD GIVE EQUAL AN
IMPORTANT FOCUS AND ATTENTION
TO. EVERYBODY. AND SO AS WE
TALK ABOUT MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THE
PEDIATRICIAN DR PAN YOU CAN'T
STAND HERE GIVEN THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE EMPOWERED PHYSICIANS TO
USE THEIR EDUCATION AND
DISCRETION. AN OPINION BASED ON
THE FACTS OF AN INDIVIDUAL CASE
TO DETERMINE THAT I'M GLAD
WE'VE EMPOWER THEM TO DO THAT
AND I'M NOT GOING TO ASK YOU TO
GIVE YOUR DEFINITION. KIND OF
IN. GENERAL I WOULD WANT YOU TO
LOOK AT AN INDIVIDUAL CASE AS A
PEDIATRICIAN LOOK AT MY FAMILY
HISTORY AND MAKE THE DECISION
AND IF EIGHT HUNDRED AND SOME
ODD POSITIONS DIDN'T KNOW THAT
THEY HAD THAT POWER THAT
CONCERNS ME AND WE SHOULD TALK
ABOUT WHAT COMES AFTER THIS
BILL IN MAKING SURE THAT THE
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER NETWORK
ACROSS THE STATE UNDERSTANDS
LAW. AND UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY
ARE EMPOWERED AND EXPECTED TO
DO TO DELIVER HIGH QUALITY
SERVICES TO THE CHILDREN IN
THEIR CHARGE. THAT'S THE NEXT
PART APPARENTLY THE EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SOME ODD APPEAR TO
BE CONFUSED IN THIS SURVEY.
QUESTION OF THE OFFER MISTER
CHAIRMAN MISTER PRESIDENT.
SENATE PANEL IS A QUESTION OF
COURSE. I WOULD LIKE FOR YOU TO
WALK THROUGH FOR ME ONE MORE
TIME SIR I THINK ABOUT THIS
QUESTION OF YOU THE TIMES I'VE
HEARD IN COMMITTEE. BECAUSE I
WANT TO MAKE SURE I'M CLEAR
BEFORE I CAST MY VOTE TODAY ON
THE FLOOR. IN MY EFFORT TO
REPRESENT THE CONSTITUENCY AYE
SIR. AND TO DO MY DUE DILIGENCE
AROUND PUBLIC HEALTH FOR ALL
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WALK ME THROUGH HOW
AN EXEMPTION CAN BE. RECEIVED
IF YOU WILL WHAT IS THAT STEP
BY STEP PROCESS BECAUSE I HEAR.
MY COLLEAGUES TALK ABOUT IT'S
AN ARDUOUS PROCESS I WHEN HERE
FOR MYSELF WHAT THE STEPS ARE
IF YOU WILL. THANK YOU
BASICALLY NOR DO YOU GET A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION THE UNDER
THIS BILL PHYSICIAN. I WOULD
INTENT OF MAY HAVE IDENTIFIED
IN ADDITION TO TAKING CARE OF
THAT THE. SHOULD NOT BE
IMMUNIZED FOR THAT THE
PARTICULAR CONDITION AND
THEREFORE SAY WELL SINCE YOU'RE
ENTERING SCHOOL. WE NEED TO
GIVE YOU A MEDICAL EXEMPTION SO
YOU CAN CONTINUE ENTERED SCHOOL
THAN THEY WOULD FILE A- FORM
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH THEY WOULD SELL
BASICALLY SAYING WHO THE
PATIENT IS. CERTIFYING THAT
DEALT WITH THEIR ON THEIR
PRIMARY CARE DOCTOR OR I CAN
INFORM YOUR PRIMARY CARE DOCTOR
DONE. FILING AN EXEMPTION FOR
THEM AND THE REASON FOR THE
EXEMPTION. AND THEN AT THAT
POINT THAT WOULD GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH. THAT
WOULD BE REVIEWED BY THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS A NURSES AND
DOCTORS IN FACT I WOULD SAY IS
THAT. IT'S APPROVED BRIAN NURSE
WILL SAY IT'S APPROVED AND
WE'RE DONE IT IT'S IF THE PART
OF THE CELTS AS WELL. WE'RE A
LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT IT. I'M
SURE WILL BE REVIEWED BY A
PHYSICIAN AND THEN AT THAT
POINT IN TIME IF THE PART OF
PUBLIC HEALTH SAYS THAT. THE
AGREED DATE THEN EXEMPTION IS
YOU HAVE THE EXEMPTION. A BY
THE WAY I SHOULD ALSO MENTION
THAT WHILE IT'S GOING THROUGH
THIS PROCESS YOUR CHILD HAS
THAT MEDICAL ATTENTION ENGINE
CONTINUE ATTENDING SCHOOL. OKAY
SO SOON YOU THIS IS YOUR TURN
IT AND BY THE FALL YOU GET THE
MEDICAL SECTION. THEN WHAT
HAPPENS IS THAT IT IS REJECTED.
THEN YOU'LL BE NOTIFIED. AND
THEN YOU CAN SAY WELL ACTUALLY
I DISAGREE. THIS FINDING. AND
THEN YOU CAN APPEAL TO THE
PANEL AS  MENTIONED THAT WAS
TAKEN UP IN THE AMENDMENTS. AND
THEN THAT PANEL WILL THEN ABOUT
WHAT YOU CAN PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THE FAMILY AND THE
PHYSICIAN COULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FAT INFORMATION TO
THE PANEL. AND THEN THEY WERE
REVIEW. AND IF THEY REVIEW THEY
SAY THAT SOMETHING VISIBLE
PHYSICIAN WOULD DO THEN THEY
WILL APPROVE IT. AND YOU'RE
SET. IF THEY ALSO DECLINE THEN
WHICH THAT CASE AFTER THAT
POINT. YOU ACTUALLY HAVE THIRTY
DAYS. AND WHICH YOUR CHILD CAN
STILL ATTEND SCHOOL. WITH
MEDICAL EXEMPTION BUT THEN AT
THAT POINT TIME EITHER WILL.
DECIDE TO GET YOUR CHILD
VACCINATED OR YOU CAN CHOOSE TO
WORK WITH THE SCHOOL TAKE AN
INDEPENDENT STUDY OF PUBLIC
FUNDS PUBLICLY FUNDED
EDUCATION. OR YOU CAN CHOOSE TO
HOME SCHOOL THOSE OF THE
OPTIONS AT NO POINT TIME WOULD
YOU BE REQUIRED. TO MANDATED TO
VACCINATE YOUR CHILD AGAINST
HER WILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE CLARIFICATION. I THINK
SOONER CENTER MONEY. I THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
WANT TO START BY THANKING
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE AGREED ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF HOW WE ENGAGE
IN CIVIL DISCOURSE HOW WE
ENGAGE IN TOUGH LEGISLATION I
APPRECIATE THOSE WHO HAVE LED
WITH THAT RECOGNITION I ALSO
APPRECIATE THOSE HERE WHO ABIDE
BY THAT SAME COMMITMENT TO
CIVIL DISCOURSE. IN YOUR HERE.
BECAUSE THEY CARE ABOUT WHAT
THEY FEEL TO BE BEST FOR THEIR
CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES.
BUT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE
AMENDMENTS WHICH ARE ON THE
FLOOR TODAY. BECAUSE THEY DO
NOT PREVENT A MEDICAL EXEMPTION
THE AMENDMENTS BEFORE US TODAY
DO NOT PRE VENT A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION. AND I DO WANT TO
ADDRESS BRIEFLY THE NOTION BY
SOME WHO OPPOSE THIS THAT WERE
INTERFERING WITH PERSONAL
FREEDOM. PERSONAL FREEDOM IS
NOT ABSOLUTE. WE AS A
LEGISLATURE SAY YOU CAN'T GO
THROUGH A RED LIGHT BECAUSE IT
ENDANGERS PUBLIC SAFETY WE SAY%
YOU CAN'T EXCEED THE SPEED
LIMIT BECAUSE IT ENDANGERS
PUBLIC SAFETY. I HAVE
CONSTITUENTS IN MY DISTRICT.
HAVE SAID THEIR PERSONAL
FREEDOM HAS BEEN CHALLENGED
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A CHILD WITH
AN AUTO IMMUNE DISEASE OR IN IN
THE PROCESS OF RECEIVING CANCER
TREATMENTS WERE THEIR IMMUNE
SYSTEM HAS BEEN. ADVERSELY
IMPACTED THEY CAN'T SEND THEIR
CHILD TO THE PUBLIC SCHOOL THAT
THEIR TAXES ARE SUPPORTING
BECAUSE THE IMMUNE RATE THE
VACCINIA VACCINATION RATE AT
THAT PUBLIC SCHOOL HAS DROPPED
IN SOME CASES THE 70% OR BELOW
SO THEIR PERSONAL FREEDOM THAT
I WAS ALSO ELECTED TO PROTECT
IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH THAT I WAS
SELECTED TO PROTECT WE'RE
TELLING THEM YOU'RE PAYING
TAXES TO SEND YOUR CHILD TO
THAT PUBLIC SCHOOL BUT BECAUSE
OF THE EXERCISE OF PERSONAL
BELIEF. NOT MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
THAT CONSTITUENT IS HAVING
THEIR PERSONAL BELIEFS AND
THEIR RIGHT TO PUBLIC HEALTH IN
A SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR THEIR
CHILD TO BE EDUCATED THAT'S
BEING ABRIDGED THIS BILL SEEKS
TO FIND THAT BALANCE I BELIEVE
THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
ENGAGEMENT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IN THE CRAFTING THESE
AMENDMENTS. AND IT'S
ARTICULATED BY THE AUTHOR.
PROVIDE A PATH. WHERE A FAMILY
IN THEIR PHYSICIAN CAN DISCUSS
WHETHER THEIR CHILD SHOULD BE
AFFORDED A MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
AND AS SOON AS THAT DR GRANT
SAT MEDICAL EXEMPTION. IT. IT
ENGAGES A FURTHER PROCESS WITH
OUR DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
BUT THAT CHILD IMMEDIATELY HAS
THAT MEDICAL EXEMPTION SO
THERE'S CHECKS AND BALANCES
THEY INDEED PROTECT. PERSONAL
RIGHTS OF ALL CONSTITUENTS OF
ALL STUDENTS IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
PERSONAL BELIEF PROTECTIONS
COLLEAGUES. THEY ARE NOT
ABSOLUTE IF THE EXERCISE OF
YOUR PERSONAL BELIEFS. THE
BRIDGE IS THE RIGHT OF MY CHILD
TO GO TO A CLASSROOM THAT WE
HAVE TRIED TO PROTECT AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE THROUGH THE USE OF
SCIENCE. ANY USE OF
IMMUNIZATIONS TO MAKE OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE I URGE AN AYE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS BEFORE
US ON CONCURRENCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN. I
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT WHEN
IT WHEN THIS BILL FIRST GAME
BUT BEFORE THE FLOOR ON ITS
INITIAL PASS. I ROSE IN SUPPORT
BUT WITH SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
SOME OF THE ISSUE THURMOND
DISCUSSION FOR HERE TODAY
AROUND FAMILY MEDICAL HISTORY
SPECIALLY COVERAGE OF
AUTOIMMUNE DISORDERS AND
WHETHER THE CDC GUIDELINES WERE
EXPANSIVE ENOUGH. FIRST OF ALL
I APPRECIATE DESPITE THE.
VIOLENT RHETORIC AND THREATS
YOU FACE. AS AN AUTHOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO REACH AND
STRETCH A BIT THROUGH THE
AMENDMENT PROCESS I APPRECIATE
ALSO MY COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE. AND EVERYONE
WHO HAS CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
BILL. SETTING SOME STANDARD
DECORUM HERE EVEN THE ADVOCATES
WHOSE SO VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE IT.
WE CAN'T ACCEPT VIOLENCE AS OUR.
AS OUR CURRENCY IN OUR POLITICS
WERE ABOVE THAT. BUT I DO WANT
TO THANK THE COUNTLESS
CONSTITUENTS WHO VISITED IN MY
OFFICE AND SAT WITH ME FOR MANY
HOURS IT EDUCATING ME ABOUT.
THEIR CONCERNS THEIR HOPES
THEIR FEARS INTRODUCING ME TO
THEIR KIDS. A LOT OF VERY
STRONG MOMS IN PARTICULAR.
BEHIND THIS EFFORT AND IT'S
BEEN MOVING. BECAUSE OF SOME
THAT EDUCATION I STILL DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS AND WAS
ENCOURAGED TO HEAR THAT THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE ENGAGING ON
THIS EFFORT TO MAKE SOME
TECHNICAL CLARIFICATIONS THAT I
THINK WILL MAKE THIS BILL
WORKABLE AND MAKE SURE THAT NO
CALIFORNIAN IS FORCED TO
VACCINATE THEIR CHILD IF IT'S
GOING TO CAUSE THAT CHILD HARM.
PERIOD THAT SHOULD NOT BE
SOMETHING THE GOVERNMENT FORCES
UPON A PERSON HERE. AND I
BELIEVE THAT IS YOUR INTENT DR.
I HAVE SOME. SOME OF THOSE
TECHNICAL ISSUES THAT. STILL
pBE ADDRESSED AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. THE TRIGGER OF FIVE
EXEMPTIONS PER YEAR FOR ONE
DOCTORED TO CALL THAT
EXCESSIVE. FEELS A LITTLE
ARBITRARY FOR ME. BUT I THINK
THERE'S ROOM TO WORK ON THAT.
THE 95% IMMUNITY RATE THAT
TRIGGERS THAT A THAT REVIEW I'M
I KNOW THERE ARE SOME SOME
TECHNICAL ISSUES TO WORK OUT
THERE. AND I KNOW THAT THIS
ISSUE STANDARD OF CARE IS
ACTUALLY QUITE A MEANINGFUL
ENHANCEMENT OF WHAT WE HAD
PRIOR BUT THERE IS STILL.
DISCRETION THAN THAT NOW CITY
PH WON'T HAVE CARTE BLANCHE TO
MAKE IT UP OR DOWN VOTE. ON A
FAMILIES VERY PERSONAL
DECISION. THAT THEY WILL. HAVE
NOW THE CONSULTATION OF DOCTORS.
AND ABIDING BY SOME STANDARD
CARE THAT. EXCEEDS THE SORT OF
OBJECTIVE AND RIGID STANDARDS
SO. I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
MEASURE TODAY BUT WITH THE
HOPES THAT IT IN THE SUBSEQUENT.
WE CAN HALF THAT WE'VE GOT HERE
THAT WE CAN MAKE SOME PROGRESS
IN REALLY REALLY FOLLOW THROUGH
ON THOSE ASSURANCES THAT WERE
MAKING A PARENTS AROUND THE
STATE. WHO HAVE LEGITIMATE.
CONCERNS AND WELL FOUNDED FEAR
WHEN THINGS COME IN SACRAMENTO
THAT THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND.
THAT THE INTENT OF THIS
LEGISLATURE'S NOT TO GET
BETWEEN YOU AND YOUR DOCTOR ARE
YOU AND YOUR CHILD IT'S TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE AS A COMMUNITY ARE
SAFE. WE TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
SERIOUS MEDICAL ISSUES. BUT
THAT A PREFERENCE IS NOT
ENOUGH. THAT A PERSONAL BELIEF.
IS SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH THAT THERE
HAS TO BE SOME MEDICAL BASIS.
SO I'M HOPING WE CAN FIND THAT
THAT LANDING SPOT I KNOW THIS
IS BEEN HARD. BUT MOST OF ALL I
JUST I APPRECIATE WITH THESE
BODIES DONE TODAY IN THE
DEBATE. AND CHECKING OURSELVES
IN MAKING SURE THIS A PLACE
WHERE WE CAN FEEL SAFE TO MAKE
GOOD PUBLIC POLICY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER GALGIANI.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR I
INITIALLY DIDN'T SUPPORT THE
BILL BECAUSE I WANTED TO INSURE
THAT THERE WAS SOME SORT OF A
TEAM TASK FORCE. THAT WOULD BE
ABLE TO REVIEW APPEALS. I WILL
BE VOTING FOR THE BILL TODAY
BUT I WISH TO EXPRESS ONE LAST
CONCERNED THAT I DO THINK IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. THE PART
THE AMENDMENT WITH REGARD TO
ADD A PHYSICIAN AND THAT HAS
FIVE OR MORE EXEMPTIONS. MY
FEAR IS THAT. THIS MIGHT CREATE
AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE I'M A
PHYSICIAN WOULD BE HAS A TENT.
TO GRANT AN EXEMPTION AND I
THINK THAT WE OUGHT TO LOOK AT
IT IN A DIFFERENT LIGHT. MY
COUSIN IN ARIZONA IS A
PHYSICIAN WHO IS AN EXPERT. ON
VALLEY FEVER AND HE IS ONE OF
THE FEW IN THE NATION WHO HAS
STUDIED VALLEY FEVER FOR
DECADES IT HAS BEEN HIS LIFE'S
WORK. I BELIEVE THEY'RE
PROBABLY PHYSICIANS OUT THERE
WHO ARE. MUCH MORE EXPERT IN
THIS AREA THAN OTHERS ARE AND I
WOULD THINK THAT IF I WAS OF A
FAMILY APPARENT TO HAD A CHILD
THAT I WAS WORRIED ABOUT. THAT
I WOULD SEEK OUT AN EXPERT. WHO
HAS MORE KNOWLEDGE IN THIS
FIELD THEN AN AVERAGE DOCTOR.
AND I THINK THAT THAT PARENTS
SHOULD BE ENCOURAGED TO SEE
THOSE EXPERTS AND I THINK THAT
THOSE EXPERTS SHOULD BE A. B.
SHOULD BE ENCOURAGED TO. DELVE
INTO THIS ARENA AND TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE FAMILIES. SO
THAT MEDICAL ADVANCEMENTS ARE
MADE AND SO THAT WE DO BETTER
UNDERSTAND. THOSE SITUATIONS
THOSE MEDICAL EXCEPTIONS THAT
DEALING WILL EXIST AND I ASSUME
THAT THERE WILL BE SOME THAT WE
CAN'T PREDICT WITH THIS
LEGISLATION. AND THAT WE WILL
NEED TO RELY ON THE MEDICAL
EXPERTISE OF THOSE PHYSICIANS
WHO HAVE THE COURAGE TO GRANT
MORE THAN FIVE EXEMPTIONS AND
WE SHOULD. MEET THEM WITH THAT
SPIRIT SO I WOULD ASK THAT
GOING FORWARD. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALAN. I JUST WANTED THE
WHOLE HEARTEDLY ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS MADE
IN THE LAST TWO SPEAKERS THE
CENTERS FROM WITH THE HOUSE AND
FROM STOCKTON. JEAN ALL DEBATE
HAVING TO SEIZE. DOCTOR PAN AND
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
MEMBERS AS AS ONE THANK
EVERYONE FOR THE FOR THE
DISCUSSION I ALSO WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE AND FOR THE
EXPRESSIONS OF SUPPORT. AROUND
OUR CIVIC DIALOGUE. AND AGAIN
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT. LET ME
JUST MAKE A FEW NOTES BASED ON
SOME THE COMMON PEOPLE MADE ON
THE BILL AND PARTICULARLY THE
AMENDMENTS SO FIRST OF ALL I
WOULD MAKE NOTES AND I WANT TO
THANK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS
ANGELES FOR ASK ABOUT THE
PROCESS FOR EXEMPTION I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT ALSO THAT
PROCESS ONLY ACTUALLY CHECKS
IN. IF THEY'RE ATTENDING SCHOOL
UNDER 95% OR THE PHYSICIAN HAS
WRITTEN MORE THAN FIVE
EXEMPTION SO IN OTHER WORDS IF
THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES IRONTON
PLAY THEY WERE TO TURN
EXEMPTION AND EXEMPTION WOULD
NEED TO BE REVIEWED AND THAT
WOULD BASICALLY BE THOUSAND SO
IFYOU'RE ATTENDING A SCHOOL
WHERE THE NIGHT YOU HAVE A 95%
OR ABOVE WHICH MEANS WE HAVE.
TO MEDIUM UNITY WE'RE NOT
WORRIED ABOUT THE SAFETY NOT A
PROBLEM RIGHT SO WHAT BUT IT
WON'T BE ME GOING THROUGH THE
WHOLE REVIEW. PROCESS THE OTHER
THING I WOULD MAKE NOTE AND I
APPRECIATE. BUT ALSO I KNOW MY
COLLEAGUES ARE THEY'RE NOT
AFRAID OF REVIEW. OKAY AND IN
FACT I WOULD POINT OUT THAT IN
TERMS OF SPECIALISTS THE
ONCOLOGISTS TO ACTUALLY WOULD
BE IN A POSITION PERHAPS RIGHT
MORE THAN FIVE THE ALLERGIST
IMMUNOLOGIST TO TAKE CARE OF
SOME WITHOUT IMMUNE DISEASE
THEY SUPPORT THE BILL. THEY'RE
NOT CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SCRUTINY. THEY WELCOME IT.
BECAUSE IT'S THEIR PATIENTS WHO
ARE ENDANGERED WHEN SOMEONE
ELSE WRITES AN APPROPRIATE
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS THAT'S WHY
THEY'RE FINE WITH IT. NOW WE
WANT TO REVIEW MY EXEMPTIONS
I'M GOOD WITH THAT. AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED TO
KEEP IN MIND. I WOULD ALSO WAS
MENTIONED ABOUT THE MEDICAL
BOARD. THE MEDICAL BOARD WHAT'S
THIS BILL THEY HAVE VOTED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY THEY HAVE NOT
BEEN GIVEN THE TOOLS TO BE ABLE
TO DO THE KIND OF
INVESTIGATIONS TO GO AFTER IS
PEOPLE SOME PEOPLE SAY THE BAD
DOCTORS OF THE DOCTORS ARE
ABUSING THEIR- AUTHORITY AND SO
THE MEDICAL BOARD WANTS US TO
PASS THIS BILL SO THEY CAN
ACTUALLY ACT AND DO THEIR JOB.
I WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE OF THAT
YOU KNOW. WE ALL WANT FREEDOM
WE WANT TO FEED ON THE ABOUT BE
ABLE TO GO ABOUT OUR
COMMUNITIES IN THE SAFE NOT
WORRY ABOUT HAVING TO CATCH A
DANGEROUS DISEASE OURSELVES.
OUR CHILDREN ARE BABIES. WE ALL
WANT THE FREEDOM TO BE ABLE TO
SEND THEIR KIDS TO SCHOOL AND
NO THEY'LL BE SAFE AND SO THIS
BILL AGAIN IS ABOUT BEING SURE
THAT THE CHILDREN WHO REALLY
NEED THE MEDICAL SENTIENCE AND
THEREFORE CANNOT BE VACCINATED
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES IF THEY
HAVE THE PROTECTION OF THE
OTHERS IN THE SCHOOL. AND SO I
THINK WE TALK ABOUT FREEDOM WE
NEED TO TALK ABOUT THE FREEDOM
OF ALL FAMILIES AND ALL
CHILDREN SO AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR OFFICE AND I
THINK THE ASSEMBLY FOR WORKING
TO. CRAFT THE AMENDMENTS THAT
MAKES IT MORE TARGETED. THAT
ADDRESSES MANY OF THE ISSUES
THAT PEOPLE TALK TO ME ABOUT. I
AM AGAIN AS I MENTIONED IN MY-
OPENING STATEMENT ABOUT YOU
KNOW. WILLING TO OF COURSE WORK
WITH THE GOVERNOR AND OTHERS TO
BE SURE YEAH WE DO
IMPLEMENTATION. WE WANT TO BE
SURE THAT THE CHILDREN DON'T
THERE'S QUESTIONS FROM THE
EXPERTS RIGHT. THAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE THE PANEL DOING STANDARD
OF CARE THAT THAT GIVES THAT
FLEXIBILITY. TO SAY YOU KNOW
WHAT THIS IS UNUSUAL SITUATION
WE DON'T. WITH THERE'S
UNCERTAINTY AND IN THAT
UNCERTAINTY WE WANT THE- CHILD
IN THE FAMILY. TO BE THE ONES
THAT WE ROOM FAVOR US. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE WILL
INTENTIONALLY CREATED THAT
FLEXIBILITY WITH THE APPEALS
PANEL AND THAT AND THE
FLEXIBILITY THERE. SO WITH THAT
AGAIN WHY THANK EVERYONE FOR
THE DISCUSSION. AND I SUSPECT
WE ASK. FOR AN AYE VOTE
CONCURRENCE WITH ASSEMBLY AND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
BATES NOBEL HI PORGES NO
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO. HI
CHIANG. NO DALLY NO DODD HI
THERE ALSO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER BY GONZALEZ HI GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
TITLE. HI. JACKSON BY JONES. NO
LEYVA HI MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
AYE MONNING BY MORE LUCK NO
MORALE NO NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. RUBIO HI
SKINNER I STERN BY STONE.
NUMBER HI WHAT COUNTY BY WINNER
BY WILK NO. THE SECTOR PLEASE
CALL OUT TO MEMBERS WITH SO I.
ROTH. ALL RIGHTS TWENTY EIGHT
NOS ELEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN. RIGHT MEMBERS
WERE NOW
. WE'RE GOING TO ASK
FOR THE QUORUM IN THE CHAMBERS
WERE ASKING YOU TO. WERE ASKING
FOR TO QUORUM. WE'RE ASKING FOR
SILENCE IN THE CHAMBER. WE WILL
BE REMOVING YOU FROM THE
CHAMBER. MEMBERS WILL CALL IN A
FIVE MINUTE RECESS
. OUR MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL BE MOVED
TO FILE ITEM FIFTEEN GOVERNMENT
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS MADAM
PROTIUM ARE YOU PREPARED TO
TAKE UP THE SIDE OF. YES.
MISTER TERRY PLEASE READ ALWAYS
I'M SORRY THAT THE REGISTER.
MANSON FOR TIM WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
DOCTOR LINDA DARLING HAMMOND TO
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
WHERE SHE'S CURRENTLY SERVING
AS THE BOARD PRESIDENT HE'S
ALSO THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
THE LEARNING POLICY INSTITUTE
AND THE STEERING COMMITTEE
CHAIR FOR THE TEACHER EDUCATION
PROGRAM IS STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
SHE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JULY THIRD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THOSE. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS.
HEARING CHAIN NONE MR KERRY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA BY ATKINS AYE BATES.
BILL GORGEOUS. BRADFORD HI
KELLY YELLOW. JANE DALY DODD.
THERE ARE SO. GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ HI GROWTH
HERTZBERG. HI HILL. HI HUESO BY
DATO. JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA BY
MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL. HI MONNING
HI MORE LUCK WELL. NIELSEN. PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. BY
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE NO I'M BURKE BY KATHY. HI
WIENER AYE WILK. THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBERS.
BATES BELL. GORGEOUS. CABALLERO
HI JANE. DALLY. DODD BY THE
RUSSELL. GROWTH GROW BY. TITLE
HI JONES. MOORLACH MORRELL NO
NIELSEN. I'M BURKE I HAVE BY
WILK HI. THE PROTO MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS NEXT ITEM IS MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE WILL BE
DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS FROM COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. NOW MOVING TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
THERE ARE FOUR MEMBERS AT THE
DESK THERE WILL BE DEEMED
ADOPTED. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. NOW'S THE TIME TO
PULL ANY ITEM THAT YOU MOVED
FROM THE AGENDA. TO THE
INACTIVE FOLLOW ARE THERE ANY
SENATOR HUESO. MISTER PRESIDENT
I'D LIKE TO AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE AB
TWELVE FORTY EIGHT TO THE ENACT
THE FILE DOES WILL NOTE. ANY
ADDITIONAL SENATOR MITCHELL.
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR I
ASK THAT FILE ITEM ONE NINETEEN
AB SEVENTEEN OH NINE BE MOVED
TO THE ENACT THE FILE. THE DOES
WILL NOTE. SACRAMENTO AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR DOING IT.
I ASK THAT FILE ITEM TO TWELVE
AB. ONE ZERO ZERO SEVEN BE
MOVED TO THE INACTIVE FILE THIS
WOMAN. IN ADDITION MOTIONS
RESOLUTION SEEN NINE MORE WENT
DORADO SENATOR ALSO THANK YOU
CENTER MITCHELL I HAVE. UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR AUTHOR
ASSET FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE ONE
SEVEN A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM BE MOVED
TO THE INACTIVE FILE. THIS WILL
NOTE. CONSIDERATION DAILY FILE.
SEKARANG FILE WAS SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL A
TWENTY FOUR WITH THE MOMENT
FIVE THIRTY NINE WITH THE
MEMBERS TWELVE FIFTY FIVE AT
THE MOMENT FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE WITH MOMENTS SENATE BILL
640-725-6250. THREE TEN SIXTY
ONE THIRTY SECOND READING WILL
BE DEEMED READ. THANK YOU.
WE'RE MOVING NOW THIS THIRD
READING. WE HAVE ITEM FORTY
SEVEN. CENTER LIVE ARE YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE UP THIS ITEM.
WELL WAIT A MOMENT. ARTS CENTER
AND AT LAKE WAS PREPARED FOR
THE SITE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE RESOLUTION
FIFTY FIVE A SENATOR LEYVA
RELATIVE TO THE UNITED STATES
WOMEN'S NATIONAL SOCCER TEAM.
SENATOR LABEL FOR GEORGE THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS AS A PRO
CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT RESOLUTION SENATE
RESOLUTION FIFTY FIVE
RECOGNIZING AND SUPPORTING THE
US WOMEN'S NATIONAL SOCCER TEAM
IN THEIR HISTORIC WIN AND ALSO
IN THEIR FIGHT FOR PAY EQUITY
AS YOU MAY ALREADY KNOW BY
SECURING THEIR LATEST WIN IN
FRANCE THE US WOMEN'S SOCCER
TEAM BECAME THE FIRST TEAM IN
HISTORY TO WIN THE WOMEN'S
WORLD CUP. FOUR TIMES THIS YEAR
ON INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY
THE TEAM FILED A CLASS ACTION
SUIT AGAINST THE U. S. SOCCER
FEDERATION DEMANDING EQUAL PAY
FOR SUBSTANTIALLY EQUAL WORK
THE WOMEN'S TEAM IS PAID ABOUT%
A QUARTER OF WHAT THE MEN'S
TEAM IS PAID DESPITE PERFORMING
SIMILAR JOB DUTIES FOR THE SAME
EMPLOYER AND OUTPERFORMING THE
MEN. IN THEIR FIRST WORLD CUP
GAME THIS YEAR THE WOMEN SCORED
EIGHTEEN GOALS NOT ONLY DID
THAT SET A RECORD FOR THE
NUMBER OF GOALS IN ONE GAME
THEY ALSO SCORED MORE THAN THE
US MEN'S TEAM HAS SCORED IN
EVERY WORLD CUP SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIX COMBINED. IT'S
ABOUT TIME THAT WOMEN ARE GIVEN
AN EVEN PLAYING FIELD LITERALLY
EMPATE TRAINING TRAVEL
CONDITIONS AN EQUAL PROMOTION
OF THEIR GAMES WE COMMEND THE
TEAM FOR USING THEIR PLATFORM
TO UP WITH WOMEN AND GIRLS
AROUND THE WORLD WITH ITS
LAWSUIT THEY'RE FIGHTING FOR
ALL YOUNG GIRLS THE FIRE TO BE
JUST LET THEM. WITH A MEMBER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ANY ADDITION TO BET ON THIS
ITEM. THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES HI BILL BY
BURGESS I BRADFORD I CAN BE AT.
I CHIANG BY DAILY DOT BY THEIR
ALSO. I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW I HERTZBERG. I
HILL AYE HUESO I TACO I JACKSON
BY JONES. BY LEYVA. MCGUIRE
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
HI MONNING BY MORE LUCK. MORALE
BY NELSON I PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER
AYE STERN. I STONE. I AM BURKE
I WOULD COUNTY. I WINNER BY
WILK HI. GENERALLY WILL MOVE
THE CALL. MEMBERS WE NOW ARE
MOVING TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING OUR FIRST ITEM UP IS
ITEM ONE THREE TWO SENATOR BILL
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM.
HE IS MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
FIFTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WALDRON AN ACT RELATING TO
MENTAL HEALTH SENATOR BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THIS BILL BRINGS
BROADER COMMUNITY IMPACT
PERSPECTIVE TO THE LOCAL MENTAL
HEALTH BOARDS IN EACH COUNTY
WITH THE ADDED BENEFITS OF
INCREASING TRANSPARENCY AND
INPUT FOR THE COMMUNITY. AS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION I REGION I VOTE ON
THIS MEASURE IT WILL HELP
IMPROVE AND STRENGTHEN OUR
LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH BOARDS
THANK YOU. ANY DESCRIPTION OF A
ON SIGNS HEARING SEEN NONE THIS
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES BY BILL. BY BURGESS I
BRADFORD I CAN BE AT ALL I
CHIANG I DALY. DODD HI THERE
ALSO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO I TACO I JACKSON.
I JONES. BY LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
AYE MITCHELL AYE MONNING BY
MORE LOCK I AM A REAL AYE
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH I RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE BY OBERG I
WOULD COUNTY I WINNER. I WILK
HI. YOUR BILL MOVES A CALL NEXT
UP MEMBERS IS ITEM ONE THREE
SIX SENATOR JONES ARE YOU
PREPARED YES SIR HE IS READY
MISS SECTOR PLEASE RATE
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SEVENTEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DEEP AN ACT
RELATING TO VEHICLES. SENATOR
JONES. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT AB
THIRTEEN I AM SORRY AB THREE
SEVENTEEN. OF WHICH I'M A PROUD
CO AUTHOR THIS BILL WILL MAKE
THE SALE OF DMV APPOINTMENTS
UNLAWFUL. AS WE ARE ALL WELL
AWARE. FROM HEARING FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND OUR FAMILIES
IT'S HARD TO GET A DMV
APPOINTMENT NOWADAYS. AND
OAKLAND BASED COMPANY IS MAKING
THAT APPOINTMENT EVEN HARDER TO
GET. THEY HAVE FOUND A WAY TO
PROFIT OFF OF A FREE GOVERNMENT
SERVICE WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
BLOCKING OUR CONSTITUENTS FROM
GETTING THE APPOINTMENTS THEY
NEED. EMPLOYEES OF THIS. FIRM
SCOUR DMB WEBSITES FOR
APPOINTMENTS BOOKING AS MANY AS
POSSIBLE THEN THEY TURN AROUND
AND SELL THE TIME SLOT TO
CALIFORNIANS WHO JUST NEED TO
USE THE GOVERNMENT SERVICE
THEMSELF. THE DMV IS ALREADY
IMPACTED DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
SUCH AS THE TRANS TRANSITION TO
REAL ID'S. SO MUCH SO THAT LAST
YEAR GOVERNOR BROWN VETOED ALL
BILLS REQUIRING ANYTHING
ADDITIONAL THE DMV. THIS
COMPANY IS CAPITALIZING ON THAT
BY FORCING PEOPLE WHO CAN
AFFORD IT TO PAY FOR
APPOINTMENTS. THAT THIS PRIVATE
ENTITY IS KEEPING SECRETIVE.
FOR THOSE OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
IT CAN AFFORD TO PAY CAN'T
AFFORD TO PAY THE PREMIUM THEY
ARE FORCED TO WAIT UP TO MONTHS
FOR AN AVAILABLE APPOINTMENT.
KEEPING THEM OUT OF PUBLIC
OFFICE THAT IS MEANT TO HELP
THEM MEMBERS I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON AB THREE SEVENTEEN.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SO I DON'T.
KERN TEEN NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES HI
BILL BY BURGESS I BRADFORD BY
CAMBIADO I CHIANG AYE DALLY
DODD HI THERE ALSO AYE GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ BY GROWTH
AYE HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO BY OUR TITLE I JACKSON. I
JONES I LEYVA. I'M MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL. HI MONNING. I'M MORE
LUCK. MORRELL. BY NIELSEN AYE
PAN. I PORTANTINO I ROTH HI
RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE BY NUMBER VIA CASSIE BY
WINNER BY WILK HI. THE SOONER
JONES MOVES THE CALL NEXT UP
MEMBERS IS ITEM ONE FIFTIES
THERMAL GO ARE YOU PREPARED MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. CENTER REQUIRED FLOORS
YOURS THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
PRESIDENT NICE JOB TODAY SIR
RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN SIXTY ON BEHALF OF THE
HARD WORKING ASSEMBLY WOMAN
FRIEDMAN. THIS BILL REVISES THE
DEFINITION OF A MAJOR TRANSIT
STOP TO INCLUDE HIGH QUALITY
BUS RAPID TRANSIT THIS BILL HAS
HAD NO OPPOSITION IN. NO NO
VOTES IN HAS BROAD SUPPORT
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE.
IN ADDITION THE DISCUSSION A
BIT ON THE SIDE OF. HEARING
CHANGE. WHO'S WHO IN A GROSS
I'M SORRY IN A ROW THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT A QUESTION THE
AUTHOR. HE TOOK QUESTION CENTER
MCGUIRE. ITEM AND ITEM LATER
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU OF COURSE.
WHAT IS THE DEFINITION OF HIGH
QUALITY OF RAPID TRANSIT. THANK
YOU MADAM LATER. IT CURRENTLY
DOES NOT INCLUDE. MISTER
PRESIDENT AT THIS IS A
WONDERFUL QUESTION. I TRUST YOU
AND I AM GOING TO WORK WITH THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER TO BE ABLE TO
GET HER A SPECIFIC DEFINITION
OF HIGH QUALITY. YES IT IS
THANK YOU I WILL WORK WITH YOU
ON GETTING A FORMAL DEFINITION
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH
BETTER LEADER. THE
DISINTEGRATION OF THE AUTHOR.
CONSIDERED REQUIRE WHICH ELECT
CLOSE WITHIN THE DREAM I MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
I'LL BE IN THAT SPECIFIC
DEFINITION DOWN TO WERE ABLE TO
PLAY JEOPARDY TOGETHER HERE I
IS THIS THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
PRESIDENT OF SPEC LASSEN I'VE-
THE Q. SECTOR PLEASE CALL
WORLD. ALLEN I ARCHULETA. AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BILL I
PURCHASE BY BRADFORD I CAN BE
AT ALL I TING I DALY DODD. BY
THE RAZA. I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW BY
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE OR TITLE. HI JACKSON I
JONES I LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE. HI
MITCHELL. HI MONNING I'M MORE
LUCK I'M REAL. I NIELSEN AYE
PAN. BY PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. I AM BURKE IOWA CASSIE.
I WIENER AYE WILK HI. SENATE
MCGUIRE MOVES A CALL NEXT UP IS
ITEM ONE FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
THE. ALL ONE FIFTY ONE I'M
SORRY. WITH ONE FIFTY ONE BUYS
A SENATOR GONZALEZ I'M SORRY.
YES MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE READ
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
I'M SORRY ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS AN ACT RELATING TO
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. GONZALEZ
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING AB
SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT LOW INCOME
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE OF COLOR IN
DURING A DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE
OF ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION AND
PUBLIC HEALTH HAZARDS. WHERE
THEY LIVE WORK AND PLAY THESE
FROM MY COMMUNITIES OFTEN LACK
RESOURCES AND OPPORTUNITIES TO
COMBAT ENVIRONMENTAL HARMS ARE
DENIED A VOICE IN KEY DECISIONS
THAT AFFECT THE QUALITY OF
THEIR LIVES AB EIGHT SIXTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT. REVISE THE
DEFINITION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE TO INCLUDE MEANINGFUL
INVOLVEMENT TO ENSURE THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES HAVE A RIGHT TO BE
MEANINGFUL LEE INVOLVED IN
DECISIONS THAT AFFECT THEIR
LIVELIHOOD. AS A SPONSORED Y
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE IT HAS NO
OPPOSITION CURRENTLY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION YOU
BET ON THE SIDE ON. HEARING
SHEEN ON THE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL I
PURCHASED NO. BRADFORD ARC HI
CAMBIADO. I CHIANG I DALY DOT.
BY THE RAZA I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE TITLE. I JACKSON. I JONES
NO LEYVA BY MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL.
BY MONNING BY MORE LUCK. NO
MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO. I
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER. I WORK OWSKI. I
WINNER BY WILK BY. JENNER
GONZALEZ MOVES A CALL NEXT UP
IS ITEM ONE FIFTY TWO BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM YES MISS
SECTOR PLEASE ROUTE ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE TWENTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC WORKS. THIRD FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB FIVE TWENTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASH KALRA WHICH
DEFINES WHEN A PUBLIC SAYS
SUBSIDY IS TO MINIMUS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF DETERMINING. IF THE
PREVAILING WAGE APPLIES PRIVATE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS USING
PUBLIC FUNDS. UNDER CURRENT LAW
THE TERM DE MINIMUS IS NOT
DEFINED AND STATUES TO THERE'S
NO SPECIFIC GUIDANCE FOR
INDUSTRY OR REGULATORS AS TO
THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF PUBLIC
SUBSIDY. THAT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED BY THE MINISTER. AND
THIS IS LED TO MANY ISSUES OF
LITIGATION. THIS BILL SPECIFIES
THAT A PUBLIC SUBSIDY ON A
PRIVATE PROJECT IS DE MINIMUS
SO LONG AS IT IS LESS THAN FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND
LESS THAN 2% OF THE TOTAL
PROJECT COST RECENT AMENDMENTS
EXAMPLE CONSTRUCTION OF SINGLE
FAMILY UNITS FROM THE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
THRESHOLD AND AS A REMINDER OUR
STATE'S PREVAILING WAGE LAWS.
ALREADY EXEMPTS ANY
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS FOR LOW OR
MODERATE INCOME RESIDENTS THIS
BILL DOES NOTHING TO CHANGE
THAT EXEMPTION. UNDER CURRENT
LAW AND MEN SKEWS ME IT AND
MAINTAINED UNDER THIS BILL NO
DEVELOPER IS REQUIRED TO TAKE A
PUBLIC SUBSIDY OVER THE DE
MINIMUS AMOUNT IF THEY DO NOT
WANT TO PAY THE PREVAILING
WAGE. IN CLOSING AB FIVE TWENTY
WILL CLARIFY THE PROCESS FOR
DETERMINING WHEN PREVAILING
WAGES APPLIED. THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
ABOUT. THANK YOU SENATOR STONE
ON THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THIS IS A PRIME
EXAMPLE OF THE LEGISLATURE
TALKING OUT OF BOTH SIDES OF
ITS MOUTH. WE KNOW WE HAVE AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THIS BILL IS NOT GOING TO DO
ANYTHING TO MAKE HOUSING MORE
AFFORDABLE. EXPAND THE COVERAGE
OF THE PREVAILING WAGE I'M
PRIVATE DEVELOPMENTS RECEIVING
MINIMAL MINIMAL PUBLIC
SUBSIDIES BY LOWERING THE
AMOUNT OF PUBLIC SUBSIDY THAT
WILL TRIGGER THE LAWS
APPLICATION AS A PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECT SPECIFICALLY THE AMOUNT
OF THE PUBLIC SUBSIDY
TRIGGERING. THE COVERAGE
REQUIRED WOULD BE GENERALLY
LOWER THAN BOTH LESS THAN FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
LESS THAN 2% OF THE PROJECT'S
COST THE BILL ALSO SPECIFIES
THAT A PUBLIC SUBSIDY FOR A
PROJECT. CONSISTENCY CONSISTING
ENTIRELY OF SINGLE FAMILY
DWELLING UNITS IS DE MINIMUS IF
LESS THAN 2% OF THE TOTAL
POTTER PRODUCTS COST. AB FIVE
TWENTY CODIFIES IT FOR PROJECT
RECEIVED A PUBLIC SUBSIDY IN
THE AREA OF FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND IS LESS
THAN 2% OF THE TOTAL PROJECT
COST EMPLOYERS. WILL BE
REQUIRED TO PAY PREVAILING
WAGE. WHICH OF COURSE IS GOING
TO PASS ON TO THE CONSUMER IN
HIGHER HOUSING COSTS. THIS IS
AN ILL CONCEIVED POWER GRAB BY
LABOR UNIONS AT THE EXPENSE OF.
ALL CALIFORNIANS. CALIFORNIA
HAS A HOMELESS PROBLEM AND A
HOUSING CRISIS ADDING MORE
COSTS ON TO THE ALREADY HIGH
COSTS AND FEES MANDATED ON
DEVELOPMENT. AND CONSTRUCTION
WILL ONLY MAKE OUR CRISIS WORSE.
FOR EVERY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
YOU INCREASE THE PRICE OF A
HOME FIFTEEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS CAN NO LONGER
AFFORD TO BUY THAT HOME.
EXTRAPOLATING AT THE TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN A FIGURE
GOES UP TO A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS THAT WILL
NOW NOT BE ABLE TO FURTHER.
AFFORD A HOME IN THE GOLDEN
STATE. PASSAGE OF AB FIVE
TWENTY WILL MEAN A DEAD AND TO
THE AMERICAN DREAM FOR TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
INSTEAD OF FINDING A HOME. HOW
MANY WILL END UP ON THE STREETS
EXACERBATING. ONE OF THE
LARGEST HUMANITARIAN CRISES.
THE NOT ONLY OUR STATE IS
WITNESSED BUT OUR COUNTRY IS IN
DURING. AB FIVE TWENTY NOT ONLY
ONE PACK ACOSTA BUILD HOMES BUT
THE CONSTRUCTION OF APARTMENTS
PLAYGROUNDS PARKS AND SCHOOLS.
STATE OFFICE BUILDINGS
COMMUNITY CLINICS PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AND- AND SO MUCH
MORE. AB FIVE TWENTY WILL
DELIVER A SEVERE BLOW TO THE
SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZE
CONTRACTORS STRUGGLING TO GROW
THEIR BUSINESSES. AND THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT THEY CAN
EMPLOY. MANY OF THE SMALLER
BUSINESSES ARE MINORITY OWNED.
IF YOU CARE ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESS IF YOU WANT TO GROW
JOBS AND HELP SOLVE OUR HOUSING
CRISIS THE VOTE TO MAKE IT
EASIER AND LESS EXPENSIVE TO
BUILD MORE HOUSING DON'T MAKE
IT HARDER AND MORE EXPENSIVE.
YOUR VOTE TODAY IS GOING TO
DETERMINE WHETHER YOU SUPPORT
THE UNIONS IN THIS STATE OR
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT THE
CONSTITUENTS ARE STRUGGLING TO
AFFORD THE AMERICAN DREAM OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP YOUR BILL WILL BE
RATHER TRANSPARENT AND VERY
CLEAR. FOR THOSE REASONS I URGE
A NO VOTE ON EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY.
SENATOR LEYVA. OKAY I DIDN'T
WRITE I DIDN'T BREAK IT UP
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT AND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM TO MAKE YOU A KNOWS
THAT THIS IS NOT ABOUT UNIONS
ALTHOUGH I ALWAYS SUPPORT
UNIONS BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
WHEN PEOPLE MAKE A LIVING WAGE
THEY CAN BUY A HOUSE AND THEY
DON'T HAVE TO GO ON PUBLIC
SUBSIDIES BUT BACK TO THIS BILL
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS THIS BILL
IS GOING TO DO ONE THING AND IS
GOING TO CLOSE A LOOPHOLE
BECAUSE THIS LOOPHOLE HAS
ALLOWED DEVELOPERS. WHO HAVE
RECEIVE PUBLIC SUBSIDIES THAT'S
MONEY THAT WE HAVE PUT OUT
THERE FOR THEM RANGING FROM
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND TWO FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION WHICH
EQUATES TO POINT 5% OR ONE
POINT 75% OF THE TOTAL COST OF
A PARTICULAR PROJECT AND THEY
ARE NOT THEN REQUIRED TO PAY
PREVAILING WAGE SO ALL THIS
DOES IS CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE SO
THAT EVERYONE HAS TO ABIDE BY
THE LAW I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
ASK A QUESTION OF THE- FOR
MANAGER FOR ME. THE QUESTION.
OKAY SO WHERE I QUESTION IS ARE
WE HEAR THAT IS ABOUT SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES IN THIS IS GOING
TO WASH DEVELOPMENT OF SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES THIS BILL OF FOUR
APPLY TO THE BUILDING OF SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES DOES NOT IT'S
EXEMPTED VERY GOOD THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR MORAL.
ALL YOU DOWN OKAY SENATOR
BORDERS. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT JUST TO POSE A
QUESTION TO THE FLOOR MANAGER.
CENTER GONZALEZ WITH HER
QUESTION. THANK YOU IN
REVIEWING THIS PROPOSED PEACE
LEGISLATION I WAS HOPING THAT
MAYBE YOU MIGHT OFFER WHAT IS
THE RATIONALE OR THE COMPELLING
NEED FOR THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. WELL WE'VESEEN
THAT WITH MAJOR DEVELOPMENT
HAPPENING IN AND MANY OF OUR
CITIES WE KNOW THAT WHEN PUBLIC
SUBSIDIES TAX DOLLAR PAID TAX
UP HERE DOLLARS ARE. UP
PROVIDED UPWARDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WE DON'T GET ANY
COMMUNITY BENEFITS NOR DO WE
HAVE LOCAL HIGHER OR ANY TYPE
OF PROVISIONS TO REALLY
SAFEGUARD GOOD. WAGES ON THESE
JOBS SO THIS IS WHY WE'RE
BRINGING THIS FOR TODAY TO CAP
THAT WHAT IS THE CURRENT
THRESHOLD THAT WOULD TRIGGER
PREVAILING WAGE THERE IS NO
CURRENT WELL. THERE'S A TWO
PERCENT BUT THERE IS NO CAP ON
THE DOLLAR AMOUNT. ALRIGHT SO.
IN A TOTALLY WERE HEARING THAT.
THERE'S MAJOR DEVELOPMENT
OCCURRING THAT IS NOT TO THE
BENEFIT OF THE COMMUNITY WORK
TO. THE TAXPAYERS THAT'S
CORRECT AND I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT IF A DEVELOPER DOES NOT
WANT TO PAY PREVAILING WAGE YOU
NEED NOT APPLY FOR PUBLIC
SUBSIDIES. ONE FINAL QUESTION
SO IF DOLLARS ARE CONTRIBUTED
FROM A PUBLIC ENTITY THROUGH A
PASS THROUGH ORGANIZATION LIKE
AN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION IS THAT ALSO DOES
THAT. STATUS OF MONEY STILL
REMAIN IF THE IF THAT ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ENTITY CONTRIBUTES
TO A MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
PROJECT OR SOME OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE IT'S ONLY A
STATE AGENCY THAT WOULD. BUT
EVERY UNIQUE EVERY SITUATION IS
UNIQUE BUT IT WOULD MOSTLY BE A
STATE AGENCY THAT WOULD QUALIFY.
SO IT'S ONLY A STATE AGENCY
RIGHT I MEAN AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION COULD
BE YOU KNOW A BUSINESS
IMPROVEMENT DISTRICT IT COULD
BE SOMETHING COMPLETELY
SEPARATE FROM THE STATE
AGENCIES SO. UNLESS THERE'S ANY
STATE FUNDING. OR STATE AGENCY
RELATED TO THIS THAT WOULD NOT
APPLY IT FORGIVE ME FOR
BELIEVER IN THIS AS ONE MAKE
CERTAIN I UNDERSTAND CIVIC
CENTER TO BORDERS YOU HAVE
DEBATE TO OFFER. WONDERSTRUCK
UNDERSTAND IF THE STATE OF IF
STATE DOLLARS FIND THEIR WAY
INTO MUNICIPALITY MUNICIPALITY
FINDS ITS WAY TO ANOTHER
RELATED ENTITY WHICH THEN FINDS
WAY TOWARD PROJECT. IS THE
COLOR OF THAT MONEY STILL.
CONTINUE WITH THE FLOW OF THAT
MONEY AND. HE CONSIDERED A
PUBLIC A PUBLIC INVESTMENT. THE
NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS A DAUGHTER
SAID IN YOUR CALL. I WAS
INTERESTED IN THE LOS AGENCYOR
STATE DOLLARS BEING USED AND
YES IT WOULD BUT IT JUST
DEPENDS. AND HOW AND WHAT
FORMAT I MEAN THERE'S VARIOUS
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
OFFERED SO. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR GALGIANI. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND NOT
ONLY DO I SUPPORT PREVAILING
WAGE I'VE ALSO SUPPORTED LOCAL
HIGHER PROVISIONS THAT MIGHT
LOCAL LEVEL BECAUSE IT ENSURES
THAT WE EMPLOY INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE DOING THE WORK THEN ARE
ALSO PAID A SALARY OR WAGE
WHERE THEY'RE ACTUALLY ABLE TO
BUY ONE OF THE HOMES OR
RESIDENCES APARTMENTS OR RENT
FROM THOSE PLACES WHERE THEY'RE
ACTUALLY DOING THE BUILDING
THIS IS ABOUT ENSURING A
LIVABLE WAGE A PREVAILING WAGE
IS A POSITIVE THING IT ENSURES
THAT WORKERS ARE ABLE TO LIVE
AND THRIVE IN A COMMUNITY AND
CONTRIBUTE ECONOMICALLY TO THAT
COMMUNITY AND I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT. THANK
YOU SENATOR BILL YES I THINK
IT'S BASICALLY ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT YOU BELIEVE IN PREVENTING
WAGE OR NOT I MEAN THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE SO FOR
ME FOR MAY MY CONSTITUENTS WANT
TO SEE ME VOTE FOR LIVABLE WAGE
FOR PEOPLE PREVAILING WAGE AND
GET FAIR PAY FOR THEIR WORK IF.
SOMEBODY COMES IN WITH THEIR
HAND OUT AND ASKED FOR SOME
KIND OF GOVERNMENT SUBSIDY THIS
IS IMPORTANT JOB PRINCIPLE THAT
I BELIEVE IN. AND ALWAYS HAVE
OUR CHEN AYE VOTE. SENATOR GIRL.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
WE HAVE A SERIOUS HOMELESS
PROBLEM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND PART OF THAT IS
THE BIG MAJORITY OF THAT IS A
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY 53% OF
CALIFORNIANS BELIEVE THAT THEY
CAN NO LONGER AFFORD TO LIVE
HERE IF YOU TAKE THAT TO THE
MILLENNIAL AGE 63% OF THEM
BELIEVE THEY CAN OF NO LONGER
AFFORD TO LIVE HERE HOUSING
COSTS HAVE GONE UP DRASTICALLY
IT'S ALMOST THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. FOR A ONE BED A MONTH
FOR A ONE BEDROOM APARTMENT IN
SAN FRANCISCO IT'S VERY AND
AFFORDABLE TO LIVE IN THIS
STATE AND TO ADD ADDITIONAL
COST ON TO THE HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION I GET THAT
SOMEBODY MAKING A LIVING WAGE
PREVAILING WAGE WILL BE ABLE TO
AFFORD THESE HOUSES BUT THOSE
PEOPLE ALREADY LIVING IN HOMES
THAT THEY OWN AND SO THE NEW
HOUSING THAT WE BILL TO BE
BUILT FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
WITHOUT OR WITHOUT A HOUSE NOW.
WHEN YOU I COME IN ON TWELFTH
STREET WHEN I CAME IN FOR MY
HOME THAT I'M OUT OF HERE AND I
SEE THE HOMELESS CAMPS AND ONE
DAY I WALKED THROUGH THERE AND
I MET A LOT OF PEOPLE AND TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU GUYS THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE IN THAT CAMP THAT
WERE NEVER GOING TO BE ABLE TO
GET OUT OF THOSE CAMPS THEY FOR
WHATEVER REASON CHOOSE TO LIVE
THAT WAY BUT THERE IS A TREND
THAT LOST HIS WIFE AND HE QUIT
WORKING HE LOST HIS HOME. THERE
IS A THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT LOST
THEIR JOB THAT LIVES THERE
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
BUY A HOME THAT CAN AFFORD TO
BUY A HOME BECAUSE THEY MAKE
AND NOT ENOUGH MONEY AND
HOUSING IS WAY OF FOR
UNAFFORDABLE SO THE IDEA THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO ADD ADDITIONAL
COST ON THE PRICE OF BUILDING A
HOME IS THIS COMPLETELY
BACKWARDS COMPARED TO. WHAT'S
GOING ON OUR STATE WITH
FORCIBLY CRISIS. THAT WE HAVE
NOW. I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR ANY OF IT. YOU SEE NO FOR
DISCUSSION SENATOR BATES. THANK
YOU MISS RATHER TOM I DO RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS AND WHAT
SEEMS TO BE LOST IN THE DEBATE
IS WHAT WILL OUR HOME IS A HOME
SINGLE FAMILY CERTAINLY BUT
MULTI FAMILY IS LAW NOT
EXEMPTED FROM THIS THE WAY I
READ THE BILL AND CURRENTLY THE
COST PER SQUARE FOOT OF MULTI
FAMILY IS ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A SQUARE FOOT.
TO BULD A MULTI FAMILY THAT
WOULD CERTAINLY WITH PREVAILING
WAGE BEING REQUIRED ON THAT
THAT COSTS WILL GO UP IN
CERTAINLY FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
NEED THOSE FORMS THEY ARE GOING
TO BE PRICED OUT OF THE MARKET
EVEN IF WE GIVE THEM A LIVING
WAGE A LIVING WAGE HOUSE TO
INCREASE. EXPONENTIALLY TO MEET
THE COSTS THIS BEING PUT ON THE
BUILDING OF A HOME AND I
CONSIDER MULTI FAMILY THE MOST
IMPORTANT HOMES THAT WE CAN
BUILD THESE DAYS THAT'S WHERE
PEOPLE GET THEIR STARTER TO GET
INTO PRIVATE HOMEOWNERSHIP SO I
WOULD LIKE US TO RETHINK THIS
ARE A FOR GOING TO BE EXEMPTION
CERTAINLY MULTI FAMILY OUGHT TO
BE PART OF THAT. BECAUSE THAT
IS REALLY WHAT'S. NEEDED IN OUR
STATE SO I URGE A NO VOTE ON
THIS. THANK YOU. SEEN NO
FURTHER DESCRIPTION OF BAIT
SENATOR GONZALEZ WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE YES I JUST WOULD LIKE
TO REITERATE. THIS DOES INCLUDE
ALL PUBLIC AGENCIES SUCH AS FOR
CLARIFICATION. SOME ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATIONS ARE
PRIVATE PUBLIC BECAUSE THEYSO
IS GETTING THAT IN MY HEAD BUT-
LASTLY AGAIN EXEMPTIONS FOR
SINGLE FAMILY EXEMPTIONS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS FOR
LOW AND MODERATE. THE PER UNIT
COST HAS NOT BEEN SUBSTANTIATED
SO WE DON'T KNOW FOR SURE AND
WE DON'T. WE CAN'T QUANTIFY
WHETHER HAS ACTUALLY WILL
INCREASE OUR COSTS AND IN FACT
WE DON'T THINK IT WILL BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MANY BENEFITS THAT.
DEVELOPERS ALREADY RECEIVED AND
AGAIN IF THEY ARE NOT
INTERESTED IN RECEIVING OR
SORRY FOR PAYING A PREVAILING
WAGE THAN THEY NEED NOT APPLY
FOR. PUBLIC SUBSIDIES. AT AND
THAT IS THE END OF IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE SIDE.
ALLEN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS BY
BATES NOBEL I PORGES NO
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO I CHIANG.
DALY NO DOT. HI THERE ALSO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER HI GONZALEZ.
I GROW NO HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE
HUESO AYE TADO HI JACKSON BY
JONES. NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. HI MONEY BY MORE LOCK
NO MORALE NO NIELSEN NO PAN. BY
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE. NO
AMBERG IOWA CASSIE I WIENER AYE
WILK. SECTOR PLEASE CALLED UP
TO MEMBERS ALLEN BY. CHIANG
WILK. WELL NO. PRICE TWENTY
NINE KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE
PASSES. CENTER GONZALEZ YOUR
FOR THE THIRD TIME ONE FIFTY
THREE. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS MISTER
TERRY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL AN ACT RELATING
TO RESIDENTIAL RENTAL PROPERTY
INNER GONZALEZ THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I'M
PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JESSE GABRIEL WHICH WILL
MAKE IT EASIER FOR LANDLORDS
AND TENANTS TO ALLOW AN
INDIVIDUAL AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS TO TEMPORARILY
RESIDE. ON THEIR PROPERTY THIS
BILL WAS INSPIRED BY
RESEARCHERS AT UCSF. OF
IDENTIFIED TEMPORARY HOUSING
WITH FAMILY OR FRIENDS AS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO ENABLE
INDIVIDUALS AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS TO SECURE SHELTER
SEE RESOURCES REGROUP AND
SEARCH FOR A MORE PERMANENT
OPTION FOR HOUSING AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT SIX TO FACILITATE
THIS PROCESS BY PROTECTING
TENANTS WHO WHICH THAT WISH TO
TEMPORARILY HOUSE A FAMILY
MEMBER OR FRIEND AND PROVIDES A
LEGAL FRAMEWORK THAT WILL
INCENTIVIZE BOTH LANDLORDS. AND
TENANTS TO ASSIST PERSONS AT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS ZERO OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR EITHER. OKAY ANY
DISCUSSION OF IT ON THE SIDE
ON. JUNE TWO NINE MS SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
HI BILL I PORGES AYE BRADFORD
AYE CAMBIADO I CHIANG AYE DALY
AYE DODD. HI THERE ALSO. I
GALGIANI. I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ.
I GROW I HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO AYE TITLE I JACKSON I
JONES. BY. LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
AYE MITCHELL. HI MONNING I'M
MORE LUCK. I'M A REAL BY NELSON.
PAN BY PORTANTINO HI ROSS. I
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. HI NUMBER. BYE BYE
CASKEY BY WINNER. I WILK. HI
RECEPTOR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. NIELSEN. ICE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS ITEM ONE FIFTY SIX
BY SENATOR ON BURGER YOU
PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM I AM AS
PRESIDENT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE ROUTE I'M GONNA ASK THE
MEMBERS IN IT BACK IN THE-
GALLERY TO KERR KEEPER VOICES
DOWN FOLKS PLEASE. THE NUMBER.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW RELATIVE TO CIVIL RIGHTS.
CENTER I'M BURKE FLORA. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NINETY NINE WRITTEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW IN OTHER
LGBT Q. ADVOCATES AS WELL AS
EVANGELICAL CHRISTIAN LEADERS
THIS MEASURE CONCERNS
CONVERSION THERAPY CONVERSION
THERAPY IS A DISCREDITED IN IN
HEART AND A HARMFUL. BOTH
METHOD IN THEORY. OF TRYING TO
CONVERT ONE'S GENDER IDENTITY
OR SEXUAL ORIENTATION. IT'S
BEEN DISCREDITED BY NUMBER OF
BOTH PSYCHOLOGISTS AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATIONS.
EACH OF US COMES TO THIS
CHAMBER EACH OF US COMES THE
LEGISLATURE WITH THEIR OWN
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES WE CAN'T
DIVORCE OURSELVES FROM THOSE
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES.
IRRESPECTIVE OF HOW ANECDOTAL
THEY MAY BE AND SO I BRING MY
OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE I BRING
THE PERSONAL EXPERIENCE OF MY
FAMILY. AND WHAT CONVERSION
THERAPY DID TO ONE OF MY-
RELATIVES MY BROTHER IN LAW THE
HARM CAUSED HIM MY LATE BROTHER
IN LAW IN THE HARM THAT IT
CAUSED OUR FAMILY. BY TRYING TO
SHAME HIM BY TRYING TO CREATE
SOME SORT OF BEHAVIORAL
MECHANISM. TO CHANGE HIS SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. IT CREATED
TREMENDOUS DEPRESSION.
DEBILITATION AND DISCORD IN THE
FAMILY. THIS RESOLUTION IS A
SIMPLE RESOLUTION IT DOESN'T
DICTATE THAT ANYBODY DO
ANYTHING IN PARTICULAR BUT WHAT
IT DOES IS IT HIGHLIGHTS THE
HARM. IT CAN BE CAUSED BY
CONVERSION THERAPY IT
HIGHLIGHTS THE FACT THAT WE ALL
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROTECT THE RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS THE
CALIFORNIA AND WHAT THIS. DOES
IN REAL TIME TO NOT JUST
MEMBERS THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY BUT
TO ALL OF US HIRED AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER SENATOR. THIS.
THIS MATTER AND THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT ON THIS MATTER
CAME BEFORE JUDICIARY AND IT
WAS A VERY IS A VERY
INTERESTING DEBATE. I DON'T
KNOW MUCH ABOUT CONVERSION
THERAPY. ON THE AND I DO HAVE A
LOT OF FRIENDS WHO ARE MEMBERS
OF THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY. AND
THEY HAVE VERY STRONG MANY OF
THEM HAVE VERY STRONG FEELINGS
ABOUT THIS TYPE OF TREATMENT.
AND I'M GOING TO TAKE THEIR
WORD ON THAT IT IS NOT BEEN
HELPFUL BUT I WILL JUST SIMPLY
ADD A WORD OF CAUTION. THAT
EVEN THOUGH THIS IS JUST A
RESOLUTION IS NOT A SUBSTANTIVE
ON PIECE OF LEGISLATION. THAT
WE ARE TREADING INTO FREEDOM OF
SPEECH TERRITORY THAT I THINK
SHOULD CONCERN ALL OF US. AND
WHEN I SAY FREEDOM OF SPEECH
AND FREEDOM OF RELIGION THESE
ARE CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
AREAS OF OUR OF OUR COUNTRY.
THAT NGUYEN IN INDIVIDUAL SEEKS
THERAPY OR GUIDANCE ON BEFORE A
RELIGIOUS LEADER OR A MEMBER OF
A CONGREGATION WHETHER IT BE A
MOSQUE A TEMPLE OR CHURCH. THAT
THAT IS IN A PRIVATE SETTING IN
THAT IT IS ALSO VOLUNTEER. AND
LASTLY THE MEMBERSHIP IN THAT
ON THAT CONGREGATION IS NOT
CONDITIONS ON THE SEEKING FOR A
POSITION OF THAT TREATMENT SO I
THINK WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF ITS
VOLUNTARY NATURE IT'S
CONFIDENTIAL NATURE. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE REMIND
OURSELVES THAT. WE'RE DEALING
WITH WITH THE FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION FREEDOM OF RELIGION.
AND TO DISALLOW OR CREATE THE
PATHWAY WHERE WE TELL
INDIVIDUALS THAT THEY CANNOT
SAY CERTAIN THINGS. SHOULD GIVE
US PAUSE AND THAT'S ONLY REASON
WHY WE HAD SUCH I THINK
STRENUOUS DEBATE IN JUDICIARY
ON THIS WAS PRIMARILY ON FIRST
AMENDMENT GROUNDS. CENTER
WINNER. I THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE AS CHAIR OF
THE LEGISLATIVE LGBT Q. CAUCUS
HI THIS RESOLUTION AS A
PRIORITY FOR OUR CAUCUS AND YOU
HAVE TO JUST TO BE VERY FRANK
CONVERSION THERAPY A
PSYCHOLOGICAL TORTURE IT IS IT
HAS ABSOLUTELY NO LEGITIMACY
THERE'S NO SUPPORT FOR THE
NOTION THAT SOMEONE CAN CHANGE
THEIR SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND
THERE'VE BEEN SO MANY PEOPLE ON
WHO HAD BEEN. BADLY DAMAGED BY
THESE EFFORTS WHICH IS WHY WE
BANDS CONVERSION THERAPY FOR
CHILDREN BUT EVEN FOR ADULTS IT
IS INCREDIBLY DAMAGING WE
SHOULD NOT BE CONDONING IT WE
SHOULD BE OPPOSING AT AND I
WILL KNOW THAT YET AGAIN
RECENTLY YET ANOTHER LEADER IN
THE CONVERSION THERAPY MOVEMENT.
ACKNOWLEDGE A GUESS WHY HE'S A
GAY MAN. AND WE SEE THIS OVER
AND OVER AGAIN. LGBT PEOPLE WHO
WHO STAR ADVOCATING FOR
CONVERSION THERAPY AND THEN IN
THE YEAH AND A KNOWLEDGE THAT
IT DOESN'T WORK AND THEY'RE
STILL LGBT. THIS IS
PSYCHOLOGICAL TORTURE WE NEED
TO REJECT THIS TERRIBLE THING.
CENTER JACKSON. IT'S THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AS CHAIR OF
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON THE
JUDICIARY DO WANT TO RESPOND TO
THIS FIRST AMENDMENT CLAIM IT'S
A VERY INTERESTING ONE AND
FRANKLY UNTIL RECENTLY THE
INTERPRETATION OF THE FIRST
AMENDMENT WAS A ONE RELIGION
COULD NOT IMPOSE ITSELF ON
OTHER RELIGIONS. ARE SO IT TOO
WOULD TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THE RULE THAT ONE SHOULD HAVE
RELIGIOUS FREEDOM TO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST OTHERS IS
A RELATIVELY NEW CONCEPT AND
HOPEFULLY ONE THAT IN THE
COURSE OF THE NEXT FEW YEARS
WILL BE REJECTED. I IT IS
ESSENTIALLY A FALSE NARRATIVE
THAT ONE RELIGIOUS PERSPECTIVE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO UNDERMINE THE
PROTECTIONS IN THE RIGHTS THAT
WE HAVE GIVEN TO OTHERS WHO
DON'T NECESSARILY SHARE THAT
PERSPECTIVE THAT WAS PART OF
THE DISCUSSION THAT WE HAD
DURING OUR- HEARING AND TO. THE
NOTION THAT. BY TRYING TO
PROTECT MEMBERS OF THE LGBT
COMMUNITY FROM OF THE HORRORS
OF THIS TYPE OF EXPERIENCE IS
NOT. A GRANT THING IT OR DO YOU
SHOULD NOT BE I HATE TO USE
WERE TRUMP BUT IT'S A GOOD ONE
OF A BY THOSE WHOSE RELIGION
SAYS THAT. THAT THOSE WHO ARE
MEMBERS OF THE LGBT Q.
COMMUNITY I SHOULD NOT HAVE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS THAT WE
HAVE GRANTED THEM BECAUSE ONE.
OTHER ANOTHER PERSON'S RELIGION
DOESN'T SUPPORT THAT THE GOAL
IS TO GIVE OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
PEOPLE IRRESPECTIVE OF ONE'S
RELIGIOUS BELIEFS. AND WITHOUT
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. SEEN NO FOR THE
DESCRIPTION OF THE SINCE
SENATOR PORTANTINO. THANK THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I DON'T SPEAK A LOT ON
THE FLOOR AS YOU KNOW BUT THIS
IS AN ISSUE OF PERSONAL FAMILY
IMPORTANCE TO ME. ALITALIA AND
WIDOW BACK INTO THE TIME WHEN
THEY WERE SUCH A THING AND NOW.
SHE KNEW ONE THING SHE LOVED
HER SON AND SHE ACCEPTED HIM
AND LOVED HIM AND HER LOVE
BROUGHT FORTH ACCEPTANCE FROM A
LARGE ITALIAN CATHOLIC FAMILY
BECAUSE HER LOVE WAS THAT. J'AI
NORMA SIN AND HEALING AND I
JUMPED TO TODAY AND THERE'S
ACTUALLY SOME. SCHOOLS PRIVATE
SCHOOLS THAT IN THEIR STUDENT
HANDBOOKS AND PARENT HANDBOOKS
HAVE IT ACTUALLY IN THEIR HAND
BOOK TO THIS DAY. THAT SAYS IF
A STUDENT FEELS THEMSELVES
ATTRACTED TO A STUDENT OF THE
SAME SEX. THAT THE PARENTS AND
STUDENTS HAVE TO AGREE TO SEND
THAT STUDENT TO MANDATORY
COUNSELING. THAT'S TODAY AND
THAT'S JUST UNACCEPTABLE AND SO
WHEN WE DO RESOLUTIONS LIKE
THIS WE CONTINUE TO EDUCATE THE
GENERAL PUBLIC THAT CONVERSION
THERAPY IS A SHAM AND WE CAN'T
FORGET THAT EVEN TODAY THERE
ARE INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE
FINDING SUBTLE WAYS TO SUBJECT
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO SHOULD BE
LOVED LIKE MY BROTHER WAS LOVED
BY MY MOM AND NOT FORCED INTO
MANDATORY COUNSELING BECAUSE
THEY ARE WHO THEY ARE SO I
STRONGLY RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR
NINETY NINE. THANK SENATOR
SENATOR BILL. OF THOSE CHAIRMAN
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
MENTAL HEALTH. I'D HAVE TO SAY
THAT CONSIDERING THIS A MENTAL
HEALTH PRACTICE. I WOULD
CONSIDER IT MENTAL HEALTH
MALPRACTICE. AND I THINK THAT
JOB. WE SHOULD NOT A- COMPARE
THE FREEDOM OF SPEECH. AND OF
FREEDOM OF RELIGION WITH
MEDICAL APPROACHES THAT HAVE
BEEN PROVEN TO BE DISREPUTABLE
AND WE SHOULD URGE ADOPTION OF
THIS RESOLUTION BECAUSE THE
RESOLUTION ITSELF. YOU'VE READ
IT IS A VERY STRONG RESOLUTION
IN FAVOR OFCOMPASSION AND
SUPPORT FOR PEOPLE WHICH IS IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION NOT IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION SO I HEARD
SUPPORT FOR THIS RESOLUTION.
FOR EVERYBODY TO VOTE FOR THANK
YOU THANK YOU. DINNER MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT WE
WERE HERE LAST YEAR ON A
SIMILAR SUBJECT AND. JUST A
RECENTLY THE LA TIMES CAME OUT
WITH AN ARTICLE THE HEADLINES
THAT SEXUALITY IS A COMPLEX MIX
AND SO I BELIEVE IN THIS AREA
WE'RE TALKING PERHAPS ABOUT TWO
DIFFERENT STREAMS OF.
COUNSELING I ALREADY MENTIONED
LAST YEAR'S SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED THAT
THAT AYE AYE SOME OF THESE
COUNCIL METHODS I DO NOT
SUPPORT AT ALL. BUT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT SPIRITUAL
COUNSELING AND SO I BELIEVE THE
RESOLUTION IS BASED ON A FALSE
PRESUMPTION THAT COUNSELING
SOMEONE REGARDING SAME SEX
ATTRACTION CANNOT INCLUDE
DISCUSSIONS CONSIDERED VAGUELY
AS CONVERSION THERAPY. HOW CAN
WE FOR CLOSE ON SPIRITUAL
COUNSELING WHEN SOMEONE IS ON A
JOURNEY AND IT'S HONESTLY
ENQUIRING ABOUT WANTING TO
CHANGE AND ONCE PROFESSIONAL
ASSISTANCE IT'S A COMPLEX AREA
AND I DON'T BELIEVE WE SHOULD
BE IMPEDING. ON A LEGITIMATE
COUNSELLING BUSINESS AS THE
RIGHT SOLUTION AND I WILL BE
VOTING IN OPPOSITION TO ACR
NINETY THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SEEN NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION IN THE VERY
CENTER ON BURKE WERE TO FIND WE
HAVE ONE MORE. I'M SORRY
SENATOR GROVE I'M STARTING NOT
TO YOUR MICROPHONE. M. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT. YOU'RE
ALL THE WAREHOUSES IN THIS
RESOLUTION ARE ARE PRETTY
BENIGN AND WHERE IT SAYS
RESOLVED YOU KNOW THE AUTHOR
LAST YEAR I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE THAT THERE WAS A BILL
THAT CAME FORTH ON THIS FLOOR
LAST YEAR AND IT HE DIDN'T
SUBMIT TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND WE HAD LONG LENGTHY
CONVERSATIONS WITH EACH OTHER.
AND I THINK WHAT WHAT NEEDED TO
BE UNDERSTOOD ABOUT LAST YEAR'S
ABOUT LAST YEAR'S BILL WAS IT
INCLUDED YOU KNOW EVERY EVERY
BOOK MATERIAL AND FOR ANY PAID
THE INDIVIDUAL WELL ALL OF US
THAT IT IN CHURCH REGARDLESS OF
WHAT OF FAITH WE PRACTICE NO
THAT THEY IN MY CASE THE BIBLE
IS A BOOK RIGHT IT'S MATERIAL
IN IN IN SOMEBODY ELSE'S CASE
IF IT MIGHT BE SOMETHING
DIFFERENT. IN MY CASE A PASTOR
IS PAID SO IT WOULD THAT
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
WOULD HAVE AFFECTED PASTORS
BEING ABLE TO COUNSEL
INDIVIDUALS AT REALLY HEARTFELT
LEAF THINKING OR SEEKING
COUNSELING I KNOW THE AUTHOR
LAST YEAR MET WITH SEVERAL
PASTORS AROUND THE STATE AND
ACTUALLY GOT THEIR INPUT AND HE
WAS VERY ENGAGING WITH
OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL. AND
FOR HIM TO COME FORWARD AND
BRING THIS RESOLUTION WHERE IT
SAYS RESOLVED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE RESOLVED
ISSUES AND IT JUST SAYS THE
LEGISLATURE CALLS ON RELIGIOUS
LEADERS ALL RELIGIOUS LEADERS
TO COUNSEL ON L. G. B. T. HE
MANAGES A MATTERS FROM A PLACE
OF LOVE COMPASSION AND
KNOWLEDGE AND- YOU KNOW I'VE
SPOKEN BEFORE PASTOR GROUPS ALL
OVER THE STATE AND YOU KNOW IF
THEY DON'T. COUNSEL ON A
POSITION FROM A POSITION OF
LOVE AND COMPASSION AND
KNOWLEDGE THAN THEY SHOULD BE
COUNSELING PEOPLE IN THIS AREA
AND SO AS YOU KNOW CONTRARY TO
WHAT. WAS SAID ON THE FLOOR
EARLIER. I MEAN TO ASK PEOPLE
TO COUNSEL FROM A PLACE OF LOVE
COMPASSION AND KNOWLEDGE OF. IS
A PRETTY SIMPLE ASK AND SO I
JUST WANNA THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
AND CHANGING THE LEGISLATION
THAT HE HAD FROM PREVIOUS
YEARS. TO WHERE IT IS TODAY AND
SAID THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OF IT ON THE
SIDE ON. CENA SOONER AMBER DO
NOW MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND THANK YOU THE
SENATOR FROM BAKERSFIELD FOR
YOUR COMMENTS I DO KNOW THAT
THE- AUTHOR THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW TRAVELED AROUND THE
STATE AND SOUGHT INPUT FROM
LEADERS RELIGIOUS LEADERS
AROUND THE STATE. AND YOU ARE
RIGHT THIS DOES ADVISE THE-
COUNSELORS COUNSEL FROM A PLACE
OF LOVE AND COMPASSION AND
INDEED. WE HOPE THEY'LL DO TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE UNDERSTAND
THIS THIS DOESN'T MANDATE
ANYTHING THIS DOES CALL OUT
CONVERSION THERAPY AS A HARMFUL
PRACTICE IN OTHERS A SPOKEN
ABOUT THE HARM TO THE PERSON
WHO RECEIVES THE SORT OF. SHAM
THERAPY I SPEAK NOT JUST. ABOUT
THE HARM DONE TO THAT
INDIVIDUAL BUT THE HARM THAT'S
DONE TO FAMILIES AND TO OTHERS
WE'RE A FAMILY MEMBER IS
SUBJECTED TO AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO POINTS OUT
TO THIS TORTURE. IT CAUSES
GREAT DISCORD SO ARE I URGE ALL
OF US TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
BY HIGHLIGHTING THIS SHAM
FRAUDULENT DECEITFUL HARMFUL
PRACTICE AND BOAT HI. ON THE
RESOLUTION THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS BY
BATES. BELL. BY BURGESS NO
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO I CHIANG.
DALY. DODD HI HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER BY GONZALEZ
BY GROWTH. HERTZBERG. BY HILL
AYE HUESO AYE TADO. BY JACKSON
HI JONES NO LEYVA. BY STERN AYE
STONE NOVEMBER IA CATHY I
WINNER HI WILK. SOONER ARE
NUMBERED MOVED TO CALL. NEXT UP
BUT MEMBERS IS ITEM ONE SIXTY
SENATOR DRAWS ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR THIS ITEM. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE ROUTE ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHEN AN ACT RELATING TO
IMPLEMENT. THIRD RAZA FOR
JURORS. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
SIX CLARIFIES AMBIGUITY IN
CURRENT LAW BY PROVIDING THAT
PART TIME THAT IS A JUNK
FACULTY. AT NONPROFIT
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES CAN CONTINUE TO BE
TREATED AS EXEMPT PROFESSIONALS
THE BILL SETS THE MINIMUM
COMPENSATION FLOOR BASED ON A
FORMULA FOR TOTAL HOURS OF
SERVICE. NOT JUST THE CLASSROOM
TIME TO ACCOUNT FOR TIME SPENT
PREPARING LESSONS RADIO SIMONS
AND RESPONDING TO STUDENTS
SEVERAL COLLEGES HAVE BEEN
FORCED TO REQUIRE THEIR AYE
JUNK FACULTY. TO USE TIME CARDS
IN ORDER TO TRACK HOURS WORKED
AS WELL AS MIL AND WEST BREAKS.
THIS CREATES A SIZEABLE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN FOR THE
UNIVERSITY AND FOR THE ADJUNCT
PROFESSORS BECAUSE IT
INTERFERES WITH THEIR ABILITY
TO SCHEDULE THEIR TEACHING
AROUND OTHER COMMITMENTS.
SUPPORTED BY THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES AND S. YEAH
YOU THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
ADD JUNK FACULTY MEMBERS ENJOY
FLEXIBILITY IN INDEPENDENCE
WELL BENEFITING STUDENTS WITH
THEIR PROFESSIONAL. EXPERIENCE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SENIOR NINE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES BY BILL. HI BURGESS HI
BRADFORD ARE HI CAMBIADO I
CHIANG I DALY. I DODD HI DORADO
AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW BY HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO I TADO. I
JACKSON I JONES I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. BY
MONNING HI MORE LOCK. MORALE HI
NIELSEN AYE PAN PORTANTINO I
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE. HI NUMBER. I
HAVE A COUNTY I WIENER. I WILK
HI. SENATOR ALSO MOVES A CALL
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
SEVEN SENATOR CAFIERO ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM YES THE
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN FIFTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS AN ACT
RELATING TO A PRINT AND SHIP.
SENATOR CAFIERO THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY EIGHT ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAMES RAMOS.
THE CURRENT ACADEMIC CLIMATE
FOR STUDENTS OFTEN EMPHASIZES
COLLEGE PREPAREDNESS AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES PROVIDED BY
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS ARE
OVERLOOKED AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT WOULD SEEK TO RAISE
AWARENESS OF APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS BY PROVIDING STUDENTS
WITH MORE ACCESS. TO THESE AT
CAREER FAIRS THIS BILL REQUIRES
A SCHOOL OR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCY TO CONTACT LOCAL
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
PRECEDING A COLLEGE OR CAREER
FAIR TO ENSURE THAT THEY CAN
PARTICIPATE TO MAKE STUDENTS
AWARE. OF AND HAVE ACCESS. TO
LOCAL APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED NO
OPPOSITION NO NO VOTES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING SEEN ON MRS SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
I CAMBIADO I CHIANG. I DALY AYE
DODD. HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I
GROWTH I HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO AYE OR TITLE. I JACKSON.
HI JONES I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL. I MONEY BY MORE
LUCK I AM A REAL AYE NIELSEN
AYE PAN PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN BY
STONE. I AMBERG IOWA COUNTY I
WINNER HI WILK HI. SENATOR
CAFIERO MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP
IS FILE ITEM ONE SEVEN SIX
SENATOR RAZA ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR THIS ITEM. SENATOR ALSO ARE
YOU PREPARED. MISS SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
FORTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA AND ACT REALLY
INTO HAZARDOUS WASTE AND
DECLINERS THROUGHOUT THE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
YOU'RE RIGHT PREPARE THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT ASSEMBLY WOMAN
GARCIA'S PREVIOUS AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY THREE WE ALLOCATED A FEE
ALREADY IMPOSED ON ALL CAR
BATTERIES THE FUND THE CLEANUP
OF CONTAMINATION CAUSED BY LEAD
ACID BATTERIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THIS BILL TODAY AB ONE
FORTY TWO REMOVES THE SUNSET
PROVISION ON THE MANUFACTURE OF
BATTERY FEE ON APRIL FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND INCREASES
IT TO TWO DOLLARS PER BATTERY
AT THE SAME TIME THE CONSUMER
FEE WILL BE TWO DOLLARS THIS
BILL WAS CREATED IN RESPONSE TO
MAN MADE ENVIRONMENTAL
DISASTERS LIKE EXIDE WHICH
OCCURRED IN MY DISTRICTS
BACKYARD. WILL WILL ALSO BE
USED IN OTHERS THE MONEY WILL
ALSO BE USED IN OTHER SITES IN
THE BAY AREA FRESNO AND LOS
ANGELES IF WE DO NOT INCREASE
THE MANUFACTURER FREE IT WILL
TAKE OVER THIRTY YEARS. THE
FUND ANY CLEAN UP EFFORTS AND
THAT IS NOT ACCEPTABLE. THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND IS SUPPORTED BY
INDUSTRY ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
GROUPS CONSUMER ATTORNEYS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR I WILL. BERNIE DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. XENON MISS
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA. ATKINS
BATES. BELL BY BURGESS. NO
BRADFORD I CARILLO BY CHIANG NO
DALY NO DODD. HI DORADO. HI
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ HI GROW NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO AYE TOTEM I
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE. MITCHELL BY MONEY I'M
MORE LOCK. MORALE NO NIELSEN NO
PAN PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. NOVEMBER. BY KELSEY I
WINNER HI WILK NO. SENATOR ALSO
MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP MEMBERS
IS FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY NINE
SENATOR COVER YOUR ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THIS I DON'T
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE ROUTE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO OH NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE MON. AND
NATURAL IN THE PARKS. THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT. AB TWO OH NINE ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MONIQUE LIMON.
CALIFORNIA HAS TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY STATE PARKS AND MILLIONS
OF ACRES OF PUBLIC LANDS BUT
NOT EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO
THESE LANDS. TRANSPORTATION
BARRIERS ARE THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THINKING ACCESS TO
ANY OF CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
OUR PUBLIC LANDS. THIS BILL
SEEKS TO ADDRESS THAT PROBLEM
BY ESTABLISHING THE OUTDOOR
EQUITY GRANTS PROGRAM. TARGETED
TO UNDERSERVED IN AT RISK
POPULATIONS SO THAT THEY
MEMBERS MAY PARTICIPATE IN
OUTDOOR ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
NO OPPOSITION. AND NO AND NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM SENATOR BREAUX.
THANK YOU I'M SUPPORTING THIS
BILL BUT I THINK WE'RE GETTING
JUST A LITTLE AHEAD OF
OURSELVES ON ALL THE
ENVIRONMENTAL STUFF AND I WANT
TO SHARE SOMETHING WITH ALL OF
YOU. THERE IS A COLLEGE
EDUCATION BOOK. THAT HAS A PAGE
IN IT AND BASICALLY THE PAGE
SAYS WHEN YOU OPEN IT UP.
THEREFORE QUESTIONS THAT THE
STUDENTS ARE SUPPOSED TO ASK
NUMBER ONE. DO YOU BUY RECYCLED
PAPER PURCHASE BIODEGRADABLE
DETERGENTS AND CLEANING AGENTS
OR MAKE MY OWN CLEANING PRODUCT
PRODUCTS WHENEVER POSSIBLE. YES
SOMETIMES FREQUENTLY ARE OFTEN.
DO YOU RECYCLE PAPER PLASTIC
METALS PURCHASE REESE
REFILLABLE CONTAINERS WHEN
POSSIBLE AGAIN ANSWER THAT DO
TRY TO WEAR YOUR CLOTHES LONGER
THAN ONE TIME. SO THAT YOU CAN
REDUCE WASHING WATERING
CONSUMPTION IN THE AMOUNT OF
DETERGENTS THAT USE. A NUMBER
FOR MY FAVORITE DO YOU VOTE FOR
PRO. AM ENVIRONMENTAL
CANDIDATES IN ELECTIONS. SO
THAT'S IN OUR AND COLLEGE
EDUCATION PIECE AND IT'S LIKE.
WE KEEP ADDING ALL THESE THINGS
THAT ARE ALMOST WHAT THE- RIGHT
WHICH I AM STARTING TO AGREE
WITH THEM. SAY IS
INDOCTRINATION OF ARE YOU
THROUGH THE EDUCATION PROCESS.
SO I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS BILL
IS NOT THAT. BAD I THINK WE
JUST NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT
WHERE. WE'RE GOING ON THE
EDUCATION PROCESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OUR SENATOR
JACKSON'S. YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT YOU KNOW.
NEXT GENERATION IS REALLY VERY
UNHAPPY WITH JUST ONE MOMENT
ORGANIZED THE BACKER CHAMBER TO.
SIMMER DOWN A LITTLE BIT ART
INTERJECTION THIS YOUNGER
GENERATION IS A LITTLE BIT
UPSET WITH US BECAUSE OF OUR
LACK OF RESPECT FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH WE LIVE.
AND IF YOU TALK TO YOUNG PEOPLE
THEY WANT TO KNOW MORE ABOUT
WHAT THEY CAN DO TO BE GOOD
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDS SO I
WOULD TAKE EXCEPTION TO THE
NOTION THAT BY PROVIDING THIS
INFORMATION TO OUR YOUTH IS A
BAD THING IN FACT. I IT'S
SOMETHING WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DOING FOR YEARS BUT TO GET TO
THE BILL AT HAND THIS BILL
ASSEMBLY REQUIRES SHOULD THE
DIRECTOR OF PARKS AND REC. TO
GIVE PRIORITY FOR FUNDING
OUTDOOR ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS THAT OUTRAGE TO THOSE
WHO ARE OTHERWISE LESS INCLINED
OR ABLE TO EXPERIENCE THE GREAT
OUTDOORS AND I WANT TO SHARE
THAT THE AN EXAMPLE OF THIS
WITH YOU. A REPRESENT AN AREA
IN THE CITY OF VENTURA. WHERE
IT'S- A VERY VERY POOR AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY LIVES
IT'S CALLED THE AVENUE OF INTER
AVENUE MANY YEARS AGO I WENT
AND SPOKE TO THE- OF FOLKS WHO
DO THE EARLY EDUCATION PROGRAMS
THERE AND ASKED THEM IF THEY
HAD. RESOURCES WHAT IS THE
NUMBER ONE THING THEY WOULD. DO
WITH THOSE RESOURCES FOR THEIR
KIDS. AND I FOUND THEIR ANSWER
TO BE QUITE ASTONISHING. THEY
SAID THEY WOULD TAKE A FIELD
TRIP TO THE OCEAN. A FIELD TRIP
TO THE OCEAN THE OCEAN
COLLEAGUES IS TWO MILES FROM
THE SCHOOL. BUT BECAUSE THESE
KIDS. HAVE NEVER HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPERIENCE THE
OCEAN THEIR PARENTS ARE WORKING
SO MUCH THEY DON'T HAVE
TRANSPORTATION THEY HAD NEVER
BEEN TO THE OCEAN WHICH WAS TWO
MILES AWAY. SO I THINK THIS
BILL MAKES A LOT OF SENSE I
THINK WE SHOULD NOT THE RIDE
THE EFFORTS THAT SOME ARE
MAKING TO TRY TO EXPAND OUR
HORIZONS IN THOSE OF OUR
CHILDREN TO WHAT NATURE GODS
GREATEST CREATION HAS OFFERED
TO THEM AND WITH THAT. I WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. IN
ADDITION DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SENATOR KIRBY ARE
WHICH OUGHT TO CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT I
WOULD HAVE I WOULD TWO
RESPONSES TO THE WHOLE ISSUE
ABOUT OR EDUCATION AS AS MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM SANTA BARBARA
SAID THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE IN
SALINAS A LOT OF KIDS THAT HAVE
NEVER SEEN THE OCEAN MORE AND
WE'RE TWELVE MILES FROM THE
OCEAN AS THE CROW FLIES. AND
WHAT THIS BILL REALLY IS ABOUT
IS GIVING YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
CREATING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO GET
A TRANSPORTATION TO SOME OF
THESE OUTDOOR IN ENVIRONMENTS
THAT WE ALL LOVE AND APPRECIATE
SO MUCH IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
INCREDIBLE OUTDOOR SPACE AND
IT'S REALLY ABOUT ACCESSING
THAT NUMBER TWO IS THAT THERE
WAS A STUDY DONE RECENTLY THAT
TALKED ABOUT. THE IMPORTANCE OF
BEING AROUND TREES AND I KNOW
THAT SOUNDS A LITTLE BIT TRITE
BUT WHAT THEY FOUND IS THAT IT
THAT INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE PART
OF THE EXPERIMENT INDICATED HAD
PHYSICAL CHANGES IN THEIR IN
THEIR SYSTEM THAT RESPONDED TO
THE FACT THAT THEY WERE
OUTDOORS IN AROUND TREES AND IN
A NATURAL ENVIRONMENT THAT
THEIR BLOOD PRESSURE WAS
LOWERED THEIR JOB THEY THERE
WAS ALL THESE BENEFICIAL.
HEALTH HEALTH THINGS AND SO
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT IN A DAY AND AGE
WHERE OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
SPENDING MORE TIME ON THEIR
ELECTRONIC DEVICES AND ARE TIED
THEIR HUMAN INTERACTION IS TIED
TO THESE ADVICE AS WE NEED TO
GET HIM OUT DOORS AND WE NEED
TO SHOW THEM THAT THAT THE
WORLD THAT EXISTS OUTSIDE OF
THEIR THEIR CELL PHONES AND
THIS. IS REALLY A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY THAT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU THE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA. ATKINS BATES. BELL.
HI PORGES HI BRADFORD HI I CAN
BE AT ALL I CHIANG. HI DOLLY HI
DODD. HI THERE ALSO HI GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI GROWTH
NO HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO
AYE OR TITLE. I JACKSON I JONES
NO LEYVA. I RUBIO SKINNER I
STERN I STONE NO NUMBER IOWA
CASKEY I WINNER. HI WILK HI.
JONES NO I. MRS. AT THE CENTER
MOST CALL. NEXT UP ITEM ONE
NINETY FIVE CENTER TO LEYVA ARE
YOU PREPARED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL I MEAN
PLEASE READ ITEMS ARE. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ AND ACT REALLY
INTO EMPLOYEES THE LEYVA THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AB FIVE
HUNDRED WOULD REQUIRE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS TO
PROVIDE CERT CERT. CERTIFICATED
ACADEMIC AND CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES AT LEAST SIX WEEKS OF
FULLY PAID LEAVE FOR MEDICALLY
NECESSARY ABSENCES RELATED TO
PREGNANCY CHILDBIRTH
MISCARRIAGE OR RECOVERY FROM
FOLLOWING CHILDBIRTH. MANY
PEOPLE DO NOT REALIZE THAT MANY
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES INCLUDING
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR STATE DISABILITY
INSURANCE SDI COVERAGE SO IF AN
EMPLOYEE GETS PREGNANT AND
HEALTH COMPLICATIONS DUE TO
PREGNANCY MISCARRIAGE OR
CHILDBIRTH. SHE WAS FIRST USED
HER SICK AND VACATION LEAVE IF
SHE HOUSING ME AFTER THAT
LEAVES EXHAUSTED THAT SHE MAY
GET DIFFERENTIAL PAY WHICH IS
HER PAY MINUS THE COST FOR A
SUBSTITUTE TEACHER FOR UP TO
FIVE MONTHS. ANY WORKFORCE THAT
IS OVER 70% FEMALE CURRENT LAW
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST WOMEN WHO
HAVE CHILDREN THAT PUTS THEM AT
A SERIOUS DISADVANTAGE COMPARED
TO THEIR MALE COLLEAGUES. WOMEN
SHOULD NOT BE PUT IN A POSITION
WHERE THEY MUST CHOOSE TO
SCHEDULE PREGNANCIES BASED ON
THE ACADEMIC CALENDAR YEAR
WOMEN WHO ALSO SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO WAIT YEARS TO HAVE CHILDREN
UNTIL THEY'VE SAVED ENOUGH SICK
LEAVE OR TEMP TO SURVIVE
WITHOUT ADEQUATE PAY. THIS BILL
ALSO WORKS TOWARDS INCREASED
RISK RETENTION OF CURRENT AND
FUTURE SCHOOL EMPLOYEES THE
STATE IS FACING A SHORTAGE OF
QUALIFIED TEACHERS AND
DISTRICTS HAVE REPORTED
SIGNIFICANT DIFFICULTY
ATTRACTING AND RETAINING THE
WORK FORCE SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAN
INCENTIVIZE THEIR EMPLOYEES. TO
REMAIN IN THEIR PROFESSION
ESPECIALLY AFTER THEY HAVE A
CHILD BY INVESTING IN NECESSARY
BENEFITS THE MAKES IT LESS
BURDENSOME FOR THEM TO START A
FAMILY. IN FACT PREGNANCY AND
CHILD CARE ARE ONE OF THE TOP
REASONS SOME TEACHERS SITE FOR
LEAVING THE PROFESSION STUDENTS
CANNOT RECEIVE THE BEST
EDUCATION POSSIBLE IF OUR
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CANNOT ATTRACT AND RETAIN GREAT
TEACHERS. AB FIVE HUNDRED WOULD
ULTIMATELY SAVE DISTRICTS MORE
FUNDS IN THE LONG RUN BUT.
HELPING RETAIN TEACHERS AND
ADDRESSING THE GENDER
INEQUITIES IN LEAVE POLICY BY
REQUIRING AT LEAST SIX WEEKS OF
PAID LEAVE PREGNANCY FOR SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. SKINNER
MORLOCK. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I
APPRECIATE. THE GOAL OF AB FIVE
HUNDRED I'M I'M JUST NOT SURE
THAT IT PROVIDES THE BEST
REMEDY TO ACCOMPLISH IT. IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYEES PAY
STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE
WHICH COVERS GRILL LEAVE AND
THAT WAS POINTED OUT BY THE
FLOOR MANAGER INSTEAD OF
IMPOSING A NEW FINANCIAL
MANDATE ON PART. PROP NINETY
EIGHT FUNDED EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEMS WHICH ARE ALREADY OVER
BURDENED WITH EVER INCREASING
PENSION CONTRIBUTIONS AND
UNFUNDED RETIREE MEDICAL
LIABILITIES PERHAPS THE WORK
FORCE. SHOULD ALSO BE SUBJECT
TO STI. THE UNRESTRICTED NET
DEFICIT COMBINED FOR CALIFORNIA
SEVENTY TWO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS INCREASED IN THE LAST
YEAR BY TWO POINT FIVE EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S A FORTY
SIX PERCENT. INCREASE IN JUST
ONE YEAR SO WE HAS A CAPITAL OF
THE LEGISLATURE IN SACRAMENTO
WE HAVE TO GET SERIOUS ABOUT
THAT FISCAL QUICKSAND OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE SINKING
AND- PUTTING ON ANOTHER
FINANCIAL MANDATE IS
FINANCIALLY IMPRUDENT ALL THE
MORE SO. WHEN A NON COST
ALTERNATIVE IS AVAILABLE
CONSEQUENTLY COLLEAGUES I URGE
A NO VOTE ON AB FIVE HUNDRED.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
TINA ANSWER LEYVA YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
WOULD JUST CLOSE BY SAYING THAT
WHEN YOU BRING IN A NEW
EMPLOYEE WHETHER THEY'RE IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR OR THE PUBLIC
SECTOR AND YOU HAVE TO TRAIN
THAT EMPLOYEE AND THEN THAT
WHEN PLAY ALTERNATELY LEAVES.
THAT IS THE COST OF THE
EMPLOYER WILL NEVER GET BACK
THIS BILL AIMS AT RETAINING
TEACHERS. BY ALLOWING THEM TO
DO WHAT WOMEN DO WE ARE THE
ONLY ONES WHO CAN GET PREGNANT
AND HAVE A CHILD SO IF WE NEED
TO TAKE THE TIME OFF TO HELP
THAT CHILD WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
DO IT WITH PAID LEAVE. IF ONE
OF MY MALE COLLEAGUES WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE TIME OFF AND HAVE
A CHILD I APPLAUD THAT AND
WOULD SUPPORT THEM IN THAT
ENDEAVOR BUT UNTIL THEM LET'S
STOP MAKING IT SO HARD FOR
WOMEN TO WORK AND HAVE. A CHILD
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WITH SICK TO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE SIDE OF. ALLEN
I ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES.
BELL RIGHT I PURCHASED AYE
BRADFORD AYE KERIO YES SIR.
CHIANG I DALY I DODD. THERE ARE
SO NO I DON'T THINK SO GALGIANI.
I GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL. I WITH SO I
TULLOW. JACKSON. I JONES NO
LEYVA HI I'M ACQUIRE HI
MITCHELL. HI MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK NO MORALE. NIELSEN PAN
PORTANTINO I ROTH. HI RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE. I'M
BURKE IOWA CASKEY HI WINNER. BY
WILK BY SIR LEYVA MOVES A CALL.
EXCEPT MEMBERS IS FILE ITEM TO
ALL FIVE SENATOR DIED ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM. THE
SECRETARY PLEASE ROUTE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SEVENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ AND ACT REALLY INTO
VOTER EDUCATION. DOT THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. IN SENATORS ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN SEVENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY OF WOMEN GONZALEZ WILL
HELP EQUIP YOUNG ADULTS TO
BECOME ELECTORALLY ENGAGE
CITIZENS BY REQUIRING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO IMPROPER IMPLEMENT
ED VOTER EDUCATION PROGRAMMING
FOR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. IN
RECENT YEARS AS BODIES BEST
SEVERAL PIECES OF LEGISLATION
AIMED AT INCREASING VOTER
REGISTRATION AND MAKE IT EASIER
FOR PEOPLE TO CAST THEIR
BALLOTS HOWEVER THE PROCESS OF
EXPANDING ACCESS SOME
INDIVIDUALS FEEL OVERWHELMED
AND SIMPLY CONFUSED BY THE
PROCESS. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
TRUE FOR NEW IS VOTERS WE NEED
TO LITERALLY TEACH YOUNG PEOPLE
THE MECHANICS OF VOTING AND
DEMYSTIFY THE ELECTORAL PROCESS
FOR INSTANCE ON OUR YOUNG.
OUGHT FOR INSTANCE ARE YOU
YOUNG VOTERS SHOULD KNOW HOW TO
REGISTER TO VOTE WHAT DEADLINES
EXIST HOW TO RETURN A BALLOT TO
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS HOW
TO ACQUIRE LANGUAGE ACCESS.
MATERIALS IN THE INFORMATION ON
THEIR RIGHTS AS VOTERS. AB
SEVEN SEVEN THREE WILL HELP
ACCOMPLISH THAT BY REQUIRING
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION AND THE SECRETARY OF
STATE TO DEVELOP EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMMING FOR IMPLEMENTATION
AT THIS SCHOOL LOCAL SCHOOL
LEVEL. LOCAL COUNTY ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS WILL ALSO BE REQUIRED
TO ENSURE THE PROGRAMMING IS
SPECIFICALLY TAILORED TO THE
ELECTION SYSTEM IN THAT COUNTY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING NINE A
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES BELL BY BURGESS.
BRADFORD I CARRY IT OFF I
CHIANG I DALY NO DODD. HI THERE
ALSO. GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO AYE HER
TITLE I JACKSON. BY JONES. NO
LEYVA. I'M ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL.
BY MONNING I'M MORE LOCK MORALE
NIELSEN. PAN PORTANTINO. I ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER. BY STERN
AYE STONE. NO BURKE IOWA CASKEY
I WINNER BY WILK BY. SENATOR
DODD MOVES A CALL. EXCEPT
MEMBERS IS FILE ITEM TOOLS SIX
SOONER PORTANTINO ARE YOU
PREPARED TO PRESENT THIS ITEM
HE IS MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
SEVENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON AND ACT REALLY TO
FIREARMS AND MAKING A
PREPARATION THERE FOR SENIOR
PORTANTINO FOR GEORGE THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT AB EIGHT
SEVENTY NINE ON BEHALF OF MR
GIPSON. WHICH SEEKS TO CLOSE A
GUN LIEU PAUL BY REQUIRING A
STATE BACKGROUND CHECK FOR
PURCHASES OF UNFINISHED FRAMES
AND RECEIVERS IN ESSENCE GUN
PARTS. IT REQUIRES THAT ALL
PURCHASES ALSO TAKE PLACE
THROUGH A LICENSED GUN DEALER
WHICH MAKES SENSE IF YOU'RE
BUILDING A GUN YOU SHOULD BY
YOUR PARTS ARE LICENSED DEALER
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES BACKGROUND
CHECKS FOR BOTH GUNS IN SALES
AND AMMUNITION YET IT IS
SILENCE ON THE SALE OF FIREARMS
PARTS CURRENT LAW REQUIRES THE
BUYER TO REGISTER THEIR HOME
ASSEMBLE FIREARM AFTER THEY
ASSEMBLE IT WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY ON THE HONOR
SYSTEM. THIS BILL INTENDS TO
IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY PUBLIC
SAFETY BY PREVENTING CRIMINALS
IN THOSE WHO SHOULD NOT
OTHERWISE POSSESS A FIREARM
FROM GAINING ACCESS WHILE
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF GUN
OWNERS THE RIFLE USED IN THE
DEADLY RIVERSIDE SHOOTING ON
AUGUST TWELFTH KILLING CHP
OFFICER ANDRE MORE A- WAS A
GHOST GUN HAS WAS THE GUN USED
IN THE TRAGIC KILLING OF
SACRAMENTO POLICE OFFICER TOWER
O'SULLIVAN. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR BORDERS FAMOUS
PRESIDENT QUESTION FOR THE- FOR
MAJOR. CENTER PORTANTINO WE TO
QUESTION SHORT. CAN YOU HELP ME
UNDERSTAND PRECURSOR PARTS WE
SEE THIS AND IT IN THE CHEMICAL
INDUSTRIES. WERE YOU HAVE
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE USED FOR
SOMETHING ELSE. I IS THAT
ANALOGOUS HERE CAN YOU DESCRIBE
PRECURSOR PARTS AND THAT ALL
THAT COULD BE. MISAPPLIED
PERHAPS SO IN THIS BILL IT
ACTUALLY IS DEFINING WHAT THOSE
PARTS ARE OKAY SO IT'S
CLARIFYING ALL OF THOSE ISSUES
SO WE'LL KNOW WHAT. THE
PRECURSOR PARTS ARE AND IF YOU
USE THEM TO BUILD THE GUN YOU
HAVE TO BUY THOSE PARTS.
THROUGH A LICENSED DEALER SO
DOESN'T INFRINGE UPON A LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS RIGHT TO GO BY
THOSE PARTS MAKE THEIR OWN GUN
JUST SAYS YOU HAVE TO BUY THEM
WITH A BACKGROUND CHECK. AND
YOU HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
LICENSED DEALER THANK YOU. YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL DESCRIPTION OF
IT CENTER PORTANTINO WHICH ARE
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES BELL I PURCHASED.
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO. CHANGE. NO
DALY NO DODD. HI THERE ALSO.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW NO HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO I TADO.
JACKSON. BY JONES NO LEYVA BUY
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING BY MORLOCK MORALE NO
NIELSEN. PAN TINO I ROTH BY.
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER OUR COUNTY I WINNER BY
WILK. BY. CENTER PORTANTINO
MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP MEMBERS
IS FILE ITEM TWO FIVE ONE
SENATOR GLAZER YOU'RE PREPARED
FOR THIS ITEM MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
CONTRACTS SENATOR GLAZER FLOOR
GEORGE THAT THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT. THIS BILL
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS IT WILL INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY BETWEEN THE
STATE AND IT CONTRACTORS BY
REQUIRING DEPARTMENTS TO
CONDUCT POST EVALUATIONS FOR
MAJOR IT PROJECT TOTALLY FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS OR
MORE. CURRENTLY POSTED
VALUATIONS ARE ONLY REQUIRED
FOR MINOR CONSULTING SERVICES
NOT LARGER PROJECTS BILLS
RECEIVE NO NO VOTES ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT OF.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. THE NUN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. HI
ARCHIE LET AN AYE ATKINS. HI
BATES HI BILL I BRIDGES.
BRADFORD I CAN BE AT ALL.
CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD AYE
DOURADO I GALGIANI. I GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ I GROW BY HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I TITLE I
JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. HI
MONNING I'M MORE LUCK I'M A
REAL I NIELSEN. PAN PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE. I AM BURKE
I WOULD COUNTY I WINNER. BY
WILK HI HI. SOONER GLAZER MOVES
A CALL NEXT UP MEMBERS IS FILE
ITEM TWO FIVE TWO SENATOR ALLEN
ARE YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT
THIS ITEM. THE SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
TEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
RELATIVE TO VEHICULAR AIR
POLLUTION CENTER OUR- MEMBERS
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU AJ ARE
TEN ON BEHALF OF A SUMMER
RADIUS. THIS RESOLUTION
REAFFIRMS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE STANDARDS PURSUANT TO
THE WAIVER THAT WE HAVE UNDER
THE CLIP THE FEDERAL CLEAN AIR
ACT. THERE HAVE BEEN A SERIES
OF PROPOSALS UNDER SOME OF THE
FOLKS IN WASHINGTON TO WEAKEN
THE ABILITY OF OUR STATE TO
ENACT POLICIES NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS PUBLIC HEALTH OUTCOMES
OF CLIMATE CHANGE WHILE
PRESERVING THE STATE'S ECONOMY
YOU KNOW. FOR SOMEONE YOU FROM
LOS ANGELES WHO GREW UP IN A
TIME WHEN KIDS WERE HAD HALF OF
THE LUNG CAPACITY IT'S A IS
KIDS GOING UP ANOTHER WORLD
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY BECAUSE OF
THE TERRIBLE SMOG THAT WE HAD
THE BASIC VISIBILITY WAS SO
AWFUL. WE NEED TO TAKE A FIRM
STAND TO PROTECT OUR AIR IT'S
PART OF HOW WE ENDED UP GETTING
THE SPECIAL STATUS OF THE CLEAN
AIR ACT WE WANT TO PROTECT THAT
STATUS ADMINISTRATION AFTER
ADMINISTRATION REPUBLICAN
DEMOCRAT. CLINTON REAGAN BUSH I
HAVE GRANTED WAIVERS TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WORKED WITH
US BECAUSE THEY KNEW THAT WE
NEEDED TO TAKE SPECIAL STEPS TO
PROTECT OUR AIR GIVEN OUR
GEOGRAPHY AND GIVEN OUR SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES IN AREAS LIKE THE
SOUTH LAND ELSEWHERE. AND WE
NEED TO CONTINUE THAT THAT
STRONG TRADITION OF PARTNERSHIP
AND RESPECT FOR OUR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES. AND WITHOUT I
RESPECT YESTERDAY VOTE. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. A HEARING ON THIS SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BATES BELL HI BURGESS. BRADFORD
HI I HAVE A YELLOW I CHANGE.
DALY DODD. HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI. I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ
I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO AYE HER TITLE I JACKSON
BY JONES. LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. HI MONEY. MORE LUCK.
MORALE NIELSEN PAN PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE. NO NUMBER.
IOWA CASKEY I WINNER BY WILK HI.
SENATOR ALLEN MOVES A CALL.
NEXT ON DECK IS FILE IEM TWO
FIVE THREE SENATOR BORDERS ARE
YOU PREPARED. SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE NINETY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER AN ACT RELATING TO
THE MINUTES OF THE CODES
SENATOR BOARDS WHICH COLLEAGUES
I'M HONORED TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE NINE NINE ONE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
GALLAGHER THIS IS A TRUE CLEAN
UP BILL. THIS IS THE ANNUAL
CODE MAINTENANCE BILL THAT
INCLUDES CHANGES TO STATE COACH
RECOMMENDED BY LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL SUCH IS GRAMMATICAL
ERRORS IN A LIMITING
DUPLICATIVE CODE SECTIONS AND
OTHER NON SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE.
NEED TO BETTER DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM. CENA AND- SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCH LETTER AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES AYE BILL I BRIDGES AYE
BRADFORD AYE CAMBIADO I CHIANG
AYE DALY AYE DODD. HI THERE
ALSO I GALGIANI HI GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO TITLE. WITH SO I
THOUGHT OF I JACKSON. I JONES I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING I'M MORE LOCK I'M
REAL. HI NIELSEN AYE PAN.
PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO. I
SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE. I
AM BURKE OUR COUNTY I WINNER BY
WILK HI. SENATOR WARS MOVES A
CALL. MEMBERS NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM TWO FIVE FIVE SENATOR WILK.
FOR THIS ITEM MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
NINETY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AN ACT RELATING TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CENTER WILK
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE 2% A. B.
SIX NINETY FIVE AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMAN MEDINA AB SIX
NINETY FIVE EXTENDS THE CURRENT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
DESIGN BUILD STATUTE UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. ACCORDING
TO EXPERIENCES FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
THEY USED DESIGN BUILD
CONTRACTING TO EXPEDITE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A PROJECT AVOID
CONFLICTS BETWEEN ARCHITECTS
ENGINEERS CONTRACTORS AND
REDUCE COSTS THE BILL ALSO
PLAYS EXISTING PROVISIONS
REGARDING THE USE OF SKILLED
AND TRAIN TO WORK FORCE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OF
IT ON THE SIDE ON. XENON
INSTRUCTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES NO BELL BY BURGESS.
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO. I CHIANG
AYE DALY AYE DODD. HI THERE
ALSO I GALGIANI. HI GLAZER I
GONZALEZ HI. GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY
TITLE HI JACKSON I JONES. HI
LEYVA HI MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
I MONNING I'M MORE LOCK NO
MORRELL. NO NIELSEN NO PAN.
PORTANTINO I ROTH BY RUBIO BY
SKINNER. BY STERN. I STONE NO
BURKE OUR CASSIE BY WINNER BY
WILK BY. JUNIOR WOKE MOVES A
CALL. EXCEPT MEMBERS IS FILE
ITEM TWO FIVE SEVEN SKINNER
MINING YOU'RE PREPARED FOR THIS
ITEMS SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE. MINING
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
WE CREATED THE INDIVIDUAL
MARKET ASSISTANCE PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANT TO
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WITH
HOUSEHOLD INCOMES AT OR BELOW
6100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL INCLUDING ADDITIONAL
SUBSIDIES TO THOSE CURRENTLY
ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL SUBSIDIES
AB ONE SEVENTY FOUR WILL ENSURE
WE REVIEW THE ENROLLMENT
FIGURES COLLECTED BY COVER
CALIFORNIA AS A RESULT OF THESE
NEW STATE SUBSIDIES. THIS BILL
ALSO INCLUDES A TECHNICAL FIX
TUNE ARONIE AS CODE SECTION IN
THE CORPORATION'S CODE MEMBERS
ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YEAR
AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE SO I DON'T.
SEEING NONE RECEPTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BELL I BRIDGES. BRADFORD HI
KELLY AT I CHIANG BY DAILY DODD
I DORADO AYE GALGIANI I GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. BY TITLE I
JACKSON I JONES I LEYVA. BY
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. BY MONEY
HI I'M MORE LUCK MORALE. NO
NELSON. I PAN PORTANTINO. ROTH
I RUBIO I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. NUMBER OUR CASKEY.
WIENER. HI WILK HI LIKE OUT
HERE. PORTANTINO AYE. REMOVE
THE CALL. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
TWO SEVEN ONE SENATOR SCANNER
YOU PREPARED THIS ITEM MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING AND NECK RELATED
FARMS. CENTERS SKINNER. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
AB SIXTY ONE WOULD EXPAND THE
POOL OF PEOPLE WHO WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR WHAT IS NOW
POPULARLY KNOWN AS RED FLAG
ORDERS RED FLAG ORDERS ARE THE
ABILITY FOR US TO. IF WE
CONFRONT A LOVED ONE SOMEONE
WHO IS IN OUR A CO WORKER IN
OUR OFFICE FOR IF WE ARE AT A
HIGH SCHOOL OR COLLEGE SAY A
STUDENT OR CO WORKER THERE WHO
IS MAKING CREDIBLE THREATS OF
VIOLENCE AGAINST THEMSELVES OR
OTHERS. THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO BY PRESENTING TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR COURT THE
DEMONSTRATION OF THESE CREDIBLE
THREATS THAT THE RED FLAG ORDER
WOULD BE ABLE TO TEMPORARILY.
GET FIREARMS OUT OF THE HANDS
OF THESE PEOPLE NOW A RECENT
STUDY AT UC DAVIS LITERALLY
THAT JUST CAME OUT THIS MONTH
WHERE THEY'VE BEEN OVER FOUR
HUNDRED RED FLAG ORDERS ISSUED
IN CALIFORNIA SINCE THE BILL
WAS FIRST WENT INTO EFFECT
WHICH WAS TWENTY SIXTEEN AND I
WAS THE AUTHOR OF THE ORIGINAL
BILL IT DIDN'T GO IN EFFECT
TWENTY SIXTEEN BUT SINCE TWENTY
SIXTEEN. A MODEST NUMBER ONLY
FOUR HUNDRED OF SUCH ORDERS
HAVE BEEN RE ISSUED BUT OUT OF
THOSE FOUR HUNDRED UC DAVIS DID
A DETAILED STUDY. ON A SELECT
NUMBER OF THEM AND THESE WERE
ALL. PEOPLE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD
MADE THREATS OF MASS VIOLENCE
OR MASS SHOOTINGS AND THESE
PEOPLE WERE THE RED FLAG ORDER
WAS ISSUED IN THE FIRE ARMS
WERE REMOVED NOW WE WILL NEVER
KNOW. IF THE THERE WAS ACTUALLY
A MASS SHOOTING PREVENTED AS A
RESULT OF THE ISSUING OF THAT
ORDER BUT WHAT THIS STUDY SHOWS
IS THAT THE ORDER WAS ABLE TO
GIVE A TOOL TO SOMEONE WHO IF
WE- KNOW THAT THEY ARE MAKING
THESE CREDIBLE THREATS. AND WE
CAN SHOW TO LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
COURT THIS CREDIBLE EVIDENCE WE
CAN TEMPORARILY GET THE
FIREARMS OUT OF THEIR HANDS SO
AB SIXTY ONE. JUST EXPANDS THE
POOL OF PEOPLE WHO COULD
REQUEST A RED FLAG ORDER
INCLUDING TO BE INCLUDING AN
EMPLOYER A CO WORKER OR AN
EMPLOYEE OF A HIGH SCHOOL OR
COLLEGE AND GIVEN WHAT WE HAVE
SEEN FROM THE MASS SHOOTINGS.
IN MOST RECENT DAYS. EXPANSION
LIKE THIS WOULD BE VERY VERY
HELPFUL IN WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. IN THE DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING TEAM JACKSON'S SOONER
JACKSON PLEASE JUST VERY
BRIEFLY IS THE I THINK
PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR IN THIS
BILL WHEN IT CAME UP BY MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM A BERKELEY A
IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT WE CAN
IDENTIFY. WHEN PEOPLE ARE A
TRULY EVIDENCING SIGNS OF
SIGNIFICAN INSTABILITY
FREQUENTLY THEY WILL TALK ABOUT
FIREARMS THEY WILL TALK ABOUT
THE WEATHER IT'S ILLUSORY OR-
JUST SORT OF DREAMING ABOUT THE
PROSPECT OF GOING OUT AND
COMMITTING SOME KIND OF A MASS
SHOOTING OR KILLING ONCE LOVED
ONES. WE DO KNOW THAT WHEN WE
LOOK BACK AT SOME OF THE MASS
SHOOTINGS AND FAMILY SHOOTINGS
THAT WE'VE SEEN RECENTLY THERE
HAVE BEEN VERY CLEAR SIGNS VERY
CLEAR SIGNS FOR WHICH THIS BILL
IS INTENDED TO INTERVENE. YOU
KNOW WE CAN TALK ABOUT WHAT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN BUT WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT FAMILIES WHO ARE
GRIEVING BECAUSE OF THESE
EVENTS. THIS IS A MEASURE THAT
I THINK IS PROTECTIVE BOTH OF
THOSE WHO ARE LEGITIMATE OWNERS
OF FIREARMS AND THOSE WHO HAVE
THEM AND IN THEIR POSSESSION
ARE LIKELY AND VERY PROBABLY
ARE GOING TO COMMIT HARM ON
OTHERS WE CAN INTERVENE THIS
BILL CALLS FOR A CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE STANDARD
IT'S A FAIRLY HIGH STANDARD.
THIS IS A GOOD MEASURE AND WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY URGE
AN AYE VOTE. IN ADDITION
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THE
SIDE OF. THE NINE CENTERS
SKINNER YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
ASKED FOR YOUR AYE VOTE MISS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA. I ATKINS
AYE BATES NO BELL HI WE'RE JUST.
NO BRADFORD AYE AYE CABALLERO I
CHIANG. NO DALY NO DODD. HI
THERE ALSO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ. GROVE. NO
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO I
TITLE. I JACKSON I JONES NO
LEYVA I AM A CHOIR. BY MITCHELL
BY MONNING. I'M MORE LOCK NO
MORALE NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER. IOWA CASKEY I WINNER
HI WILK BY. PRESIDENT PLEASE
MISS SECTOR PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS. GONZALEZ HI. ICE
THIRTY KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBER GOING FOR WILL
NOT NO LONGER BE PUTTING
MEASURES ON CALL SO WE'RE GONNA
AND SHE'D BE ON THE FLOOR BE
SOMEWHERE WHERE YOU CAN HEAR
YOUR NAME WHEN IT'S CALLED SO.
WE CAN MOVE THIS PROCESS ALONG
SO. A MEASURE PASSES ON THIRTY
TO TEN. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
TWO SEVEN FIVE. AND WE HAVE
SOME SENATOR WILK. TO PRESENT
THAT MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE I MEAN PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY AN ACT
RELATING TO GUIDE SIGNAL AND
SERVICE DOGS SENATOR WILK THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB ONE SIXTY NINE WHICH
MAKES CHANGES IN LAW RELATING
TO GUIDE SIGNAL AND SERVICE
DOGS MOST NOTABLY EXTENSIVE
SAME PROTECTIONS AFFORDED TO
DOGS ON DUTY TO THE TO. TO
THOSE THAT ARE OFF DUTY WHEN A
DOG IS INJURED OR KILLED BY
ANOTHER DOG THEY HANDLE OR WILL
HAVE ACCESS TO THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION FUND AB ONE SIXTY
NINE EXTENSIVE VICTIMS ACCESS
TO THE FUND TO INCLUDE MEDICAL
EXPENSES AND LOST INCOME
RESULTING FROM THE TIME PENT
WITHOUT THE SERVICE OF THE
ANIMAL. THE BILL ALSO EXPANDS
THE DEFINITION OF GUIDE SIGNAL
AND SERVICE DR INCLUDE POPPIES
IN TRAINING THE BILL HAS TAKEN
A SIMPLE AMENDMENT TO REMOVE
THE PROVISION THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS REMAIN ON
THE SCENE UNTIL ANIMAL CONTROL
CAN ASSESS THE SITUATION THIS
LEGISLATION PROVIDES IMPORTANT
PROTECTION PROTECTIONS TO THE
DISABLED COMMUNITY AND THE
COMPANIONS THAT THEY DEPEND ON.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. SENATE
HEARING ON MISTER TERRY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARE SO
THAT A AYE ATKINS AYE BATES AYE
BILL BY BRIDGES. I BRADFORD HI
AYE CABALLERO AYE TING AYE DALY
AYE DODD. ARE THERE ALSO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. AYE TITLE I
JACKSON. JONES I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING. BY MORE LOCK I AM REAL
HI NIELSEN AYE PAN. BY
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER BY STERN AYE STONE.
I AMBERG OUR CASKEY I WINNER BY
WILK HI. SIX THIRTY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBER JACKSON BY.
BY TWO FORTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM TO NINETY SENATE BY
SENATOR HILL ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR THIS ITEM SENATOR HILL
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THIRTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN
AND THAT GOING TO COUNTY
PATIENTS RIGHTS ADVOCATES
SENATOR WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AB THREE
THIRTY THREE AIMS TO EXTEND
WHISTLE BLOWER PROTECTIONS TO
CONTRACTED EMPLOYEES WHOSE
ROLES INVOLVED RECEIVING AND
INVESTIGATING COMPLAINTS. THESE
JOBS PROTECT VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS IN ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE TREATED IN ACCORDANCE WITH
THE LAW HOWEVER MANY OF THESE
PATIENTS RIGHTS ADVOCATES ARE
TECHNICALLY NOT EMPLOYEES OF
THE FACILITIES THAT THEY SERVE
OR THE COUNTIES THEMSELVES AND
ARE INSTEAD CONTRACTED FOR THIS
WORK WE HAVE LAWS IN PLACE TO
PROTECT PEOPLE FROM ON THE JOB
RETALIATION WHEN PART OF A
CONTRACTORS ROLE IS TO OF
OVERSEE THE WELL BEING OF A
CLIENT OR CONSUMER POPULATION
THEY SHOULD BE CONFIDENT THAT
THEY CAN DO THEIR JOB WITHOUT
BEING UNDULY PUNISHED. OR
RETALIATED AGAINST OUR LABOR
LAWS ARE TAILORED TO PROTECT
EMPLOYEES BUT MANY PEOPLE
INSENSITIVE ROLES ARE
CONTRACTED AND DESERVE THE SAME
PROTECTIONS THIS BILL HAS KNOWN
NO KNOWN OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR BIBLE
COLLEGE. MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
A BIT ON THE SIDE OF. HEARING
SEEING NONE INSTRUCTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES NO
BILL I PURCHASED. NO. BRADFORD
I CAN BE AT ALL I CHIANG I DALY.
DODD ARE THERE ALSO I GALGIANI
I GLAZER. GONZALEZ BY GROVE.
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO AYE
HER TITLE. HI. JACKSON I JONES
NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING BY MORE
LUCK NO MORE REAL. NO NIELSEN
NO PAN I PORTANTINO. I ROTH I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN AYE
STONE NO NUMBER BY WORK OWSKI
BY WINNER BY WILK HI. SECTOR
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS
DALLY. GLAZER. HI GROWTH NO
YOUR. MARCH THIRTY ONE KNOWS
EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TWO NINE ONE SENATOR
LABELS PREPARED SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. TWO TO NINETY ONE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THIRTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO AN
ACCOLADE TO MANUFACTURED
HOUSING. SOONER LEYVA THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THIRTY
EIGHT WHICH UPDATES EXISTING
SMOKE DETECTOR STATE STANDARDS
BY REQUIRING A MOBILE HOME OR
MANUFACTURED HOME TO HAVE A
LISTED STATE FIRE MARSHAL SMOKE
DETECTOR UPON LEASING OR
SELLING OF THE PROPERTY ALSO TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS MATERIALS. FOR
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS THE BILL
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT EIGHT CD TO
TRANSLATE THE PART OF THE
EXISTING EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
MATERIALS INTO LANGUAGES THAT
ARE SPOKEN BY 5% OF THE
POPULATION SERVED. ENSURING
LANGUAGE ACCESS TO THESE
MATERIALS IS CRITICAL TO
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS BECAUSE
WITHOUT TRANSLATION MANY
CALIFORNIANS WILL NOT
UNDERSTAND THESE IMPORTANT
EMERGENCY INSTRUCTIONS. UNDER
THE BILL PARK OWNERS WILL MAKE
THE TRANSLATED PLAN AVAILABLE
WITH THE ENGLISH VERSION A
NOTIFY RESIDENTS ONCE A YEAR
THAT THESE MATERIALS ARE
AVAILABLE TO THEM. THE
CONVERSION ABOUT THIS BILL
CONVERSATIONABOUT THIS BILL
BEGAN AFTER A TRAGIC FIRE IN
SAN JOSE IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN THE AUTHORS
DISTRICT WHERE A MOBILE HOME
FIRE KILLED THREE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS TWO OF WHOM WERE YOUNG
CHILDREN. THE ISSUE ALSO BECAME
INCREASINGLY URGENT AS FIRES
BLAZED THROUGH MOBILE HOME
PARKS DURING THE DEVASTATING-FIRES IN SANTA ROSA FALLBROOK
PARADISE IN OTHER COMMUNITIES
AS THE CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON MANUFACTURED HOMES
I BELIEVE THAT THIS MEASURE
WILL HELP TO MAKE OUR MOBILE
HOME COMMUNITY SAFER AND
ULTIMATELY HELP SAVE LIVES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY DESCRIPTION OF IT ON
THE SIDE OF. HEARING AND SEEING
NONE MISTER TERRY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL I
PURCHASED BRADFORD I CABALLERO
I CHIANG. DELHI DODD. HI THERE
ALSO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. NO HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO AYE HER TITLE BY
JACKSON. I JONES NO LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. MONEY I'M
MORE LUCK WELL. NELSON. MERLE
NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE
NO BERG. OUR CASKEY. WIENER I
WILK HI. THE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BATES. NO
PURCHASE. CHIANG DELHI NO
MITCHELL. MORE LOCK. WHAT
CASKEY. AFTER. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS WERE MORE TIME
FOR JUST. CHIANG MITCHELL. MORE
LOCK BY KATHY. THE. ICE TWENTY
EIGHT NO SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP MEMBERS IS FILE
ITEM TWO NINE EIGHT. FOR TWO
I'M SORRY TWO NINE FOUR MY BAD
TWO NINE FOUR. CENTRE BELL ARE
YOU PREPARED. MS SECTOR PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA AND ACTUALLY
INTERESTING POINT. MISS PRESENT
MEMBERS THIS BILL THE LIMITED
EXAMINATION AN APPLICATION
PROGRAM IS KNOWN AS LEAD THIS
IS THE PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE
DESIGNED TO HELP INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES EARNED CIVIL
SERVICE JOBS. AND THE BILL
SIMPLY WILL REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES TO DEVELOP A PLAN TO
EXPAND LEAVE THEIR BY PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL JOB OPPORTUNITIES
AND IMPROVE HIRING STANDARDS
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES ARJUN AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANY OBJECTION OF
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THE SIDE OF. SEE NINE EYES
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS A MEMBERS IS
ITEM TWO NINE EIGHT CENTER WHEN
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR TWENTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
SOCIAL SERVICES. SOONER WINNER
WHEN YOU'RE READY I THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I'M
PRESENTING AB FOR TWENTY SIX ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN IN TWENTY ELEVEN
THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED A
REQUIREMENT THAT I YOU TO
pSTATEMENT FROM A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL I INDICATING THAT
THEY NEED IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES UNFORTUNATELY IN ORDER
TO COMPLETE THIS FORM SOME
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS ARE
CHARGING UP TO A HUNDRED
DOLLARS. CREATING A SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL BARRIER ARE FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE TYPICALLY LOW
INCOME BY EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
SIX PROHIBITS LICENSE HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS FROM CHARGING FOR
THE COMPLETION OF THIS FORM THE
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT WORK IN
THIS AREA AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. NEEDS
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. IN CHEN NINE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES. HI BILL I BRIDGES
HI BRADFORD BY CAMBIADO I
CHIANG I DALY. I DODD I DORADO
AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. BY
GONZALEZ I GROW. I HERTZBERG. I
HILL AYE HUESO I TADO I JACKSON.
BY JONES. BY LEYVA HI MCGUIRE
BY MITCHELL. MONNING. I'M MORE
LUCK I'M A REAL. MORRELL HI
NIELSEN. HI PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG
I WERE CASSIE BY WIENER AYE
WILK HI. RESEARCHER PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS MITCHELL.
PRICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP MEMBERS
IS FILE ITEM THREE HUNDRED. BY
ASSEMBLYMAN Q. MISTER SENATOR
BILL ARE YOU PREPARED. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE ROUTE ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR FIFTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC CONTRACTS SENATOR BILL.
WAS PRESENT MEMBERS OF THIS
BILL ADDRESSES. THE EXTENSION
OF THE PROMPT PAYMENT LAW THAT
WE PASSED A FEW YEARS AGO FOR
CONTRACTORS THAT WORK ON PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS. FOR EXTRA WORK
PERFORMED THE BILL WOULD ALSO
EXTEND CLOSE A LOOPHOLE IN THIS
LAW WHEN IT COMES TO RESOLVING
DISPUTES IN THE CLAIM PROCESS
BOB WILL ENSURE THAT WE HAVE.
PROMPT PAYMENT FOR OUR
CONTRACTORS TO DO OUR PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS. I REGION ARE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE. ANY
DESCRIPTION OF THE RAID ON THE
SIDE ON. HERE IN CHINO AND THIS
IS A CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION OF USING YOU KNOW MY
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE SIDE
OF. NINETEEN NINE EYES FORTY.
NINE ICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PROCESS. EXCEPT
MEMBERS IS FILE ITEM THREE OH
WANNA SOONER TADO SHE'S
PREPARED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
TWELVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
AN ACT RELATING TO MEDI CAL.
DINNER TODDLE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
EXISTING LAW. THE FEDERAL
PATIENT PROTECTION AND
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT REQUIRES
NEARLY ALL HEALTH PLANS TO
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH CARE FOR
THEIR MEMBERS. THIS BILL
EXPANDS THE INFORMATION
COLLECTED REPORTED AND THEN
UTILIZED IN CULTURAL COMPETENCY
PLANS FOR COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
CARE PROGRAMS. COLLECTING THIS
DATA WILL HELP ADDRESS
DISPARITIES IN HEALTH OUTCOMES
FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES BY COLLECTING
BETTER INFORMATION DEVELOPING
WHILE RESEARCH PLANS THAN
FOLLOWING THROUGH WITH THE
STRATEGIES WE WILL CREATE A
MORE RESPONSIVE AND EFFECTIVE
MENTAL HEALTH CARE SYSTEM FOR
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY DESCRIPTION
IT ON THE SIDE OF. SOON SHE
NINE MISS SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES. BELL BY BURGESS
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
CHIANG BY DAILY. DODD I DORADO.
HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO AYE HER TITLE
I JACKSON BY JONES NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING. I'M MORE LOCK WELL NO
NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE NOVEMBER
OUR CASKEY I WIENER AYE WILK HI.
VICTOR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS BATES NO.
BURGESS. DALY NO. MORE LOOK NO.
OUR EYES THIRTY KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP MEMBERS
IS FILE ITEM THREE SEVENTEEN BY
A SOME WOMEN MCCARTY DOCTOR PAN
YOU'RE PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE RATE
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY ENACT
BELINDA BUT NON VEHICULAR AIR
POLLUTION. SENATOR PATH THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT SENATORS
SIDE RICE RESENT EIGHTY SIX
SIXTY ONE A DISTRICT BILL THAT
WILL SERVE AS A TEMPLATE ON HOW
COMMUNITIES CAN ATTEST TO THE
UNFORTUNATE NEW NORMAL WILD
FIRES AND EFFECTS ON LOCAL AIR
QUALITY FOR SEVERAL DAYS LAST
YEAR SACRAMENTO HAD THE
DISTINCTION OF HAVING THE WORST
AIR QUALITY OF ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD. AND THIS WAS CAUSED BY
THE CAMP FIRE WHICH IS A
HUNDRED MILES NORTH I ALSO KNOW
THE OTHER PARTS OF STATE
INCLUDING THE BAY AREA
EXPERIENCE SIMILAR AIR QUALITY
EMERGENCIES DURING THAT FIRE
BEYOND HEALTH IMPACTS THESE
EVENTS CAUSE CONFUSION
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS SUCH AS
SHOULD HE TAKE THE KIDS TO
SCHOOL WHERE IS THE SAFEST
PLACE TO BE. SO WE NEED TO HAVE
PROPER PLANNING IN PLACE
CALIFORNIA KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT.
EIGHTY SIX SIXTY ONE ACCOMPLISH
THIS. SEC. DEVELOP AN- EDUCATE
THE COMMUNITY WHAT DO AN EVENT
OF AN AIR QUALITY EMERGENCY.
ALSO REQUIRES THE AIR JUST TO
COLLABORATE WITH COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICER SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
OTHERS. THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SEEN NONE THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS ARE
ANY OBJECTION OF USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ROGER. HEARING SEEN ICE THIRTY
EIGHT THE NINE AT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. ALL RIGHT NEXT
UP ITEM FILE ITEM THREE TWENTY
SIX SENATOR HILL. MISS SECTOR
PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY SENATOR
HILL THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
IT AB SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR WILL
EXEMPT ZERO EMISSION TRANSIT
BUSES RESERVES FROM THE STATE
PORTION OF THE SALES TAX UNTIL
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR IN ORDER TO ADVANCE THE
DEPLOYMENT. OF ZERO EMISSION
BUSES IN CALIFORNIA ALMOST HALF
OF THE STATE'S BUS POPULATION
CONTAINS DIESEL ENGINES WHICH
EMIT A COMPLEX MIXTURE OF AIR
POLLUTANTS THAT CAUSE CANCER
PREMATURE DEATH THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS TOP CONTRIBUTORS
TO CLIMATE CHANGE MANY TRANSIT
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
BEGUN TO REDUCE THESE EMISSIONS
BY THE PLANE'S ABS HOWEVER
THESE TECHNOLOGIES ARE
CONCERNED THREE MORE PICS
PENSIVE THAN DIESEL
ALTERNATIVES. IN TRANSIT
AGENCIES ARE OFTEN CASH
STRAPPED LOSING MONEY AT THE
FARE BOX AND RELYING ON FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL SUBSIDIES TO
COVER CAPITAL COST IS THE A. R.
B. IS NOW MANDATE IN THE PUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCIES CONVERTER FREE
TO ZERO CAPTION TECHNOLOGIES BY
TWENTY FORTY. SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
WILL ASSIST THESE AGENTS USED
BY EXEMPTING THE PURPOSE OF THE
STOVE TAX FOR FOUR YEARS
HELPING AGENCIES TO OVERCOME AN
IMPORTANT UP FRONT FUNDING
SHORTFALL THE CURRENTLY IMPEACH
THE PROCUREMENT OF SAID THE
MEASURE. HAS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE COLLEAGUES. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING CHAIN ON IT THIS
pROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION OF USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THE SIDE OF.
THIRTY EIGHT. I IS THE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. ALRIGHT
MOVING ON MEMBERS WERE NOW IT
FILE FILE ITEM THREE TWENTY
NINE CENTER OR CALL SKI FOR
DOCTOR QUIRK. THE SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
THIRTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK AN ACT RELATING TO WATER
QUALITY. CENTER ACOSTA MR
PRESIDENT THAT THIS BILL
DIRECTS THE STATE WATER BOARD
TO ESTABLISH THE FRESH WATER
AND MYSTERON HARMFUL HARMFUL L.
GUY OLD BLOOM PROGRAM TO
COORDINATE ACTIONS NECESSARY TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
ENVIRONMENT FROM TOXINS YOU
KNOW LG ARE AN ESSENTIAL
COMPONENT MANY ECOSYSTEMS.
HOWEVER CERTAIN TYPES OF ALGAE
PRODUCE TOXINS MULTIPLE BODIES
INCLUDING LEGIBLE IN MY
DISTRICT HAS BEEN AND. ARE
CURRENTLY IMPAIRED BY THIS
URGENT AYE VOTE. GREAT ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OF IT ON
THIS ITEM. SUSTAINING HEARING
NONE OF THIS IS ACCOUNTED FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IN THIS I
DON'T. SEE NINE THIRTY EIGHT
EYES NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP MEMBERS IS FILE ITEM
THREE THREE SIX BY SENATOR
IRWIN. SENATOR DODD'S NOT AS IT
DOES TO. WILL PASS TEMPORARILY.
WILL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM.
THREE FORTY CENTER MINING ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM OUR
DODD HERE SO WILL TAKE SENATOR
DODD IF THAT'S OKAY. REMOVING
BACK TO. THREE THREE SIX. SO
WE'RE GOING BACK TO THREE THREE
SIX. YES WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR PLEASE ROUTE ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN AN ACT
RELATING TO TAXATION. SENATOR
DOT. THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
AB EIGHT EIGHT FIVE WILL HELP
VICTIMS OF CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES
GET BACK ON THEIR FEET BY
PROVIDING THE MUCH NEEDED
PROPERTY TAX RELIEF. THIS IS A
SUPPORT SUPPORT BY CREATING
CONFORMITY WITH OTHER AREAS A
PROPERTY TAX LAW. AB EIGHTY
EIGHTY FIVE WILL HELP SUPPORT
THOSE WHO MAY HAVE LOST
EVERYTHING THAT ARE STRUGGLING
TO BUILD THEIR LOT REBUILD
THEIR LIVES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION
OF IT ON THIS ITEM. KERN CHAIN
NINE IT IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. SHE NINE OZ THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS TO FILE ITEM THREES
FORTY SENATOR MINING MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND ACT REALLY
AND EMERGENCY SERVICES IN
IRVINE. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS YOU'LL SEE
THIS IS AB NINE ELEVEN NO
COINCIDENCE IT'S ABOUT OUR NINE
ONE ONE CALL SYSTEM TO RUN A
STUDY TO SEE IF WE COULD
INCLUDE INFORMATION THAT COULD
BE LIFESAVING FOR PEOPLE WITH.
FRAGILE HEALTH CONDITIONS I
URGE HERE HI VOTE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING HEARING ON HIS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS. HI
BILL BY BURGESS BY BRADFORD AYE
KALLIO. JANE AYE DALY AYE DODD
I DORADO I GALGIANI. I GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI TITLE I
JACKSON. I JONES I LEYVA I
MCGUIRE MITCHELL. MONEY I'M
MORE LOCK. I AM A REAL. AYE
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO
BY ROTH AYE RUBIO. SKINNER I
STERN BY STONE I AM BURKE. BY
COUNTY HI I WIENER AYE WILK HI.
MR DIRT PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS COVER YELLOW HI.
GROWTH MITCHELL. HI RUBIO BY
AMBERG. NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM. THREE FOUR SIX SENATOR
PORTANTINO WAS PREPARED MISTER
SECRETARY WHEN YOU'RE READY YOU
MAY READ ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
SIXTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AN ACT RELATING TO
CAL WORKS SOONER PORTANTINO
THANK YOU. MISTER PRESIDENT A
MEMBERS. TODAY I PRESENT TO AB
NINE SIXTY ON BEHALF OF MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN CURRENT LAW
PROVIDES TEMPORARY HOUSING
ASSISTANCE TO HOMELESS FAMILIES
RECEIVING AID THROUGH THE
CALPERS PROGRAM FOR UP TO
SIXTEEN CAN SEX IN CONSECUTIVE
NIGHTS IN A HOTEL OR MOTEL A
COMMERCIAL ESTABLISHMENT. AB
NINE SIXTY WILL ALLOW BERMAN
HOUSING ASSISTANCE TO BE USED
TOWARDS SHARED HOUSING SETTINGS
SETTINGS THERE BY EXPANDING THE
OPTIONS THESE FAMILY HAVE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY DISCUSSION
OF IT ON THE SIDE ON. KERN
SCENE NINE THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
THAT AS ROLL CALL. SHE NINE. OZ
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM. THREE FIVE ONE.
DOCTOR PAN HE SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE ASSEMBLY BILL TEN THIRTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AN ACCOLADE
ELECTIONS DR. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT SENATORS AT TEN
THIRTY SIX BY SUMMER
AGUIAR-CURRY WILL REDUCE FAIRS
TO THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS IN
TWO WAYS FIRST TO REQUIRED A
SEPARATE STATE TO UPDATE THE
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
REGULATIONS DIRECTING COUNTY
OFFICIALS TO DEVELOP VOTER
OUTREACH PROGRAMS AND I THINK
WE'LL HAVE SOME MEMBERS WHO MAY
HAVE BEEN BORN YET BY THEN.
THESE GUIDELINES HAVE NEVER
BEEN UPDATED AND THEREFORE DO
NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENTS IN
STATE ELECTIONS LAW OR MODERN
TECHNOLOGY SECOND OF ALL AB TEN
THIRTY SIX CREATES A HIGH
SCHOOL VOTER EDUCATION PILOT
PROGRAM IN YELLOW COUNTY WHICH
IS COUNTY OF FOR THE SELLING
WOMAN AND THIS WILL TEACH
YOUNGER GENERATIONS HOW TO CAST
THE BALLOTS OF THEIR EXCITING
CONFIDENT WHEN THEY GO TO THE
FOLK FIRST POLL. EXPECT WE ASK
BIRD I THE- THIS BILL THANK.
THANK YOU ANY DESCRIPTION OF IT
ON THE SIDE OF. AND C. NONE THE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
BATES NO BELL I PURCHASED.
BRADFORD HI I CABALLERO I
CHIANG. DALY NO DODD. HI DORADO
AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROW BY HERTZBERG.
GROVE NOEL HERTZBERG. I HILL
AYE HUESO BY HER TITLE BY
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA. I AM
ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK NO MORALE. NO
NIELSEN NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH BY RUBIO. SKINNER. I
STERN BY STONE NO NUMBER. IOWA
CASKEY HI WINNER HI WILK HI THE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS FOR JUST NO.
CHIANG I. RUBIO HI. MARCH
THIRTY KNOWS NINE THE MEASURE
PASSES NEXT UP MEMBERS IS FILE
ITEM THREE SIX TWO SENATOR WELL
HE'S NOT AT HIS OWN AREAS. MISS
SECTOR PLEASE READ SOME OF
ELEVEN SEVEN TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AN ACT
RELATING TO SPECIAL EDUCATION.
SKINNER WOKE WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
DOING A GREAT JOB. A RISE 2% A.
B. ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TRAGIC EVENTS
IN EL DORADO COUNTY EXPOSE THE
URGENT NED FOR CHANGE IN
PRIVATE SCHOOLS. AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY TWO WILL REQUIRE
SPECIALIZED NON PUBLIC SCHOOLS
TO TRAIN STAFF AND POSITIVE
BEHAVIORAL BEHAVIORAL SUPPORTS
AND MAINTAIN A BEHAVIORAL
PROFESSIONAL ON SITE THE
SCHOOLS ARE ADJUSTING KIND OF
SCHOOL THAT ONLY SIR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES OR HIGH
NEEDS. AB ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO
WILL REQUIRE THE SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS TO ME COMPETENCY
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS HOLDING AN
ADMINISTRATOR ADMINISTRATOR
CREDENTIAL THIS WILL ALSO
REQUIRE MORE FREQUENT ONSITE
MONITORING AND REPORTING BY
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES.
FINALLY THE BILL WILL GET THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THAT
ABILITY TO. REVOKE
CERTIFICATION MORE QUICKLY WHEN
THE STUDENTS HEALTH IS IN
JEOPARDY AB ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO
ALLOWS STUDNTS WITH
DISABILITIES ARE HIGH NEEDS TO
HAVE A POSITIVE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT BY MENTORS WHO HAVE
THE SKILLS AND RESOURCES TO
ASSIST THEM. THIS BILL HAS
STRONG SUPPORT FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AND IS RECEIVE NO
NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OF
IT ON THIS ITEM. SHE NONE THIS
IS A CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM. JEANNIE
HEARING NINE. I JUST THIRTY
NINE. ARE WE ARE NOT. SO. ICE
THIRTY NINE A NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP MEMBERS
IS FILE ITEM THREE EIGHT SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMAN TING. SENATOR
SKINNER YOU PREPARED FOR THIS
ITEM. SHE'S PREPARED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN NINETY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AN ACT
RELATING TO FARMS. SKINNER
SKINNER WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THIS IS A FIVE AB FORTY
NINETY THREE IS ON. SAME
SUBJECT THAT THE BILL I
PRESENTED JUST FEW MINUTES AGO
WHICH IS THE PROCESS FOR
ISSUING. WHAT IS NOW CALLED RED
FLAG ORDER BUT WHICH OUR
STATUTE REFERS TO AS THE GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER. AND
WHAT THIS DOES IS IT ALLOWS THE.
THE PERSON WHO IS THE SUBJECT
OF THE GB RO TO SUBMIT A COURT
FORM STATING THAT THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO CONTEST THE ORDER SO
THAT'S THEIR DOES NOT HAVE TO
BE A COURT HEARING. CLEARLY IF
THE PERSON FOR WHOM THE GB RO
WAS ISSUED. FEEL SAID IT WAS
IMPROPERLY ISSUED OBVIOUSLY.
THEY DO NOT HAVE TO SIGN SUCH A
FORM AND THEY HAVE THE RIGHT
UNDER THE ORIGINAL STATUTE TO
HAVE A COURT HEARING AND TO
PETITION AND CHALLENGE THE
COURT FOR THE ISSUING OF THE
DVR ROW. BUT IF THE SUBJECT
WANTS TO WAIVE THE COURT
HEARING THIS JUST TO ESTABLISH
IS A PROCESS TO DO SO THAT IT
RELIEVES THE STRAIN ON THE
COURT AND RELIEVES THE NUMBER
OF COURT HEARINGS AND WITH THAT
I ASKED FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DESCRIPTION OF IT ON THE SIDE
ON. KERN SEEN NONE THIS IS
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL HERE.
ICE THIRTY NINE A NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM THREE NINE EIGHT CENTER
PORTANTINO FOR ASSEMBLY WOMAN
WORKS. WHEN YOU'RE READY. PASS
TEMPORARILY ALL RIGHT. MOVING
ON NOW TO FILE ITEM FOR ALL
NINE SENATOR RUBIO. ARE YOU
PREPARED. GIVE ME A MINUTE TO
GET YOUR TEST. READ MY LIPS.
YES THANK MISTER SECRETARY
WE'RE GONNA HAVE FILE ITEM FOUR
NINE. PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMMUS AN ACT
RELATING TO PEOPLE HEALTH
SENATOR RUBIO WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO RESENT AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN THIS BILL
EXPANDS THE SUICIDE PREVENTION
POLICIES AT SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
DEVELOP TO INCLUDE A POLICY ON
YOUTH SUICIDE PREVENTION FROM
KATE THROUGH SIXTH GRADE
SUICIDE IN ALL PARTS OF OUR
SOCIETY AND ALL AGES RANGE AT
IS AN EPIDEMIC AND WHILE THE
ISSUE OF ADOLESCENT SUICIDE
HOUSE. RECIEVE FOCUS AND
RESOURCES IN RECENT YEARS.
RATES OF SELF HARM SUICIDE OF
MY YOUNGEST IN OUR COMMUNITIES
HAVE TRAGICALLY INCREASED AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN SEEKS TO
BUILD ON THE WORK OF LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES BY
EXPANDING SUICIDE PREVENTION
POLICIES. TO BEGIN TO ADDRESS
YOUTH SUICIDE ARE YOU
SPECTRALLY ASPER GUIDEBOOK. ANY
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. AND SHE NINE MS SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES HI
BILL I PURCHASED AYE BRADFORD
AYE CAMBIADO I CHIANG BY DALY
AYE DODD. HI THERE ALSO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG. I
HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TITLE. I
JACKSON AYE JONES. NO LEYVA. I
AM A CHOIR HI MITCHELL. BY
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK. RAIL.
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER HI
STERN BY STONE. NO NUMBER HI MY
COUNTY AYE WIENER AYE WILK.
SECTOR PLEASE CALLED UP TO
MEMBERS ATKINS GROVE. MORE LOCK
MORRELL. WILK WILK AYE. PRICE
THIRTY FOUR NOTES TO THE
MEASURE PASSES. BRENT TOOK
TEMPORARY PAUL'S INACTION
.
MEMBERS WHEN WE START BACK WILL
BE GOING TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT SHORTLY SENATOR
WILK AND WILL BE PROCESS IN
ADDITION OF BILLS THAT WILL BE
TAKEN UP SHORTLY
. MEMBERS WE'RE
MOVING TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS SENATOR WOKE ARE
YOU PREPARED. ALL I'VE BEEN
MORE THAN PREPARED MISTER
PRESIDENT IT THANK YOU JOINT
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN WHICH IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF JENNIFER OSBORN
IS THE DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION
OF ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES AT
CDC ARE. PART OF THIS
APPOINTMENT AND MISS OSBORNE
SPENT FIVE YEARS AS A DEPUTY
SECRETARY AT THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY. AND THIRTEEN
YEARS AS AN ANALYST AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SHE WAS
APPROVED BY UNANIMOUS FIVE A
VOTE BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
THE TWENTY FIRST OF AUGUST.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
ABOUT. ANY DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE. THE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES. HI BILL BY
BURGESS BY BRADFORD I COUNTY AT
ALL I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD
I DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER YEAH I GONZALEZ I GROW.
I HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE TADO. I JACKSON AYE JONES I
LEYVA. LEYVA. MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL I MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK I'M REAL BY NIELSEN AYE
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. AYE AMBERG. IOWA CASKEY
I WINNER HI WILK I. SIX THIRD
PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBERS.
ATKINS LEYVA. ONE MOMENT. SHE'S.
WELL SENATOR MOVES A CALL. YOUR
WORK THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN IS A CONFIRMATION OF
RALPH D. AS AS THE SECRETARY OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION MR DSS SPENT
HIS ENTIRE TWENTY YEAR CAREER
WITH THE CDC ARE STARTING AS A
CORRECTIONAL CADET IN NINETEEN
NINETY ONE HE SERVED IN
MULTIPLE ROLES AT CDC ARE
INCLUDING AS A CORRECTIONAL
COUNSELOR ADMINISTRATOR AND
WARDEN HE WAS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS FIVE A VOTE BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON AUGUST
TWENTY FIRST. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. SENATOR
NELSON. PRESENT LEADING CHEN
THE SENATE I WOULD ALSO URGE AN
AYE VOTE ON RALPH IDEAS AS OUR
AGENCY SECRETAR I AM FAMILIAR
WITH HIM AS HE IS PURSUED A
LONG CAREER IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. THE ONE OF THE
MOST DIFFICULT JOBS STATE
GOVERNMENT. ALMOST NOTHING IS
PLEASANT ABOUT THE JOB. BUT
HE'S DONE THE STEADFAST WAY
OVER MANY YEARS HE'S WELL
WORTHY OF OUR YES WELL. THANK
YOU ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OF THE DEBATE ON THE
APPOINTMENT. HEARING EIGHTEEN
NINE MR KERRY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES BY BILL. GORGEOUS
BELLI. GORGEOUS HI BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE
DODD AYE DORADO AYE GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ. I
GROW AYE HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO. I TADO. I JACKSON I
JONES I LEYVA. MCGUIRE BY
MITCHELL. BY MONNING I'M MORE
LOCKED I'M REAL. I NIELSEN. PAN.
HI PORTANTINO AYE AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER I STERN. I
STONE. HI NUMBER FIVE A COUNTY
I WINNER BY WILK HI. SIR TO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS LEYVA NIELSEN HI. OURS
THIRTY EIGHT. I'M GONNA MOVE
THE CALL WE'RE GONNA MOVE THE
CALL. SENATOR WORK. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF
LIKE 2% FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN WHICH IS THE
CONFIRMATION AFSHAN MCGUIRE TO
THE STATE ROUTE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD MISTER MCGUIRE IS
A PROFESSIONAL CIVIL ENGINEER
AND PREVIOUS PREVIOUSLY SERVED
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SECTION MANAGER FOR ITS
DIVISION OF WATER RIGHTS HE WAS
PROVED BY THE HE WAS APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
AUGUST THIRTY FIRST ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OF THE RAID
ON THE APPOINTMENT. HEARING
JUNE NINE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES. BELL.
IPURCHASE HI BRADFORD I CAN BE
AT ALL I CHIANG BY DAILY I DODD.
HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI. I
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. HI
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE HER TITLE I JACKSON BY
JONES. LEYVA MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL. BY MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK. MORRELL NO NIELSEN. I PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO. BY SKINNER I STERN AYE
STONE NO BURKE BOB OWSKI I
WINNER BY WILK HI. SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS BATES HI. JONES NO LEYVA.
MORE LOCK. REMOVE THE CALL.
YOU'RE WELCOME NEXT POINTING
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT WE
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN WHICH IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF LAUREL
FIRESTONE TO THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD MISFIRE
STONE IS THE ATTORNEY MEMBER ON
THE BOARD PRIOR TO THIS
APPOINTMENT SHE WAS THE CO
DIRECTOR OF THE COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER WHICH SHE CO FOUNDED IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SIX. SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON THE TWENTY FIRST OF AUGUST I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ANY DESCRIPTION OF IT ON
THE APPOINTMENT. STING HEARING
ON THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES. BELL HI GORGEOUS
HI BRADFORD I CAN BE ERA. I
CHIANG BY DAILY. DOT I DORADO.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TITLE.
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA.
MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL BY MONEY
I'M MORE LACKEY. WELL NO
NIELSEN. BY PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO I SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE NOVEMBER I HAVE
A COUNTY AYE WIENER AYE WILK HI
I. THE ROOM WILL MOVE THE CALL
CENTER. NEXT ONE SENATOR WHAT
TO PREPARE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY IS A CONFIRMATION
AS SEVERIN BORENSTEIN AND MERRY
LESLIE TO THE GOVERNING BOARD
OF THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
SYSTEM OPERATOR DOCTOR
BORNSTEIN IS PROFESSOR AT THE
UC BERKELEY HAAS SCHOOL OF
BUSINESS MISS LESLIE'S
PRESIDENT OF THE LOS ANGELES
BUSINESS COUNCIL IT IS A FORMER
COMMISSIONER AT THE LA
DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND POWER.
BOTH APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED
IN RULES COMMITTEE ON AUGUST
TWENTY EIGHTH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY
DESCRIPTION OF A SENATOR
HERTZBERG. YEAH VERY BRIEFLY MR
PRESIDENT YOU KNOW. SEVEN BORN
SEEN WORK WITH US ON THE ENERGY
CRISIS IN DEFENSE FANTASTIC JOB
BUT I. STAND IN HIS SUPPORT
MERRY LESLIE IS BEEN A FRIEND.
FOR MANY MANY MANY YEARS AND
HAS WORKED ON SO MANY ISSUES
THROUGHOUT THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY IS SOMEONE WHO IS
QUITE BRIGHT. HARD WORKER AND A
DESERVES OUR SUPPORT I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF BOTH OF THE NOMINEES
FOR CALLOUS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OF A. SENIOR NON SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARE SO
THAT A I ATKINS BATES HI BILL I
PORGES BY BRADFORD I CABALLERO
I CHIANG KAI DELI I DODD. I
DORADO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE. HI HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO AYE TADO I
JACKSON I JONES BY LEYVA
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. I MONNING
I'M MORE LUCK I'M REAL AYE
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG
OUR COUNTY I WINNER HI WILK BY.
JUNIOR WILL BE MOVES CALL.
CENTER THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT OUR FINAL GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT FOR THE DAYS FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE WHICH IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF DAVID OLSON TO
THE GOVERNING BOARD OF THE
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT SYSTEM
OPERATOR MISTER OLSON IS
SERVICE AN APPOINTEE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE IS
CURRENTLY THE CHAIR OF THE
BOARD HE WAS APPROVED IN THE
RULES COMMITTEE HEARING ON
AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTH. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE APPOINTMENT. IN SYRIANA
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARE SURE THAT AND I
ATKINS. BATES. BELL I BRIDGES I
BRADFORD. I CABALLERO. I CHIANG
I DALY. DODD I DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER BY GONZALEZ
I GROW. I HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO. HI TITLE I JACKSON
BY JONES. LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL. HI MONEY BY MORE LUCK
MORALE. NO NELSON. PAN. I
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER. TYLER CASKEY BY
WINNER HI WILK HI HI. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALLED UP TO MEMBERS
ATKINS. WICKS. DALY NO. JONES
WARLOCK. NIELSEN HI AND I. VICE
THIRTY THREE KNOWS THREE THE
POINT IS CONFIRMED AT. MISTER
PRESIDENT MISSPOKE EARLIER NOW
IS GOING TO BE OUR FINAL THE
FIRST APPOINTMENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY TWO WHICH IS THE
CONFIRMATION TO MARIA HERRERA
FOR RE APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION
MISERERE HAS SERVED ON THE
BOARD SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN AND SHE'S A COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT MANAGER FOR SELF
HELP ENTERPRISES SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON THE TWENTY EIGHTH OF AUGUST
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE
BILLS. THANK YOU ANY DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THE APPOINTMENT.
HEARING EIGHTEEN NINE MS SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES. HI
BILL I BURGESS I BRADFORD I
CARRIER I CHIANG I DALY. DODD
I'D RATHER GO I GALGIANI.
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROW. BY
GALGIANI I. BURKE AYE HILL AYE
HUESO AYE HER TITLE. I JACKSON
I JONES. LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL HI MONNING I'M MORE
LUCK. MORALE NIELSEN. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
BY SKINNER. I STERN. I STONE. I
AM BURKE POWER COUNTY I WIENER
AYE WILK HI. SECRETARY CALL UPS
MEMBERS ATKINS DELHI BY. JONES
NO MORE LOCK. MORRELL NO. ICE
THIRTY SIX KNOWS TO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. OUR
MEMBERS WERE MOVING BACK TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS CONCURRENT
OF ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS WE'RE
STARTING OFF WITH FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE. ZARA. THE TWENTY
OFFICE THIS IS THE OKAY. SENATE
ALLEN YOU'RE PREPARED. MISS
SECRETARY PLEASE ROUTE. SENATE
BILL SIX FORTY ONE BY SENATOR
ALLEN AND NECK RELATED TO
ELECTIONS. WHEN YOU'RE READY
CENTER AL THANK YOU SEE PRESENT
MEMBERS THIS BILL WILL EXTEND
THE TIMELINE FOR SPECIAL ACTION
CONSOLIDATION FROM HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO HUNDRED DAYS FONG
ELECTION PROCLAMATION IT IT
COMES FROM A SERIES OF. OF
ELECTIONS THAT TOOK PLACE IN LA
A COUPLE YEARS AGO WHEN THERE
WAS A CASCADING EFFECT OF
OPENINGS AND THERE WAS THE
SITUATION WE LITERALLY HAD. ONE
ELECTION FOR ASSEMBLY THAN
COUPLE WEEKS LATER FOR THE
SCHOOL BOARD AND THEN THE
SECOND ROUND FOR THE ASSEMBLY
AND IT IS BECAUSE OF THE DATE
THERE WERE THERE WASN'T ANY
OPPORTUNITY TO CONSOLIDATE A
REALLY LED TO A CRAZY STRING.
OF ELECTIONS IN SENATOR RISES
DISTRICT OVER THE COURSE OF
SEVERAL MONTHS AND SO THIS THIS
WOULD ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IT IS
TO HAVE IT AS RECEIVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES. AND RESPECT RESTAURANT
I'VE A. ANY DESCRIPTION OF
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. TURN CENA
AND MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ON ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES HI
BILL. GORGEOUS HI BRADFORD ART
I CABALLERO I CHIANG I DALY. BY
DODD I DORADO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW AYE
HERTZBERG. HILL AYE HUESO BY
HER TITLE I JACKSON BY JONES I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. BY MITCHELL
HI MONNING. I'M MORE LUCK. I'M
A REAL. BY NELSON I PAN AYE
PORTANTIO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
AYE AYE NUMBER OUR CASKEY I
WINNER HI WILK HI. PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS BELL HI.
HERTZBERG HI. ALL EYES THIRTEEN
NINE AND NO ZERO. THOSE ARE THE
SENATE'S ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED AND NEXT UP MEMBERS
IS FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE SOONER
LEYVA. HIS SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR LEYVA AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH AND CARE
FACILITIES CENTER LEVEL. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBER
SENATE BILL TWO TWO SEVEN IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE SINCE
LEAVING THE SENATE SB TWO TWO
SEVEN HAS BEEN AMENDED TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS RAISED BY BOTH
THE OPPOSITION AND FELLOW
pMEMBERS TWO TWO SEVEN IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
CAN PROTECT PATIENT HEALTH AND
SAFETY HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HEARING CHAIN
NINE MR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OUR- I ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES.
BATES NO. BELL I PURCHASED.
BRADFORD HI KELLY EURO BY
CHIANG. NO DALY NO DODD. BY
DORADO I GALGIANI. GLAZER
GONZALEZ BY GROVE. NO HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TITLE.
JACKSON I JONES. NO LEYVA. BY
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. MONEY HI
MITCHELL I. MORE LUCK NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN NO PAN BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH BY RUBIO. SKINNER I
STERN. I STONE NO I'M BURKE. BY
KATHY. I WINNER BY WILK. THE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS GORGEOUS NO.
GALGIANI GLAZER HI TADO. RUBIO
NUMBER WILK. OUR EYES TWENTY
FOUR NOTES TO IN THE MOMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP
MEMBERS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO.
SENATOR HERTZBERG YOU'RE
PREPARED FOR THE SIGHT ON
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY NUMBER
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN APPLE INTO
EMPLOYMENT CENTER HERTZBERG
THANK YOU WAS PRESIDENT SAID
THIS MEASURE SB TWO TWENTY NINE
A SOLIDIFIES WHISTLE BLOWER
RIGHTS WELL IN THE LABOR
CONTENTS BY STRENGTHENING THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S ABILITY TO
CARRY OUT. A JUST LITIGATION
PROCESS THE AMENDMENTS WHICH
WERE SEEKING TO CONCURRENT NOW
FILL IN DETAILS IN THE FINAL
STAGES OF THE CITATION AN
APPEAL PROCESS AND CLARIFIES
WHEN THE CLERK CAN ISSUE A
MONETARY JUDGMENT. I ASK YOUR
RIVAL. ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING CHAIN NINE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
BATES NOBEL I PURCHASED.
BRADFORD HI I CABALLERO I
CHIANG BY DAILY NO DODD. I
DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
I GONZALEZ BY GROW. NO
HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO BY
HER TITLE I JACKSON BY JONES NO
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL
AYE MONNING BY MORE LUCK NO
MORALE NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH I RUBIO BY
SKINNER I STERN I STONE
NOVEMBER. IOWA CASKEY BY WINNER.
BY WILK HI. PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS BURGESS BOARD IS
NO. OUR ICE THIRTY KNOWS NINE
THIS SIMPLY MOMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. EXCEPT MEMBERS IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE SENATOR
DODD. SECRETARY PLEASE RATE
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
MOBILE HOME RESIDENCY CENTER
DOT THIS PRESIDENT MEMBERS TO
SEVENTY FOUR PROVIDES INCREASE
PROTECTIONS FOR MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
THIS BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION
OF IT ON ITEM. MMHM SEEN NINE
MS SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN WORKS FOR AYE ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES. HI BILL I BURGESS
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CHIANG
I DALY. I DODD HI DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ TO SAY I GROW.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE TITLE. I JACKSON I JONES I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING AYE I'M MORE LUCK.
A REAL. I NIELSEN. PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO. BY ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN
AYE STONE AYE HAMBURG IA CATHY
BYE WINNER HI WILK HI. SIX
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS GROVE. MORE LOCK
MOORLACH. BY NIELSEN. HI. MARCH
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIR CONCURRED
IN. NEXT UP MEMBERS IS FILE
ITEM. THIRTY EIGHT. SENATOR
HERTZBERG ARE YOU PREPARED TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT.
SB FOUR THREE EIGHT. CLERK WILL
READ CORPORATE IN A BILL FOR
THIRTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG ACKERLEY TO EMERGENCY
SERVICES CENTER BURKE HE'S SO
MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT THIS
MEASURE REQUIRES THE EMERGENCY
DISPATCH A SERVICES TO BE
COORDINATED BY GOVERNMENT
EXCEPT UNDER VERY LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THE
GOVERNMENT DECIDES OTHERWISE A
WITH THE LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICIALS ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
FURTHER REDEFINE THE PROCESS
AND REMOVE MUCH OF THE
OPPOSITION THE MEASURE HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH HOUSES RESPECT ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM
SENATOR BORDERS. WAS PRESENT A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR CENTERS
FOR WE ACCEPT A QUESTION NO
THANK YOU. IT WILL NOT TO
QUESTION. NO HE'S NOT GONNA
QUESTION. CALDERON. ALLEN
ARCHULETA. HI ATKINS. BATES.
BELL FIVE LARGEST NO BRADFORD
BY CARRIER. I CHIANG I DALY. NO
DODD. DURAZO. I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ BY GROW. NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY
TADO I JACKSON. BY JONES. NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
BY MONNING. BY MORE LOCK. NO
MORALE. NO NIELSEN HI. PAN HI
BY PORTANTINO. HI BY ROTH BY
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. BY NUMBER BY. WHAT
COUNTY BY WINNER BY WILK BY.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE UP TO
MEMBERS ALLEN HI. ATKINS BATES.
NO DODD. GROVE NOTIFY. THE
SECTOR CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
OVER TIME ATKINS DOT. HI IS
THIRTY TWO NO SIX THE CEMENT
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
NEXT UP IS ITEM FORTY BY
SENATOR GALGIANI MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SIX THIRTY TWO BY SENATOR
GALGIANI AN ACT RELATED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY CENTER
GALGIANI THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THE AMENDMENTS
REQUIRE THE BOARD TO MOVE THE
DATE BY WHICH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW IS DUE FROM JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
FEBRUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
AND REQUIRE THE BOARD TO ADOPT
THE FINAL PROGRAM E. I. R. THE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
RIVALS. THANK YOU ANY
DESCRIPTION OF A ON THIS ITEM.
XENON WAS SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA BY
ATKINS BATES. HI BILL I BURGESS.
I BRADFORD HI I CABALLERO I
CHIANG KAI DELI HI DODD. I
DORADO. I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL. BY WITH SOME HI TITLE.
HI JACKSON. HI JONES. I LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE. MITCHELL. HI
MONNING. HI MOORLACH. I AM A
REAL. BY NELSON. PAN BY
PORTANTINO. I ROTH BY RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE. BY
OUR CASKEY. WINNER HI WILK. BY.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS GROVE.
MCGUIRE BY GROW BY NIELSEN BYE
BYE CASKEY. WHAT HEALTHCARE. I
JUST THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN
. MEMBERS WILL BE MOVING
SHORTLY BACK TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING JUST GIVE US A FEW
MOMENTS AGO AT OUR FALL IN
ORDER
. ART MEMBERS WERE GOING
BACK TO THOSE ITEMS THAT WE
HAVE ON CALL WE'RE STARTING
WITH FILE ITEM FIFTEEN
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BATES BELL HI BURGESS. HI JANE
BY DALLY. BY THE RAZA. I JONES
NO MORE LOCK. NIELSEN. ALL
RIGHTS THIRTY FOUR KNOWS THREE
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
NOW MEMBERS REMOVING UP TO FILE
ITEM FORTY SEVEN S. R. FIVE
FIVE. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. DALY BY MORE
LOCK. CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER
ONE MORE TIME. MORE LOCK. WELL
I GOT. AYE AYES FORTY KNOWS.
HE'S VERY UP BY THE EYES FORTY
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MEMBERS REMOTE ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY TWO. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLY. I GROWTH.
GROW BY ICE FORTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. WELL IN THE
FILE ITEM ONE THREE SIX. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DELHI BY GLAZER
BY MORLOCK. HI. ICE FORTY NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE FIVE
ONE MR. ONE FIVE ZERO. THE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS. DALLY BY. ICE FORTY NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MOVING ON THOSE FILE ITEM ONE
FIVE ONE MR KERRY PLEASE CALLED
OUT FOR MEMBERS. BATES NO. DALY
NO GLAZER BY. ICE THIRTY ONE
KNOWS NINE AND THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE FIVE SIX MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES CHIANG.
DOLLY NO ROVE. PAN. BY WILK.
OUR EYES TWENTY NINE KNOWS
SEVEN THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
SIX ZERO. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
LOCK. I PAN HI ALL EYES FORTY
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MOVING ON TO ONE SIX SEVEN FILE
ITEM ONE SIX SEVEN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBER. PAN PAN AYE.
I SUPPORTING NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WERE
LOOKING TO CALL ON FILE ITEM
ONE SEVEN SIX MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. WICKS NO.
MCGUIRE AYE MORLOCK. PAN I.
NUMBER. ALL EYES TWENTY SEVEN
KNOWS TEN ON THE URGENCY ALL
EYES TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS TEN ON
THE MEASURE. EXCEPT MEMBERS IS
FILE ITEM ONE SEVEN NINE. IT'S
SECTOR PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
BATES. MORE LOCK. MORRELL PAN.
BY RUBIO BY. BY AGE THIRTY
THREE KNOWS THREE THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON NOW MEMBERS
TO FILE ITEM. ONE NINE FIVE MS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALLED OUT TO
MEMBERS. ATKINS BATES. CARRIERA
BY DODD. THE RAZA. GLAZER HI.
DRAWS WHY THE TITLE HI MORRELL.
NIELSEN. PAN HI. DOT I MISS
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS BATES. MORRELL
NIELSEN. NIELSEN AYE STONE.
PRICE THIRTY FOUR KNOWS. FIVE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS HI
BATES. GORGEOUS DORADO BY
GROWTH. MORE LOCK. MERRELL NO
NIELSEN NO PAN HI. GROVE NOEL.
BATES NO. SEVEN HI IS THIRTY
ONE NO SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
TOOLS SIX SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS. I
BATES NO PORGES. NO CARRIER. HI
DORADO HI TADO. MORE LOCK.
NIELSEN NO PAN HI. WILK I DON'T
KNOW. CABALLERO WE HAVE AS I. I
COME HERE I DIDN'T KNOW. PRICE
TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS ELEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
TWO FIVE ONE MS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL ABSENT MEMBERS. FOR JUST.
CABALLERO JONES BRIDGES I.
CABALLERO HI JONES. NIELSEN. BY
HAND BY JONES I. VICE FORTY NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
TWO FIVE TWO RECEPTOR PLEASE
CALL ABSENT MEMBERS. WICKS
GORGEOUS. CHIANG HI DOLLY.
GROWTH. I JONES. MONNING I MORE
LOCK. MORALE NO NIELSEN. PAN.
GROW I TO KNOW. AYE AYES THIRTY
ONE KNOWS THREE THE MEASURE
PASSES. NO MEMBERS ARE MOVING
TO FILE ITEM TWO FIVE THREE
PLEASE CALL THEM SAID MEMBERS.
GROWTH. I PAN HI VICE FORTY NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO FIVE
FIVE THIS SECTOR PLEASE CALL
OUT TO MEMBERS. GORGEOUS PAN.
PAN I. A THIRD TO A THIRTY
THREE. ICE THIRTY THREE NO SIX
THE MEASURE PROCESS. NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TWO FIVE SEVEN. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BATES HI. THIS DALLY. GROVE
MORE LOCK I AND- I STONE. VICE
THIRTY FIVE NOSE ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE BACK TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBERS.
ATKINS HI LEYVA HI. SIZE FORTY
NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN
MS SECTOR PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS. ATKINS HI LEYVA BY ICE
FORTY NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT
IS CONFIRMED. FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN. ATKINS HI LEYVA I
MORE LOCK. ICE THIRTY SIX KNOWS
THREE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
FILE ITEM NINETEEN MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS I BATES. DELHI
DORADO HI TADO. LEYVA I MORE
LOCK. VICE THIRTY THREE KNOWS
THREE THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED ARE FOR THE FINAL
APPOINTMENT IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
HI LEYVA HI. AYE AYES FORTY HAD
NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. THAT IS ALL OF OUR
HALL CURRENT CALL ITEM TO
ANNOUNCE. ALL RIGHT MEMBERS
WERE GONNA RETURN BACK TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING AND
WE'RE GOING TO START OFF WITH
FILE ITEM ONE OH SEVEN. DOCTOR
PAN ARE YOU PREPARED. MISTER
SECRETARY WHEN YOU'RE READY
PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
TWENTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
AN ACT RELATING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. DOCTOR PAN THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT SENATORS
PLEASE PERCENT EIGHTY SIX
TWENTY BY SUMMER COOLEY RELATED
TO SUDDEN UNEXPLAINED DEATH AND
CHILDHOOD WHICH IS DIFFERENT
FROM SIDS OR SUDDEN INFANT
DEATH IN INFANTS. EIGHTY SIX
TWENTY TO FIND SUDDEN
UNEXPLAINED DEATH AND CHILDHOOD
IN STATUTE REQUIRES CORNERS TO
INFORM THE PARENTS ARE GARDEN
GUARDIAN OF A CHILD WHO DIES
UNDER THESE CIRCUMSTANCES ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF TAKING TISSUE
SAMPLES FOR THE PURPOSE OF
FURTHERINVESTIGATION. SENATE
UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN CHILDHOOD
IS NOT NEW BUT IS RARE HAS BEEN
REPAIRED REPORTED INCIDENTS OF
ONLY ONE POINT TWO DEATHS PER
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN
HOWEVER IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
LEARN MORE ABOUT THIS AND
HOPEFULLY IDENTIFIED VARIOUS
CAUSES. THE BILL HAS BY FAR
SUPPORT AND ESPECIALLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
SIDE. THIS IS ALL DOUBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION FOR USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE SIDE
OF. YES. ALL RIGHT NO
OBJECTIONS ICE FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP
MEMBERS THIS FALL ITEM ONE
SIXTEEN. BY SENATOR ON BURKE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
AN ACT RELATING TO PLEA
BARGAINS SENATOR UMBERG WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS BILL
SIMPLY CLARIFIES THAT A PLEA
BARGAIN THAT REQUIRES THE
DEFENDANT TO GENERALLY WAVE
UNKNOWN FUTURE POTENTIAL
ASPECTS OF LEGISLATIVE
ENACTMENTS INITIATIVES IN
JUDICIAL DECISIONS OR OTHER
CHANGES MAY OCCUR AFTER THE
DATE OF THE PLEA. THAT IT IT
PRECLUDES THAT SORT OF FEE
WAIVER AND IS AGAINST PUBLIC
POLICY URGENT AYE VOTE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HEARING TING NONE
MISS SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES BELL I BRIDGES.
BRADFORD. BY BY CARRIER I
CHIANG I DALY. DODD HI DORADO
HI GALGIANI BY GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROW I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI FOR TITLE.
HI JACKSON. I JONES. HI LEYVA I
AM A CHOIR. HI MITCHELL. HI
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK THE RAIL.
NELSON. PAN AYE PORTANTINO HI.
ROUGH I RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN.
BY STONE. NO NUMBER. IOWA
CASKEY BY WINNER HI WILK HI.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALLED
UP TO MEMBERS BATES. POR JUST
BY DALY. MORE LOCK MORRELL.
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HIGH MORALE
CALL THAT SOME MEMBERS FROM
RETURN REAL NO. BATES HI DALY
MORE LOCK. FIVE THIRTY SIX NOSE
TO THE MEASURE PROCESS NEXT UP
IS FILE ITEM ONE FOUR ONE
SENATOR JACKSON YOU'RE PREPARED
SHE SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FORTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MURATSUCHI AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC LANDS.
SOONER JACKSON THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES SO I WOULD
LIKE TO PRESENT THIS MEASURE
WHICH WILL SAFEGUARD FEDERALLY
PROTECTED LAND AND NATIONAL
MONUMENTS THAT ARE LOCATED
WITHIN THE BORDERS OF OUR GREAT
STATE. IT WILL DO SO BY
PROHIBITING ANY STATE ENTITY
FROM ENTERING INTO AN INFRA
INCH INFRASTRUCTURE EXCUSE ME
AGREEMENT TO ENABLE OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION ON FEDERALLY
PROTECTED LANDS ON APRIL TWENTY
SIX OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN THIS
ADMINISTRATION THIS
PRESIDENTIAL ADMINISTRATION.
ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
REQUIRING THE US DEPARTMENT OF
THE INTERIOR TO CONDUCT A
REVIEW OF FEDERAL LANDS FOR NEW
RESOURCE EXPLOITATION NAMELY
OIL GAS AND MINERALS AS A
RESULT OF ITS INITIAL REVIEW
NATIONAL MONUMENTS IN UTAH
WE'RE SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED IN
SIZE AND WE'RE OPENED UP TO
MINERAL RIGHTS LEASING. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THE BUREAU OF LAND
MANAGEMENT AUTHORIZED THE
DRILLING OF A NEW WELL AN
INSTALLATION OF A NEW PIPELINE
WITHIN THE BEAUTIFUL COREY SO
PLAIN NATIONAL MONUMENT IN SAN
LUIS OBISPO COUNTY. EARLIER
THIS YEAR THE ADMINISTRATION
FINALIZED A PLAN TO OPEN OVER
ONE MILLION ACRES OF PUBLIC
LAND IN CALIFORNIA THE FURTHER
OIL AND GAS EXPLORATION AND
PRODUCTION. THIS PLAN WILL
AFFECT LANDS PUBLIC LANDS IN
ALAMEDACONTRA COSTA FRESNO
MERCED MODERATION BENITO SAN
JOAQUIN SAN MATTEO SANTA CLARA
SANTA CRUZ AND STANISLAUS
COUNTY. BY PROHIBITING THE
ISSUANCE OF SUPPORTING
INFRASTRUCTURE LEASES THIS
MEASURE WILL HELP PROTECT
FEDERALLY DESIGNATED LANDS
WATERS HISTORIC LANDMARKS
PREHISTORIC STRUCTURES WILDLIFE
NATURAL RESOURCES CRITICAL IT
COSTA ECOSYSTEMS AND
ENVIRONMENTS WITHIN OUR BORDERS
FROM THIS ASSAULT ON OUR
ENVIRONMENT WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM SENATOR BORDERS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT OF
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT. IN
THE IDEA OF NEW LEASE IS THAT
THAT WOULD ALSO INCLUDE A
RENEWAL. IF ANYONE KNOWS
OTHERWISE I'D LOVE TO HEAR THAT
BUT THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING.
AND SO I'M TRYING TO MAKE SENSE
OF IF WE HAVE EXISTING DRILLING
GOING ON RIGHT NOW THAT LEASE
IS IN PLACE. WHEN IT COMES UP
FOR RENEWAL THIS WOULD DISALLOW
THAT. SO I THINK WE WILL LAY
THE DISCUSSION YESTERDAY ON THE
FUTURE OF FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRIES IN CALIFORNIA AND
WHAT THAT MEANS FOR THE
IMPORTATION. FROM LESS THAN
DESIRABLE COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD INTO OUR ECONOMY. BUT I
THINK IF WE IF WE THINK THIS
THING THROUGH. THIS COULD HAVE
DIRE CONSEQUENCES IN COMPLETELY
RUN OUT OF BUSINESS FOLKS IN IN
THE FUEL INDUSTRY. SO THAT IS
MY CONCERN AND I'D I'D I DON'T
UNDERSTAND. THIS IS A
RELENTLESS PUSH TO DRIVE THIS
ENTIRE INDUSTRY OUT OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT LITERALLY WE
HAVE TO ABIDE BY THE LAW FUNDS
ABILITY WE'RE GOING TO GET IT
ELSEWHERE. AND I JUST DON'T I
DON'T SEE THE MERIT IN THIS IF
THEY'RE ABIDING BY THE RULES
AND THEIR EXTRACTING IN
CONFORMITY WITH OUR SAFETY
PROTOCOLS IN OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS WHY ARE WE ARE
PUNISHING THEM AND FORCING THEM
OUT OF BUSINESS. SO I THINK
THIS IS OF GRAVE CONCERN EVEN
THOUGH IT'S COUCHED IN
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION.
CENTER GIRL. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL AGAIN YESTERDAY WE
HAD A VERY BROAD DISCUSSION ON
ON OIL AND CALIFORNIA'S
CONSUMPTION INCREASES OF GONNA
HAPPEN WE STILL HAVE TO HAVE A
PLACE TO BUILD TO PRODUCE IT
UNDER THE MAASTRICHT
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY EVER WE
HAD THAT CONVERSATION YESTERDAY
BUT TO ADD TO THIS 45% OF
CALIFORNIA IS OWNED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO YOU'RE
BASICALLY ELIMINATING THE
ENTIRE CENTRAL VALLEY AND ALL
THE WAY AT THE CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA SO IF YOU JUST TAKE.
ON A MAP AND YOU TAKE THE
OUTLINE OF THE COASTAL AREA
ACROSS THE TOP OF CALIFORNIAN
AND DOWN TOWARDS NEVADA ARIZONA
AND THEN DOWN AT THE VERY
BOTTOM SANDIEGO THAT'S
EVERYTHING IN THE MIDDLE IS
OWNED BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SO YOU WOULD BE LIMITING
DRILLING AND PRODUCTION AGAIN
UNDER THE SAFEST ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY PER PRODUCED IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD. IS A DEFINITELY
THE NATION SO HOW MY COMMENTS
OF A LINE WITH WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE SAID FROM FRESNO THAT
YOU KNOW WE HAVE LEASES AND
WHEN THEY GO THROUGH PERMIT
PROCESSING FOR THE DIVISION OF
OIL AND GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
RESOURCES A LOT OF THESE LANDS
HAVE SURFACED RIGHTS AND
MINERAL RIGHTS AND THEY BECOME
TO DIFFERENT OWNERS SO MAYBE BE
A LIMB IS THE SURFACE RIGHT ON
BUT THE MINERAL RIGHT OWNER
BELONGS TO AN EVEN BE NATURAL
RESOURCES ARE A CHEVRON. THEN
THAT MEANS THEY HAVE TO GET A
LOCAL DOCTOR APPROVAL AND TO
GET APPROVAL FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO BE ABLE TO DRILL
ON THESE LANDS SO IT'S A DOUBLE
PERMIT PROCESS AND AS WE
DISCUSS DAGR YESTERDAY THERE IN
INDUSTRY FUNDED ORGANIZATION
THEY HAVE THE APPLICANT HAS TO
APPLY FOR A PERMIT IN ORDER TO
GET A DRILLING PERMIT AND THEN
WHEN THEY GET A DRILLING PERMIT
IT SENT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES FOR APPROVAL IT
SENT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF AND
THE AIR QUALITY CONTROL BOARD
FOR APPROVAL THEM BACK TO
DOCTOR AND THEN THE APPLICANT
HAS TO INDEMNIFY DAGR. WITH A
BOND SO THAT WHEN THEY GET SUED
BY THE- CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY YOUR. THE
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THAT. THE
DOCTOR DOESN'T HAVE TO PAY FOR
THAT THE APPLICANT DOES WHEN
THEY'RE DONE THEIR DUE PROCESS.
THIS IS A BLATANT ATTACK ON THE
OIL INDUSTRY AND- AGAIN WE AS
CALIFORNIANS HAVE NOT STOPPED
THE CONSUMPTION. WE CONTINUALLY
INCREASE OUR USE OF CONSUMPTION
ON OIL. BUT WE ARE IMPORTING
THAT FROM FOREIGN NATIONS THAT
ARE NOT BENEFICIAL TO AS
EITHER. FROM AN ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDPOINT OR A CIVIL RIGHTS
STANDPOINT. AND I WOULD JUST
ASK THAT YOU THINK ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF FEDERAL LANDS THAT
ARE OWNED. BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND WHERE THIS
RESTRICTS US FROM BEING ABLE TO
PRODUCE OIL AGAIN UNDER THE
STRICTEST. MOST ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY REGULATORY PROCESSES
EVER. WE TALKED YESTERDAY ABOUT
BUNKER FUEL I BELIEVE. AND
THOSE VESSELS THAT BRING THAT
OIL TO US BECAUSE WE CONTINUE
TO CONSUME IT WHEN IT WHEN IT
ARRIVES IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY WE EXPORT A HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS. OFF OF THAT
PARTICULAR VESSEL AND THE COST
TO FOREIGN COUNTRIES. AND NOT
ONLY THAT COLLEAGUES THE BUNKER
FUEL THAT IS USED TO BRING THAT
FUEL TO S. HAS THE HIGHEST
SULFUR CONTENT. OF ANY FUEL
EVER AND IF YOU'LL MAYBE THEY
JUST ONE OF THOSE TRIPS YOU TO
ELIMINATE ALMOST EVERY TAIL
PIPE IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. THE WEEK. AND SO I
THINK IF WE LOOKED AT THIS FROM
A GLOBAL PERSPECTIVE AND WE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRODUCE.
DELEGATE PRODUCING JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA. UNDER THE STRICTEST
ENVIRONMENTAL. IMPACTS THAT WE
HAVE IN IF NOT THE NATION THE
WORLD THIS WOULD BE BETTER FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. AND ADDRESS
GLOBAL SITUATIONS AS WELL. AND
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR NO VOTE. THANK YOU IN
ADDITION. IN ADDITION
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM HEARING AND SEEING NINE
CENTER JACKSON GEORGIA CLOSE
THANK YOU WELL I WHILE I
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION AND
LOOK FORWARD TO AT SOME POINT
TALKING ABOUT OIL AND GAS
EXPLORATION AND GLOBAL CLIMATE
CHANGE IN CALIFORNIA'S GOALS
THEY TRY TO REDUCE OUR USE ON
OIL THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL
IS ABOUT. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
NEW LEASES NEW LEASES. NEW
LEASES. NOT RENEWING NEW LEASES
AND IT'S NOT ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL IS
SPECIFICALLY. PERTAINS TO AREAS
THAT ARE IN NATIONAL MONUMENTS.
THE PLACES WHERE WE TAKE OUR
FAMILIES TO VACATION WHERE WE
GET TO CELEBRATE THE NATURAL
BEAUTY OF OUR LAND. THIS IS OUR
A MEASURE THAT ADDRESSES I
ENERGY EXPLORATION AND
PRODUCTION IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORIC LANDMARKS PREHISTORIC
STRUCTURES WILDLIFE NATURAL
RESOURCES CRITICAL ECOSYSTEMS.
AND THE ENVIRONMENT AT STAKE
HERE SO WHILE THIS IS A
FASCINATING DISCUSSION FOR
WHICH I ALWAYS APPRECIATE
HEARING THE ARGUMENTS THAT
EXIST ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT WE
SHOULD PAY ANY ATTENTION TO
CLIMATE CHANGE OR NOT THIS BILL
ISN'T ABOUT THAT. THIS BILL IS
ABOUT NEW LEASES IN THESE
PRISTINE AND IMPORTANT AREAS.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA ATKINS
BATES. BELL. HI PORGES NO
BRADFORD. CARRIERA CHANGE. DALY
NO DODD. HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH NO HERTZBERG.
HI HILL AYE HUESO. HI TADO.
JACKSON I JONES. NO LEYVA. HI
MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL AYE MONNING
I'M MORE LOCK. MORRELL NO
NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO
I ROTH. RUBIO. SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE NO NUMBER I
WOULD COUNTY AYE WIENER AYE
WILK. WITH SO I DON'T KNOW
GALGIANI I DIDN'T KNOW.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS ARCHULETA. ATKINS WICKS.
BRADFORD ZERO CHIANG MURTADA
MORE LOCK. ROTH RUBIO WILK. SIR
JACKSON MOVE A CALL. MEMBERS
WERE NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY SIX. SENATOR WIENER
ARE YOU SHE CENTER WHEN YOU'RE
PREPARED SECRETARY PLEASE RATE
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TWENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD ENACT
RELATED TO ELECTRICITY. SKINNER
WINNER I THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD I RISE TO PRESENT
AB TEN TWENTY SIX WHICH IS SIX
TWO ESTABLISHED THE SAME LEVEL
OF CLARITY AND THE DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION OF UTILITY LINE
EXTENSIONS. AS I WHICH
CURRENTLY EXISTS FOR THE FIRE
AND SAFETY UNLIKE SAFETY
STANDARDS AND BUILDINGS.
CURRENTLY THE PARAMETERS SET BY
BY INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES FOR
THE DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION OF
POWER LINE EXTENSIONS. ARE NOT
CODIFIED IN THE STATUTES. THIS
MEANS THAT THE RULES OF THE
GAME FOR POWER INTERCONNECTION
CAN CHANGE WELL AFTER
CONSTRUCTION HAS ALREADY
STARTED. AND IN EXTREME CASES
ONE CONSTRUCTION IS ALMOST
COMPLETE. THIS BILL WILL MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT ONCE AN
ELECTRICAL OR GAS CORPORATION.
HAS APPROVED OTHER CONSTRUCTION
DESIGN AND SPECIFICATIONS FOR
PROJECT. THE UTILITY HAS ALSO
APPROVED THE INTERCONNECTION
RULES WITH WHICH TO
CONSTRUCTION MUST COMPLY FOR
EIGHTEEN MONTHS. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO ELIMINATE
COSTLY UNAVOIDABLE DELAYS. AND
THE PRODUCTION OF HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
A HEARING ON THIS IS ACCOUNTED
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION AND
APPLYING TO UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
TO THIS. MEASURE SHE NINE. ICE
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP MEMBERS IS FILE
ITEM ONE OF FIVE FOUR SOONER
HERTZBERG YOU'RE PREPARED MRS
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE TWENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA AND ACT
RELATED TO EKORNES. CENTER
HERTZBERG. MISTER PRESIDENT
THANK YOU AND MEMBERS OF THIS
GREAT SENATE. IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT. FIFTY FOUR POINT
FIFTY NINE POINT 4% OF THE
VOTERS PASSED PROPOSITION SIX.
WHAT IN PROPOSITION SIX SAY. IT
MADE THE SLAUGHTER AND SALE OF
HORSES FOR HUMAN CONSUMPTION.
ILLEGAL. IT PROHIBITED THE
SENDING HORSES OUT OF
CALIFORNIA FOR SLAUGHTER TO
OTHER STATES OR COUNTRIES FOR
HUMAN CONSUMPTION THAT'S WHAT
THE MEASURE SAID AND DESPITE
ITS PASSAGE BY THE VOTERS
COURSES IN CALIFORNIA CONTINUE
TO BE SOLD INTO THE SLAUGHTER
PIPELINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
IS SEEKING TO CORRECT THAT WITH
THIS MEASURE AB ONE TWENTY
EIGHT WILL STRENGTHEN THE LONG
STANDING PROTECTIONS TO WHICH I
JUST REFERRED. WITH THE
SLAUGHTER OF WILD HORSE TO
DOMESTIC COURSES BY REQUIRING
THE FOLLOWING FOUR THINGS
FIRST. A SIGN MUST BE POSTED
ANYWHERE HORSES ARE SOLD
EXPLICITLY STATING THAT THE
SALE OF HORSES FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION IS A FELONY TO.
ANYONE PURCHASING A HORSE AT AN
AUCTION MUST SIGN A STATEMENT
ACKNOWLEDGING IN AGREEING TO
COMPLY WITH CALIFORNIA'S BAN.
ON THE SLAUGHTER OF HORSES
THREE. AUCTION OPERATORS MUST
PROVIDE SALE RECORDS AND OTHER
DOCUMENTS UPON REQUEST OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE OR ANIMAL CONTROL
AGENCIES AND YOU MAIN OFFICERS
FOR. AUCTION OPERATORS MUST
EXAMINE HORSES FOR IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION LIKE BRANDS INTO
TWOS AND MICROCHIPS AND MUST
MAKE THAT INFORMATION AVAILABLE
ONLINE. THE OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE OF WHICH ARE ONLY A FEW
ORGANIZATIONS SAY THAT THIS
WEAKENS THE LAW. IT PROVIDES
AND SUPPLEMENTS SERVICE
SUBSTITUTE CIVIL PROCESS
PROCEEDINGS FOR CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS WELL THE BILL SAYS
IN A SPECIFIC LANGUAGE ON PAGE
FIVE LINE TWENTY FOUR. IN
ADDITION TO ANY OTHER PENALTIES
AVAILABLE UNDER LAW DOES NOT
LIMIT THE FACT THAT THIS IS A
FELONY GET INQUIRES IT REQUIRES
ADDITIONAL CIVIL PENALTIES THE
COALITION OF FIFTEEN
ORGANIZATIONS FOR MARANDA SAN
DIEGO. ALL ACROSS THE STATE TO
CALIFORNIA IN THEIR FLORA LORD
INDICATE THAT THEY'VE GOTTEN
LEGAL OPINIONS TOGETHER BY BOTH
PRIVATE LAWYERS AND LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL INDICATED THIS MEASURE
DOES NOT IN ANY WAY WE CAN
PROPOSITIONS SIX. PROPOSITION
WAS IS IMPORTANT IT WAS VOTED
THROUGHOUT ALL THE COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA WITH GREAT SUPPORT.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
FILL THE HOLES SO TO SPEAK IN
TERMS OF WHAT THE PEOPLE OF
SAID IN DEALING WITH THE
SLAUGHTER OF HORSES IN
CALIFORNIA. I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. ANY ADDITIONS
CHRISTIAN RATE ON THE SIDE ON
BY MEMBERS. HEARING INSANE
NINE. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
BY BILL. GORGEOUS. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO. I CHIANG I DALY NO
DODD. HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE TITLE. JACKSON I JONES. NO
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL.
HI MONEY I'M MORE LUCK MORALE.
NO NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. BY ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE. NO
AMERICA IOWA CASKEY I WINNER BY
WILK. WILK HI. MR TO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BELL HI
FOR JUST. GROVE. BY TITLE I.
MORE LUCK. I JUST THIRTY THREE
KNOWS FIVE THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MEMBERS WERE NOW MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY SEVEN BY
SOON GLORIA. BEING PRESENTED BY.
SENATOR PAN IF YOU. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE ROUTE ASSEMBLY
TO A RESOLUTION NINETEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA RELATIVE
TO REFUGEES. SENATOR PAN THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT SENATORS
EIGHTY ARE NINETEEN CALLS UPON
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
RESETTLE ALL THIRTY THOUSAND
REFUGEES THAT THE UNITED STATES
HAS COMMITTED TO RESETTLE IN
THE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
NINETEEN. CALIFORNIA HAS LONG
BEEN A WELCOME HOME FOR
REFUGEES RESETTLED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AM PROUD THAT MY
OWN DISTRICT HERE IN SACRAMENTO
WITH MANY REFUGEES HAVE BEEN
SETTLED FROM PLACES LIKE
AFGHANISTAN AND IRAQ. FIJI
RESETTLEMENT IS A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT INVOLVES FEDERAL STATE
COUNTY AND NONPROFIT ENTITY SO
IT IS OF UTMOST IMPORTANCE.
EVERYONE COMES TOGETHER AS
UNITED EFFORT HOWEVER
UNFORTUNATELY HAS NOT BEEN THE
CASE IN FEDERAL LEVEL IN RECENT
YEARS THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION'S FACETTI CUT
THE NATION'S REFUGEE ARRIVALS
AND OF HAS AFFECTED THE
ELIMINATED ALMOST HALF OF THE
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT SPOTS
AVAILABLE IN THE WORLD. OUR
COUNTRY HAS WELCOME FEWER THAN
ELEVEN THOUSAND REFUGEES SO FAR
AND MORE THAN HALFWAY THROUGH
THE YEAR. AT THIS RATE TODAY
MISTER SHE'LL COME NOWHERE NEAR
RESELLING THE THIRTY THOUSAND
GOAL A GOAL WHICH PALES IN
COMPARISON TO THE HISTORIC
AVERAGE COMMITMENT OF NINETY
FIVE THOUSAND REFUGEES ANNUALLY.
CONGRESS AND THE PRESIDENT HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO CONTINUE TO
STAND BEHIND THIS INCREDIBLY
VALUABLE POPULATION AS THEY
HAVE DONE IN THE PAST. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE CAN
ALL COME TOGETHER AROUND. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
INSANE NINE MS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA. ATKINS BY BATES BELL
I PORCHES BRADFORD AYE AYE
CABALLERO AYE CHIANG BY DAILY.
DODD DORADO I GALGIANI. I
GLAZER. GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI
GROWTH. THE THING THAT THEM
HERTZBERG. HI HILL. BY HUESO. I
TITLE BY JACKSON. BY JONES.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING I'M MORE LOCK
MORALE. NIELSEN. PAN BY
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE.
NUMBER OUR CASKEY BY WINNER BY
WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MISS SECRETARY
ARCHULETA BY. BATES GORGEOUS.
DALY DODD. HI GLAZER BY GROWTH.
JONES MORE LOCK WELL NIELSEN
STONE WILK. OUR EYES THIRTY NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM OF ONE EIGHTY SENATOR
DORADO YOU'RE PREPARED THE
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO SEVENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY AN ACT
RELATING TO RESOURCE
CONSERVATION. IN ORDER ALSO
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
SPEAKER PRESIDENT I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
WHICH WOULD EXPAND THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR WHO CAN APPLY
TO JOIN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS. CORPS
MEMBERS LEARN SKILLS SUCH AS
FORESTRY MANAGEMENT ENERGY
ODDITY IN AN INSTALLATION
EMERGENCY SERVICES MANAGEMENT
AND FIRE FIGHTING IN OFTEN EARN
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS AND
INDUSTRY CERTIFICATIONS AT THE
END OF THEIR SERVICE. AB TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT WOULD ALLOW BUT
NOT REQUIRED THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE COURT TO
CONSIDER APPLICATIONS FROM
PEOPLE ON PAROLE AND EACH
APPLICATION WILL BE LOOKED AT
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS. THIS
PROVIDES A MUCH NEEDED
OPPORTUNITY FOR ADDITIONAL
EDUCATION WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
TRAINING AND A SENSE OF
ACCOMPLISHMENT TO YOUTH THAT
ARE CURRENTLY EXCLUDED FROM
BECOMING CORPS MEMBERS THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. AND HAS NO OPPOSITION
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION SENATOR NELSON. IS
PRESENT IN JENIN THE SENATE THE
THIS BILL HAS MERIT BUT ONLY
WITH QUALIFICATIONS. IT APPEARS
THAT IT ASSUMES THAT ALL
PAROLEES ARE. ELIGIBLE TO YOU
BE HANNAH FIRE CAN'T. IN
CALIFORNIA. THE DAY DO NOT HAVE
SERIOUS PROBLEMS THAT WOULD
CAUSE THEM TO BE A DANGER.
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS IN THE
COMMUNITY. AND WHEN YOU'RE IN A
FIRE CAMP. YOUR AND COMMUNITY.
POST RE ALIGNMENT. OF
CALIFORNIA DUMPED THOUSANDS OF
INMATES AND PAROLEES INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES. IN A FIRE CAMP
SERVER SANCHES BEEN MORE
DIFFICULT. TO GET. THE FIRE
INMATE FIREFIGHTERS. AND IN THE
CAMPS. IN MAY ON STAFF. AN
INMATE ON INMATE. INCIDENCES OF
VIOLENCE HAVE GREATLY
ACCELERATED. I'VE GOTTEN CALLS
FROM THE OFFICERS IN THE CAMPS
OVER THE YEARS REPEATEDLY. BIG
KNOWLEDGE IN THIS FACT. AND THE
DIFFICULTY THAT THEY HAVE. TO
DEAL WITH IT. ALSO IT BECOMES A
WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY. FOR
MERCHANDISING AND TRANSPORTING
DRUGS. IN THAT FREE ENVIRONMENT.
FIGHTING FIRES IN THE POOREST
IN THE WILD LANDS. ALWAYS VERY
EASY TO FIND PICK UP SPOTS.
THAT TRAFFIC MOVES. IF THIS
WERE RESTRICTED THEN TO CERTAIN
CLASSIFICATION SCORES WHILE IN
PRISON. CERTAIN REHABILITATIVE
REQUIREMENTS. THEN I WOULD HAVE
A CONVERSATION. BUT IT DOES NOT.
IT IS SIMPLY A NOTHER WAY. TO
GET MORE INDIVIDUALS OUT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES SOME OF WHICH- NOT
BE THERE. SENATOR DALLY. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESENT MEMBERS
ACTUALLY RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION. AS
SOMEBODY WHO HAS TRIED EMPLOYEE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE HAD MISFORTUNE
IN THEIR LIVES IT IS DIFFICULT
AS AN EMPLOYER TRUST ME TO TRY
TO GET A PAROLE THE BACK ON
THEIR FEET IN. AND MAY AND I'VE
BEEN CHALLENGED AND TRY TO HELP
THOSE FOLKS BUT I'VE I LOOKED
AT THE AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL.
I THINK THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ALLOW THEM TO BE ABLE TO
WORK GET A SKILL. AND MAYBE
YEAH THERE'S GOING TO BE
OPPORTUNITIES BUT THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES WITH. ANYONE IN
THIS FIELD THAT HAS COME OUT OF
THAT. SITUATION AND I THINK
THAT. THE WRIST THAT WE'RE
TAKING IS MINIMAL THEY THEY DID
TAKES AMENDMENTS WERE SEX
OFFENDERS. COULDN'T BE ALL IN
THIS PROGRAM AND I'M ENCOURAGED
OF SOMEBODY WHO ALL MY LIFE
LIVED A MILE AND A HALF. FROM A
CONSERVATION CAMP. THAT HAD NO
LOCKS ON THE GATES ONE WARDEN
WATCHING THEM. THERE THE WHOLE
TIME THEY'RE THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY
AB ONE OH NINE. AS PUSHED OUT
IN PROP FIFTY SEVEN AND FORTY
SEVEN HAVE. YOU'LL PUT MORE
PEOPLE ON THE STREET BUT WE
HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO
REHABILITATE THESE PEOPLE.
TRAIN THEM SO THEY ACTUALLY
KNOW HOW TO WORK AND THEN TRY
TO GET THEM BACK IN THE WORK
FORCE. ANY WE JUST WERE ABLE TO
GET A FEW IT WOULD MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN OUR SOCIETY SO I
AM GOING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND I WILL BE WATCHING IT TO
SEE HOW SUCCESSFUL IS TO TRY TO
BREAK THAT RESET IS IN RATE OF
FOLKS WHO ARE IN THE SYSTEM. I
CONTINUALLY ARE INCARCERATED
THE GOAL HERE IS TO TRAIN THEM
UP GIVE THEM SOME SELF PRIDE BE
ABLE TO HAVE A JOB. DO SOME
THINGS WE NEED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES LIKE FIRE SAFE OUR
COMMUNITIES SEVERAL FOLKS ARE
OUT WORKING RIGHT NOW IN THE
FORCED THINNING AROUND OUR
COMMUNITIES. THAT WERE
INCARCERATED BEFORE SO I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION I THINK IT'S A GOOD
START. AND YES THERE'S ALWAYS
RISK IN EVERYTHING YOU DO BUT
AT SOME POINT YOU HAVE TO TAKE
THOSE RISKS. TO HELP SOME OF
THOSE OUT THAT MAY BE
MISFORTUNE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL. THANK YOU THE
PRESIDENT QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR. WE TAKE A QUESTION YES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IN MY READ OF AB TWO SEVEN
EIGHT SUGGESTS TO ME THAT IT
WOULD CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PAROLE LEAST TO THEN BE
CONSIDERED FOR INCLUSION IN IN
IN THE CONSERVATION CORPS IS
THAT CORRECT MIGHT WRONG. THANK
YOU MAY RESPOND YES THAT IS
CORRECT THANK YOU SO IT OR TO
READ ABOUT PAROLEES YES ON MY
OWN TIME IS THE PRESIDENT
PEOPLE ALREADY SERVED THEIR
TIME AND HAD BEEN PAROLED BACK
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES ARE WHAT
THIS BILL ADDRESSES I WOULD
FURTHER REMIND ALL OF US. THAT
40% OF THE FIREFIGHTING MEN AND
WOMEN WOMEN I BELIEVE THAT
COMPRISE CAL FIRE OUR CURRENT
EDC OUR RESIDENTS FOR THE LACK
OF A BETTER TERM. 40% OF CAL
FIRE FIREFIGHTERS ARE CURRENT
RESIDENTS THE CDC OUR THAT'S
OUR CURRENT STATUS QUO AND AS I
RECALL AND BUDGET COMMITTEE
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT WAYS IN
WHICH TO EXPAND FUNDING FOR CAL
FIRE I HOPE TO STAND CORRECTED
IF THIS IS THAT THIS FACT IS
NOT TRUE. THAT THERE HAS NEVER
BEEN A REPORT. A COMMUNITY
MEMBER. ABOUT A CD C. R.
FIREFIGHTER BEING
INAPPROPRIATE. OR AND SOMEHOW
SOME WAY COMPROMISE IN THE
PUBLIC SAFETY. AND SO FOR THOSE
REASONS EVEN THOUGH WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A COMPLETELY
SEPARATE POPULATION I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
TO GIVE PAROLEES. WHO HAVE
SERVED THEIR TIME AND HAVE BEEN
PAROLED BACK INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES BACK HOME AN
OPPORTUNITY THROUGH THE
CONSERVATION CORPS TO RECEIVE
TRAINING. AND EDUCATION TO BE
ABLE TO BE SELF SUFFICIENT OUR
AND FOR FEEL THEIR RE ENTRY
EXPECTATIONS I STAND IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SEVEN EIGHT. THANK
YOU SENATOR GROW THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN EIGHT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BEST A
SOLUTION TO POVERTY AND BEING A
JOB AND THEN THE BEST SOLUTION
TO KEEPING PEOPLE OUT OF PRISON
IT'S MAKING SURE THAT THEY HAVE
A JOB OF TO KEEP THEM OUT OF
PRISON BECAUSE I THINK THAT
SHOWS A SELF ACCOUNTABILITY
THIS WORK IS NOT EASY IT'S HARD
IT'S ON A FIRE LINE IT'S
DIGGING TRENCHES IT'S
SEPARATING BRASH IT'S NOT EASY
WORK IT'S VERY HARD WORK. AND I
THINK THAT WHEN THEY FINISH
THIS TYPE OF PROGRAM THEY HAVE
DEVELOP SKILLS THAT THEY WOULD
NORMALLY NOT GET ANYWHERE ELSE
EXCEPT FOR ON A JOB AND THAT'S
GETTING UP SHOWING UP ON TIME
BEING AT WORK ON TIME DOING A
GOOD JOB AND IT ALSO I THINK
GIVES THEM A SELF IMPORTANCE OF
PROTECTING AND SERVING THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE WITH FIRE
LINES AND THINGS LIKE THAT THEY
PROTECT HOMES AND PEOPLE'S
HOMES AND THEIR RESOURCES AND
WHAT THEY REQUIRED TO BE TAKEN
NOT BE TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM
BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE ACTUALLY
GO OUT AND WORK ON THE FIRE
LINE. AGAIN IT DOES IT PRESENT
IT PREVENTS RECIDIVISM FROM
PEOPLE RETURNING ACTUALLY GOING
BACK TO PRISON AND SO I THINK
THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT PIECE
OF THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AND IT'S A READ SPONSOR BULL
PIECE OF LEGISLATION IT JUST
DOESN'T ALLOW CRIMINALS OUT TO
LET THEM RUN FREE AND DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT AT ANY TIME
LIKE YOU KNOW RIPOFF ELDERLY
PEOPLE AT NINE HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS A DAY JUST GET A TICKET
THIS IS A RESPONSIBLE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE
TO WORK IN A WAY AND DEVELOP
SKILLS AND ABILITY TO KEEP THEM
OUT OF PRISON SO I WOULD
SUPPORT. AN AB TWO SEVENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU SENATOR. HI
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION. ON THIS
ITEM SEEING AND HEARING NONE
SENATOR ALSO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
COMMENTS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. I
ARCH LETTER I ATKINS AYE BATES
HI BILL. I PORGES BY BRADFORD I
COME A EURO I CHIANG. DALY I
DOT HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ BY
GROWTH I HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO BY DATO I JACKSON. I
JONES. LEYVA BY MCGUIRE. I
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK. MORRELL NIELSEN NO. HI
PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE AYE
AMBERG IOWA CASKEY I WINNER BY
WILK HI. SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS CHIANG. HI JONES.
NO MORE LOCK BY MERRELL. NO.
VICE THIRTY SEVEN NOES THREE
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
WERE MOVING WE'RE LIFTING THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM ONE FOUR ONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
ATKINS BY BATES. BRADFORD
COUNTY AT ALL. W. I. JANE TACO
MORE LARK ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO.
WILK. HI TWENTY THREE KNOWS
NINE THE MEASURE PASSES. OUR
MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO FALL
ITEM ONE EIGHTY SEVEN. SENATOR
HUESO YOU'RE PREPARED FOR THIS
ITEM MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL THREE EIGHTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA AND ACT RELATED TO
ENERGY EFFICIENCY CENTER HUESO
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT A.
B. THREE EIGHTY SIX WILL
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT TO DEVELOP. AND
ADMINISTER THE AGRICULTURAL
WORKING FOR ENERGY EFFICIENT
HOUSING PROGRAM THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO PROVIDE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND FARM WORKER OWN
HOUSING USUALLY PEOPLE LIVE IN
A FARM WORKER HOUSING HAVE MORE
MORE PEOPLE OF PER PER HOUSING
UNITS IN THE MOST HOUSING
UNITS. AND THESE ARE HOUSING
UNITS THAT ARE USUALLY USUALLY
MANUFACTURED HOUSING OR OTHER
HOUSING PRODUCTS THAT DON'T
NORMALLY COMPLIED PROGRAMS BUT
THESE FAMILIES DESERVE TO HAVE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY INSTALLED IN
OUR HOMES AS WELL THIS SORT OF.
SUPPORT OUR OUR WORKERS IN THE
IN THE FIELD AND SUPPORT THEM A
TO MAKE SURE THEY CAN ALSO SAVE
ON THEIR ELECTRIC BILLS AND
THAT THEY HAVE. WHETHER ICE
HOMES AS WELL. SO ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE FOR THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. FURTHER DISCUSSION
SENATOR NELSON. LADIES
GENTLEMEN SENATE I RISE IN
SUPPORT. THERE IS INDEED A NEED
FOR AGRICULTURAL WORKER HOUSING
CALIFORNIA'S THEIR LONG HAS
BEEN. THIS IS A POSITIVE STEP.
TOWARDS THAT END. TO
ORGANIZATIONS THAT I'VE BEEN A
AFFILIATED WITH OVER THE
DECADES THE CALIFORNIA EVEN
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION AND THE
LOCAL OPERATIVE A CAPPUCCINO
HAVE BEEN VERY INVOLVED IN THIS
KIND OF ISSUE. WEATHERIZATION
OF FARM WORKER HOUSING AND
PROVIDING IN FACT. ARM WORKER
HOUSING THIS IS A POSITIVE AND
NEEDED STEP I URGE AN AIBO. IN
ADDITION A DESCRIPTION DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE SENATOR HUESO
WHICH ELECT CLOSE. SIMPLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE TODAY THINGS
ARE CURED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES BY BILL BY BURGESS.
BRADFORD I CABALLERO HI JANE.
HI DALY I DODD. HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI. HI GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TITLE
I JACKSON. I JONES NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK. MORRELL
NIELSEN HI PAN. BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH I RUBIO. HI INNER. BY
STERN AYE STONE NOVEMBER OUR
COUNTY BY WIENER AYE WILK I.
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BURGESS HI. MORE LOCK
MORRELL. ICE THIRTY SIX KNOWS
TO THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TOO OLD TO SENATOR JACKSON
IS REPAIRED AND SHE SECRETARY
YOU MAY READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN TWENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO AN ACT RELATING TO
RECYCLING. SENATOR JOCKS THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
RECYCLING SOMETHING THAT IS A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF
FOR THE FUTURE THIS PLANET BUT
ONE THAT IS HAD A- CHALLENGING.
GO ADD TO MAKING THINGS
ACTUALLY HAPPEN AS INTENDED
THIS IS A BILL THAT'S GOING TO
PROVIDE THE STATE WITH TOOLS TO
ADDRESS THE DEFICIENCIES THAT
EXIST IN THE CARPET STEWARDSHIP
PROGRAM. AND TO IMPROVE
INCENTIVES FOR CONSUMERS TO BUY
EASIER TO RECYCLE CARPET OR
CARPET WITH RECYCLED MATERIAL
CONTENT. SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
ALLOWS FOR A BRIDGE PLAN IN THE
CASE OF STEWARDSHIP
ORGANIZATION CEASES OPERATION
OR A PLAN IS DISAPPROVED. TO
PROTECT CONSUMER FEES AND
CONTINUING TO CONTINUE
RECYCLING THE BILL REQUIRES THE
TRANSFER OF THE AN EXPANDED
CONSUMER FEES TO BE DEPOSITED
INTO A TRUST OR ESCROW ACCOUNT
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE THE
PROGRAM. NOW DO DO A HISTORY OF
NONCOMPLIANCE WITH STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS THE DEPARTMENT OF
RESOURCES RECYCLING AND
RECOVERY OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CAL
RECYCLE. NEEDS LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY TO PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT TO MEET
OUR STATE RECYCLING GOALS TO DO
THIS THIS BILL INCREASES THE
AMOUNT AN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE CAN ASSESS FOR A CIVIL
PENALTY IN ORDER. TO TRY TO
GAIN GREATER COMPLIANCE. IN
ADDITION THE BILL REMOVES IN
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS CAP IN
ALLOWS CAL RECYCLED TO FULLY
RECOVER ITS ADMINISTRATIVE IN
ENFORCEMENT COSTS FOR THIS
PROGRAM WHICH IS WHAT WE DO FOR
OTHER A PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
PROGRAMS AND FINALLY THE BILL
DIRECTS THE STEWARDSHIP
ORGANIZATION TO IMPLEMENT A
DIFFERENTIAL ASSESSMENT. THAT
WILL INCENTIVIZE CONSUMERS TO
BUY GREENER CARPETS THE GOALS
OF THE BILL ARE SIMPLY TO GIVE.
OUR OR TO MAKE RECYCLING OF
CARPETS IN THIS MATERIAL MORE
ATTRACTIVE AND AVAILABLE TO
CUSTOMERS AND THIS BILL WILL
GIVE OF CAL RECYCLE THE TOOLS
TO OVERSEE THE PROGRAM TO MEET
OUR STATE'S RECYCLING GOALS IN
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR GROW. MISTER PRESIDENT
I RISE RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET YOU GUYS TO THINK
ABOUT THE WHOLE PICTURE ON
THINGS IBM. I RECENTLY GOT
CALLED TO GO TO A TRAILER PARK
EACH CD NEEDED SOME HELP WITH
SOME STUFF GOING ON AND WHEN WE
GOT THERE THEY WERE MATTRESSES
AND CARPET AND BUGS AND IT WAS
JUST IT WAS NASTY LIKE NO ONE
SHOULD LIVE LIKE THAT AND SO WE
WALK THROUGH WE GOT AT CITY
SERVED COMMITTED TO A COMPLETE
CLEAN AT. GOT TRASHED COMPANIES
TO DONATE THEIR OF DUMPSTERS TO
DO A CLEAN UP AND THE RESIDENTS
REALLY TOOK PART IN IT BUT I
MEAN YOU GUYS KNOW ME RIGHT I
GET OUT THERE WITH ALL THOSE
RESIDENTS AND I'M LIKE HW DO
YOU LIVE LIKE THIS LIKE WHAT
WHAT IS THE DEAL HOW DO YOU
LIVE LIKE THIS THIS MAKES NO
SENSE THAT SHE WOULD LIVE IN
THIS GARBAGE. AND ONE OF THE
RESIDENTS SPOKE UP AND HE GOES
WELL. IT DOESN'T FIT IN THE
BLUE CAN. IT DOESN'T FIT IN THE
BROWN CAN. IT DOESN'T FIT IN
THE GREEN CAN. I DON'T HAVE A
TRUCK. TO HAUL IT TO THE
LANDFILL. AND I DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY TO PAY THE FEE. SO IT
ENDS UP. RIGHT THERE. AND I
JUST THOUGHT WELL WHAT A
REALITY CHECK AND I HAD NO
IDEA. THAT THAT WAS ONE OF THE
ISSUES AND WHEN I TALK TO MY
COUNTY CHAU. AND I CHALLENGE
ALL OF YOU GUYS TO TALK TO YOUR
COUNTY CIOS HE SAYS THAT'S THE
BIG ISSUE ONE ILLEGAL DUMPING.
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE WILLING TO
PAY THE FEES ASSOCIATED WITH
TAKING. THESE THINGS TO THE
LANDFILLS. AND SO IT'S EITHER
PEOPLE THAT CAN AFFORD TO DO IT
THAT WON'T DO IT TO THE DO
ILLEGAL DUMPING. OR IT'S THE
POOR. THAT WE SERVE. THAT LIKE
THAT RESIDENT SAID. DOESN'T FIT
IN THE BLUE CAN DOESN'T FIT IN
THE GREEN CAN DOESN'T FIT IN
THE BROWN CAN. AND I DON'T HAVE
THE MONEY OR THE VEHICLE TO
TRANSPORT THIS TO A LANDFILL.
SO I WOULD ASK YOU TO THINK. ON
A BROADER SCALE. I REALIZE WE
ALL WANT TO DRESS.
ENVIRONMENTAL THINGS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES BUT WE
NEED TO TAKE CARE OF THE
CONSTITUENTS WE SERVE AND SEE
HOW IT'S AFFECTING THEM
DIRECTLY AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY URGE. A NO VOTE.
ANY ADDITIONAL DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SENATOR ALAN I JUST TO ADDRESS
THE COMMENTS ABOUT MY FRIEND I
YOU KNOW I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO GO TO A CORPORATE RECYCLING
FACILITY I HEAR THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED I SHARE SOME
OF THE BUT IN THE END OF THE
DAY THIS IS ABOUT. HAVING YOU
KNOW MAKING SURE THAT THE FOLKS
WHO EVEN TRUSTED IN ENSURING
THAT THERE IS A GOOD PROGRAM IN
PLACE I HAVE THE POWER TO. YOU
KNOW TO ENSURE THIS CAN MAKE IT
PROGRAM AND IF YOU TALK TO
FOLKS IN ADMINISTRATION THEY
WILL GIVE YOU. A SERIES OF VERY.
HEALTH CONCERNS ABOUT THE WAY
THAT THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTED. SO I'M I'M
COMFORTABLE WITH VOTING FOR THE
BILL TODAY. I THINK WE ALL NEED
TO STAY ON THE AGENCY AND
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE FOLKS
IN THE INDUSTRY. TO ENSURE THAT
WE COME UP WITH IS A GOOD
OUTCOMES HERE. BY IN THE END OF
THE DAY THIS IS ABOUT REALLY
MAKING SURE THAT THIS PROGRAM
WHICH IS REACHES THE GOALS.
THAT THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO
REACH AND- YOU KNOW I'S GONNA
INVOLVE A COLLABORATIVE PROCESS
BUT I GUESS I INVITE MY
COLLEAGUES TO. TO REALLY
ENGAGE. AT TO ENSURE THAT THE
WE REACH OUR GOALS HERE AND
THAT'S WHY I'M COMFORTABLE BUT
WHEN THE BILL TODAY. THANK YOU
CENTER ALLEN MEMBERS WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR. SEE NINE CENTER
JACKSON DO YOU LIKE CLOSE
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES. YOU SEE
PART OF WHAT THIS IS TRYING TO
DO IS TO FIND A WAY THAT THESE
PRODUCTS WILL NOT JUST BE
DUMPED OUT ON THE STREET THAT
IS THE GOAL. SO THE PROGRAM IS
DESIGNED TO OR IS INTENDED TO
AND THUS THE WORK THAT'S BEING
DONE IS GOING TO TRY TO ACHIEVE
THE GOAL. OF HAVING CARPET
INSTALLERS TAKE BACK THE CARPET
WHEN THEY PUT THE NEW CARPET.
AND THAT WHEN A PROFESSIONAL
COMES TO INSTALL A FLOOR THEY
WILL REMOVE THE CARPET THAT IS
WHAT WE ARE ATTEMPTING TO
ACHIEVE WITH THIS BILL WHICH IS
I THINK A VERY LAUDATORY GOLDEN
ONE WHICH I THINK WE- SHOULD
CERTAINLY ALL SUPPORT. ARE
THERE IS A PROCESS NOW THAT'S
BEING EVALUATED WE'VE SEEN
AREAS WHERE WE'VE NOT BEEN ABLE
TO GET A PEOPLE. THIS IS AN
EFFORT NOW TO GET INTO PERHAPS
THE RECYCLING TWO POINT OH ON
THIS THE PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL. IS TRYING TO DO IS TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO MAKE THIS
WORK AND TO PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
GOING TO INSTALL THE NEXT ROUND
TO TAKE THOSE MATERIALS AND GET
RID OF THEM THE WAY WE DO WITH
TIRES FRANKLY. WHEN YOU GO TO
GET A NEW SET OF TIRES YOU GIVE
THE YOU GIVE THE COMPANY THE
OLD SET OF TIRES AND YOU PAY A
SMALL FEE. AND THOSE TIRES AND
THEN REMOVED SO THAT THEY'RE
NOT IN A LANDFILL OR WHERE WE
END UP WITH THESE. TIRE FIRES A
GO ON FOR A YEAR OR TWO OR
THREE AND THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
THIS IS GOING TO BE A RETURN
PROGRAM A PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY PROGRAM. THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO
WORK ON AND TO IMPROVE UPON AND
THAT'S THE REASON WE'RE HERE
AND THAT'S WHY I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. MISTER SPEAKER CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA ATKINS HI BATES NOBEL
I BRIDGES NO BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I CHIANG NO DALLY I
DOT HI. SO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
DOT ON. NO NO JACKSON HI JONES
NO LEYVA. MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL.
I MONNING I'M MORE LOCK NO
MORALE NO NIELSEN NO PAN.
PORTANTINO ROTH. BY RUBIO. HI
SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER. BY CASSIE I WINNER BY
WILK NO. WE'RE GONNA CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONCE THEY WERE
GONNA CLOSE THE VOTE DOWN MR
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
BRADFORD. GLAZER HI HUESO.
LEYVA AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE NUMBER. BRADFORD HI. NUMBER
GUY. HI IS TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS A
LEVIN THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TO TEN CENTER WORKING
PREPARED TO PRESENT HE IS
MISTER SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FORTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
ENACT RELATED TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. EIGHTY NINE
FORTY THREE AUTHORIZES THE USE
OF FUNDING FROM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE'S STUDENT EQUITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAM TO BE USED
FOR EMERGENCY STUDENT FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO HELP AN ELIGIBLE
STUDENT OVERCOME UNFORESEEN
FINANCIAL CHALLENGES THAT WOULD
DIRECTLY IMPACT THE STUDENT'S
ABILITY TO PERSIST IN THE
STUDENTS COURSES STUDY SEARCHES
THE NEED FOR FOOD OR SHELTER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. HEARING SHE NINE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BELL I BRIDGES
ARE BRADFORD I CARRIER ALL. I
CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD HI
THERE ALSO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ. GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY TITLE I JACKSON. I JONES I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING BY MORE LOCK.
MORRELL I NIELSEN. PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE AYE
AMBERG BY WHAT COUNTY I WINNER.
I WILK BY. THIS. SIX PLEASE
CALL ABSENT MEMBERS. GONZALEZ.
HI MORE LUCK BY NIELSEN. PRICE
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. RIGHT NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM TO THIRTEEN. SENATOR
GLAZERS OUR. JUST A MOMENT.
RUNS LIKE A GAZELLE. IT TAKES
CENTER. THE SECTOR PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TWENTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON AN
ACT RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION
SENATOR GLAZER THANK YOU OF
THIS PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT THIS BILL ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON IT IS ADISTRICT BILL
FOR HIM AND FOR ME IT REMOVES
THE OBLIGATION OF THE CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY TO REIMBURSE THE
STATE TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
AND DEVELOPMENT ACCOUNTS GRANT.
THAT THEY'VE RECEIVED TO IN
ORDER TO ADD TO IT A REGIONAL
TRAIL IT ALSO REQUIRES THE
COUNTY TO INCLUDE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE CONTRA
COSTA TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
ON THE IRON HORSE TRAIL QUARTER
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM I KNOW YOU
GUYS ARE ALL INTERESTED IN THAT
THIS IS A TRAIL THAT GOES
THROUGH. OUR DISTRICTS THIRTY
TWO MILES AND IT'S A GREAT TO
TRANSPORTATION IN QUARTER
ALTHOUGH. BY FEET. THE BILL
RECOGNIZES THAT CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY HAS INVESTED IN THESE
DIFFERENT PATHWAYS DIFFERENT
WAYS OF GETTING AROUND IN THIS
PART OF THE WORLD. AND WITHOUT
A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. CENTER
STONE MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TEN TWENTY
FIVE CONTRA COSTA COUNTY WAS
AWARDED A GRANT OF TEN POINT
SIX MILLION TO BUILD A TRANSIT
FACILITY INSTEAD SPEND THE
MONEY ON A NATURE TRAIL THIS IS
NOT A REASONABLE USE OF MONEY
THAT WAS GIVEN FOR TRANSIT
PURPOSES I FIND IT
IRRESPONSIBLE TO PROPOSE
FORGIVENESS FOR THIS
MISMANAGEMENT OF FUNDS
CONSIDERING THE OUTCRY OF
TRANSIT ADVOCATES WHOSE A WE
ARE IN DIRE NEED A MORE
TRANSPORTATION REVENUE.
CALIFORNIA IS NOT IN A POSITION
TO GET THIS MONEY WHILE ALSO
TELLING TAXPAYERS WE NEED MORE
MONEY FROM THEM FOR
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS THE SECTOR
PREVENT US FROM FALLING THE
TRADITION A DUTY THAT WE OWE
OUR TAXPAYERS FOR THESE
REASONS. I ASKED FOR A NO VOTE
ON THIS BILL. ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HERE NINETEEN DONE
SENATOR CLOSURE WHICH OUGHT TO
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELL
THE COUNTY LOOKED AT THIS ISSUE
OF WHICH IS WHAT'S THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO MOVE PEOPLE
THEY LOOKED AT BY SWAYZE LOOKED
AT EXCLUSIVE MASS TRANSIT GUIDE
WAYS AND THEY CAME TO A
CONCLUSION THAT THEY WERE NOT
FINANCIALLY VIABLE DURING DUE
TO THE COST OF DEVELOPING THESE
DIFFERENT MODES. AND THEY CAME
TO A CONCLUSION THAT THE TRAIL
PATHWAYS WOULD BE ABLE TO BE
THE MOST EFFICIENT USE AND
THAT'S WHY THEY FAST THIS BILL
TO MOVE FOR BEEF MOVE FORWARD
ON THEIR BEHALF WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SIX THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE SIDE OF. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA. ATKINS BATES. NO
BILL HI PORCHES NO BRADFORD I
CABALLERO HI CHIANG. DALY. I
DODD I DORADO I GALGIANI.
GLAZER. GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ. HI GROW. I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I TACO AYE
JACKSON AYE JONES. NO LEYVA
TIME ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL BY
MONEY BY MORE LOCK. MORRELL
NOPE NIELSEN NO PAN HI
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN. BY STONE
NO AMBERG IOWA CASSIE I WINNER
BY WILK. THE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
HI ATKINS HI CHIANG BY. GROVE I
TO KNOW. MORE LUCK. WELL OCT HI.
FIVE THIRTY THREE NO SEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS
WERE MOVING BACK TO FILE ITEM
TWO THREE EIGHT. SENATOR PAN
ARE YOU PREPARED YES COURSE.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE MOVING BACK
221-321-4214 SENATOR STONE IS
PREPARED ME I'M SORRY STERN.
I'M. I HAVE TO FOURTEEN SO WHAT
WE ARE
. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
TWO NINETY YEAH. GOOD ALL RIGHT.
OKAY. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM TO
NINETEEN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE SIXTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AN ACT RELATING TO
ENDANGERED WILDLIFE SENATOR
STERN THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH ME HERE. AB TWELVE SIXTY
IS A CRITICAL MEASURE THAT WILL
PROTECT THOUSANDS OF ANIMALS
WHO ARE CURRENTLY SUBJECT TO
CRUEL PRACTICES THAT ARE FAR
PAST THEIR LIFETIME HERE
THOUSANDS OF EXOTIC ANIMALS ARE
KILLED EVERY YEAR FOR THEIR
SKINS. THE ANIMAL SUFFER
GREATLY FOR THE SAKE OF FASHION
IN VANITY EVEN THOUGH
ALTERNATIVES EXIST. THE BROAD
ARRAY OF LUXURIOUS CRUELTY FREE
MATERIALS AVAILABLE FOR USE
INCLUDING. EMBOSSED IMITATION
LEATHER THAT LOOKS AND FEELS
LIKE EXOTIC SKIN. REAL LEATHER
BUT THE KINDS OF. LETTER THIS
BILL CONCERNS INVOLVE HIPPOS
CAYMANS AND SEVERAL SPECIES OF
LIZARDS THAT ARE NOT ONLY AT
RISK OF IT EXTINCTION BUT NOT
THAT FASHIONABLE ANYMORE.
SEVERAL LARGE RETAILERS OF
ALREADY LED THE CHARGE IN
BANNING THE SKINS INCLUDING XIN
NOW IN TAYLOR H. AND M. ADIDAS
AND VICTORIA'S SECRET TO NAME A
FEW. NAME A FEW BUT IT'S TIME
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE TURN
THE PAGE AND BEGIN TO EVOLVE.
IF THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AB.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SEEING NONE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
NOBEL. I BURGESS. BRADFORD I
COVER YELLOW HI JANE HIGH DAILY
NO DOT. HI DORADO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ. GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG AYE HILL. I
WHISTLE HI TADO. I JACKSON BY
JONES. JONES NO LEYVA. BY
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. HI MONNING.
WARLOCK MORRELL. NO NIELSEN. NO
PAN. I PORTANTINO AYE ROTH BY
RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. NO I'M BURKE BY WHAT
CASKEY. BY WIENER AYE WILK HI.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BURGESS NO.
GONZALEZ I. MONEY BY MORE LUCK.
ICE THIRTY ONE KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WERE
MOVING BACK TO FILE ITEM TO
THIRTY EIGHT. SENATOR PAN ARE
YOU PREPARED. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO RELATIVE TO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. SENATOR PAN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER HAS SENATORS
PLEASED TO PRESENT ACR FIFTY ON
BEHALF OF SOME NUMBER TWO WHICH
ARE JUST THE LEGISLATURE'S
COMMITMENT TO REMOVING BARRIERS
TO GOOD JOBS AND CAREER
PATHWAYS AND ENSURING EQUITY
INCLUSION IN HIRING PRACTICES.
CALIFORNIA IS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD AND
IMMIGRANTS TO BECOME A
NOTEWORTHY IN GROWING PORTION
OF OUR ECONOMIC WORKFORCE.
DESPITE CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRANT
AND REFUGEE CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THE STATE THEY HAVE BEEN
LARGELY LEFT OUT OF THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT EQUATION.
STRUCTURAL BEARS INCLUDING
LANGUAGE ACCESS LED BY SECURE
COSTS AND OTHER REASONS SHUT
OUT THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
FROM WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND CONTRIBUTE TO
INCREASING IN A QUALITY. ACR
FIFTY HIGHLIGHTS THE IMPORTANCE
OF INVESTING IN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS ASPECT WE
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON ACR
FIFTY. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OF IT ON THE SIDE OF.
MEMBERS THIS IS A CANDIDATE
IT'S ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USE IN A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM. SCENE
NINE HIGHS THIRTY NINE A NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM CHIU FIFTY EIGHT. WE HAVE
SENATOR GLAZER ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR THIS ITEM FOLLOWING TWO
FIFTY EIGHT. AB FIVE EIGHT
EIGHT. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TEN AN
ACT RELATING TO ANIMAL SHELTERS.
SENATOR GLAZER THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I KNOW WE'VE
HAD A LONG DAY TODAY AND A LOT
OF A VERY COMPLEX AND DIFFICULT
ISSUES TO DEBATE BUT I
HOPEFULLY THIS IS ONE THAT
MAYBE CAN FIND BROAD SUPPORT
IT'S- THE IT'S A MEASURE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMAN CAN THAT
WOULD REQUIRE THAT ANIMAL
SHELTERS ARE RESCUE GROUPS.
DISCLOSE WHEN YOU'RE ADOPTING
OUT. INFORMATION THAT THEY
PROVIDE INFORMATION ON ON A
DOG. AND THEIR HISTORY OF
BITING. SO IF YOU'RE GONNA
ADOPT THAT ANIMAL WHICH IS A
WONDERFUL THING. THAT IF THERE
IS A HISTORY OF BITING THAT IT
BE PROVIDED TO THE PERSON DIED
THAT THE PLACEMENT IS BEING
DONE WITH. THE BILL HAS NO NO
VOTES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON BEHALF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM. EIGHTY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEN IN HEARING NONE
THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ON THIS
MEASURE. C. NINE HAI'S THIRTY
NINE KNOWS IS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON NOW TO FILE
ITEM TWO SIX SEVEN. SENATOR
MCGUIRE YOU PREPARED MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER AND
ACCOLADES TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY
SOONER MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS IS THE
NUMBER JONES HAS BEEN ADVANCE
IN THIS BILL NOW FOR TWO
STRAIGHT YEARS IN A ROW THAT
PRIOR TO THAT IS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WOODEN GREATLY APPRECIATE.
THEIR HARD WORK. AB THIRTY
SEVEN WOULD ALLOW CANNABIS
BUSINESSES THAT FILE A SOLE
PROPRIETORS OR IS PARTNERSHIP
SUBJECT ORDINARY NECESSARY
BUSINESS EXPENSES FROM THE
A DUCK EXPENSES INCURRED WHILE
CONDUCTING BUSINESS IS ENJOYED
BY ALL LEGITIMATE BUSINESSES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHEN FILING
TAXES YOU CAN DEDUCT YOUR RANGE
UTILITIES SALARIES EMPLOYEE
BENEFITS AND OTHER OFFICE
EXPENSES HOWEVER IRIS CODE
PROHIBITS ENTITIES THAT SELF
FEDERALLY CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
LIKE CANNABIS. TO BE ENERGY DR
FEDERAL SIDE OF TAXES AS A
RESULT CANNABIS BUSINESSES ARE
TAXED AT HIGHER RATES THAN ANY
OTHER LEGAL BUSINESS IN THE
STATE. THIS IS DESPITE THE FACT
THAT CALIFORNIA VOTERS CHOSE TO
BE ABLE TO ADVANCE THE LEGAL
SALE OF CANNABIS. SB THIRTY
SEVEN ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
ALLOWING CAMERAS BUSINESSES TO
CLAIM DEDUCTIONS FOR ORDINARY
BUSINESS EXPENSES THIS BILL
PROMOTE EQUITY IN THE SUCCESS
OF THIS LEGAL INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEN IN HEARING NINE A
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS. BATES NO BELL. GORGEOUS.
NO BRADFORD HI I CAL GYRO. JANE
DOLLY I DODD. HI THERE ALSO. I
GALGIANI. GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI
GROW. HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO AYE TANTO. JACKSON. JONES
HI LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE AYE
MITCHELL BY MONEY. BY MORE
LOCKED HIGH MORALE. NO NELSON
NO PAN. BY PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER. STERN HI
STONE. I AMBERG. BY KATHY. BY
WINNER. I WILK HI. GALGIANI AYE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS. BELL BY
CABALLERO I CHIANG. GROWTH
MURTADA. JACKSON SKINNER.
NUMBER I'M A GUY. MR KERRY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME ATKINS CHIANG.
CHIANG II GROWTH TACO. JACKSON
SKINNER. SKINNER I. ICE THIRTY
TWO KNOWS FOR THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP MEMBERS IS FILE
ITEM TWO SEVEN SEVEN. STATE
SENATOR WINNERS PREPARED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE SEVENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON AN ACT
RELATING TO FOSTER CARE SENATOR
WINNER I THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT AB
ONE SEVENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON. WHICH I SIX TO
MODERNIZE THE FOSTER YOU BILL
OF RIGHTS BY ADDING RIGHTS THAT
ARE INCLUSIVE OF THE NEEDS AND
EXPERIENCES OF TODAY'S YOUTH.
FOSTER YOU HAVE TO OVERCOME
UNENDING BURDENS AND OF HIGHER
RATES OF UNEMPLOYMENT. AND
INCARCERATION THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE HAVE FEW PEOPLE TO TURN
TO CAN HELP THEM TO UNDERSTAND
THE RESOURCES AND RATES. ARE TO
RETURN TITLED. IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. AB ONE SEVENTY
FIVE WIDE PROVISIONS THAT
INCLUDE THE RIGHT TO RECEIVE
GROOMING AND HYGIENE PRODUCTS
REGARDLESS OF SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. OR GENDER IDENTITY
THE RIGHT TO BE REFERRED TO BY
THEIR PREFERRED NAME PRONOUN.
ON THE RIGHT TO HAVE REASONABLE
ACCESS TO COMPUTER TECHNOLOGY.
AND THE INTERNET I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NINE FIVE A. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HEARING AND
SEEING NONE MISS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES NOBEL
HI PORGES. NO BRADFORD I CAN BE
AT ALL I CHIANG. DALY NO DODD.
HI THERE ALSO. I GALGIANI.
GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE OR TITLE. JACKSON I JONES.
NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I'M MORE
LUCK. MERRELL NO NELSON. PAN
AYE PORTANTINO. HI ROTH I RUBIO.
I SKINNER. STERN. BY STONE NO
NUMBER OUR COUNTY. BY WINNER I
WILL I. SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS CHIANG.
GALGIANI BY GROWTH TACO.
MOORLACH NO NIELSEN. SKINNER HI.
CALL THEM UP TO MEMBERS RUMORED
JOHN ATKINS CHIANG. ROVE NO
TILE DOESN'T. THE SECRETARY ONE
MORE TIME ON THE SIDE OF ATKINS.
CHIANG TADO HI NIELSEN. THAT'S
WRAPPED IN YOUR PICTURE. OZ
TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES. EXCEPT ITEM
MEMBERS IS ITEM FILE ITEM TWO
EIGHTY ARE AB TWO ELEVENS TERM
ACQUIRE YOU'RE PREPARED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO ELEVEN BY SOME MEMBER
CALDERON AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY. SOONER
MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
THE PRESIDENT MEMBERS AT
GRATEFUL TO MAJORITY LEADER
CALDERON FOR ALL THIS WORK AND
AB TWO ELEVEN WHICH CREATES A
TAX DEDUCTION FOR CONTRIBUTIONS
TO A SCHOLAR SURE FIVE TWENTY
NINE ACCOUNT IT LIMITED TO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR SINGLE
FILERS AND TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR JOINT FILERS. CALIFORNIA IS
ONLY ONE OF SEVEN STATES IN THE
NATION WITH A PERSONAL INCOME
TAX THAT DOES NOT OFFER A
PROACTIVE TAX INCENTIVES FOR
SAVING WITH THE FIVE TWENTY ONE
FIVE TWENTY NINE PLAN EXCUSE ME
THIS JUST MAKES SENSE AND IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE TREASURER. FOR IN A MALL
AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. KERN
SEEING NONE THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL AS ARE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING
ANNOUNCED UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ON THIS ITEM. C. NINE HAI'S THE
THIRTY NINE. THERE IS AN
OBJECTION. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS WERE
GONNA ASK FOR YOU TO A NINETY
EIGHT ANSWER VERY CLEARLY WE
HAVE A HARD TIME HEARING YOU SO
IF YOU'RE VOTING TO MAKE IT
CLEAR. THAT SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES. HI BILL I
PURCHASED HI BRADFORD BY
CARRIER I CHIANG. I DALY AYE
DODD. HI DORADO. GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY TITLE. JACKSON JONES HI
LEYVA BY MCGUIRE. BY MITCHELL
BY MORNING BY MORE LUCK.
MORRELL BY. NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. BY ROTH I RUBIO BY
SKINNER. BY STERN AYE STONE AYE
AMBERG POWER CASSIE I WIENER BY
WILK. HI THE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS
THERE ALSO. HI TADO. HI JACKSON
BY MORE LUCK. TATO NO I DON'T
KNOW. ICE THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS
ONE THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MEMBERS REMOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TWO EIGHT NINE DOCTOR PAN
IS PREPARED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ DIED ON. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE EIGHTEEN BY SOME IN
NUMBER TWO AND ACTUALLY MEDI
CAL. SENATOR PAT. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS
CENTERS EIGHTY THREE EIGHTEEN
BY SUMMER KANSEN Q. REQUIRED
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
AND MANAGE CARE PLANS TO FIELD
TEST MEDI CAL DOCUMENTS ARE
TRANSLATED INTO DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRED DEPARTMENT CONSULT
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND DESIGNATE
A READABILITY EXPERT IN ORDER
TO REVIEW AND REVISE AT LEAST
TEN KEY MEDI CAL DOCUMENTS FIVE
THESE DOCUMENTS ARE EXPLICITLY
SPECIFIED IN THE BILL AND SOME
GUIDELINES PROVIDED IN ORDER.
TO ENSURE THAT THE MOST
IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS INCLUDES
PROCESS. AT LEAST ONE IN THREE
MEDICARE RECIPIENTS DOES NOT
SPEAK ENGLISH AS THEIR PRIMARY
LANGUAGE AND THIS BECOMES
PROBLEMATIC. BECAUSE TRANSLATE
MATERIALS THAT MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES RECEIVE. ARE
OFTEN WRITTEN AT EITHER TOO
HIGH OF A READING LEVEL USES
ARGUES CONFUSING WORD CHOICES
THAN FOR ANYONE HERE WHO. HAS
EVER SPOKEN A SECOND LANGUAGE
OR HAS A SECOND LANGUAGE THE
NATIVE LANGUAGE WHENEVER YOU
SURVEYS YOU SEE TRANSLATIONS
AND YOU GO THIS TRANSLATION IS
TRULY. AN INTELLIGIBLE AND DOES
NOT MAKE SENSE SO IN ORDER THAT
HAS NOT HAPPENED TO THESE VERY
IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS PEOPLE NEED
TO UNDERSTAND WE WANT TO
ENSURE. THAT THEIR WRITTEN
CLEAR SIMPLE CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE LANGUAGE AND THAT'S
REVIEWED BY PEOPLE ACTUALLY
UNDERSTAND THE LANGUAGE THE
THIRD SAYS WHAT'S SUPPOSED TO
SAY. SO AB THREE EIGHTEEN OR
PROVE ACCESS TO MEANINGFUL
HEALTHCARE AND PROMOTE.
POSITIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES. ARE
STRICTLY ASPEN EITHER. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. IN NINETEEN NINE MS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL-ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
BATES NO BELL I BRIDGES.
BRADFORD ALL RIGHT I CAN BE ERA
I CHIANG. DALY NO DODD. HI
THERE ALSO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER BY GONZALEZ. HI GROVE NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO I
TADO I JACKSON. I JONES. NO
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL.
MONNING I'M MORE LUCK NO.
MORRELL NO NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
SKINNER AYE STERN HI STONE NO
BURKE. IOWA CASKEY I WINNER. BY
WILK NO. SIX PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS FOR JUST.
CHIANG FOR JUST NO BUT CHIANG
NO. MITCHELL BY RUBIO HI. ICE
TWENTY EIGHT NOS ELEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WERE
NOW MOVING TO ITEM THREE
FOURTEEN. SENATOR CAFIERO
YOU'RE PREPARED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE EAD ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY AND ACT
REALLY TO WATER RESOURCES.
CAVIAR THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
SIX THIRTY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADAM GRAY.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS UP TO
THE TASK OF ADAPTING TO NEW AND
UNPREDICTABLE WEATHER PATTERNS
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA HAS
PRIORITIZED RENEWABLE ENERGY IN
AN ATTEMPT TO FIGHT THE EFFECTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE WE MUST ALSO
PREPARE FOR THE INEVITABLE
CHANGES ON OUR WATER SUPPLY. AB
SIX THIRTY EIGHT REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
TO IDENTIFY THREATS TO WATER
STORAGE FACILITIES VULNERABLE
TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND TO
PROPOSE STRATEGIES TO MITIGATE
THOSE THREATS THIS BILL HAS HAD
NO NO VOTE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THE
THANK YOU FOR THE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SEEN NINE THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. THREE
NINE. OZ THIRTY EIGHT THE ICE
THIRTY NINE KNOWS IS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM THREE EIGHTEEN. THIRD
BORDERS ARE YOU PREPARED FOR A
THREE EIGHTEEN ABSOLUTELY
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SEVENTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI AN ACT
RELATING TO INTERCOUNTRY
ADOPTION. OR JUST A FLOOR
JURORS THANK YOU I RISE TO
PRESENT A. B. SIX SEVEN SEVEN
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOI. AB SIX SEVEN SEVEN IS A
HUMANITARIAN BILL THAT SEEKS TO
PROVIDE A SAFETY NET FOR
CHILDREN ADOPTED OVERSEAS AND
TO PROVIDE A MEANS TO FIGHT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. UNDER THE
CURRENT SYSTEM CALIFORNIA IS
ONE THE LAST STATES THAT STILL
REQUIRES RE ADOPTION IN CERTAIN
SITUATIONS FOR INTERCOUNTRY
ADOPTIONS. THIS PROCESS IF NOT
ALLOWED LEAVES THE CHILD
SUBJECT TO DEPORTATION. EVEN
THOUGH THEY HAVE BEEN ADOPTED
BY AMERICAN NATIONALS. IT IS IT
IS THIS CURRENT SYSTEM THAT
ALSO ALLOWS ABUSERS TO TRAFFIC
CHILDREN INTO CALIFORNIA IN
HOLD THEM THROUGH THREATS AND
INTIMIDATION. COLLEAGUES THIS
IS A SIMPLE AND EASY STEP WE
CAN TAKE TO HELP LEAD ARE
LEGITIMATE FAMILIES WHO ARE
ADOPTING OVERSEAS. AT THE SAME
TIME PROVIDED TURNED TO WOULD
BE HUMAN TRAFFICKERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION IN THE
VAN ON THE SIDE ON. SIX SENATOR
HERTZBERG QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR. WITH ALL THE TAKE
QUESTION. YOU KNOW IN THE
INTEREST OF CLASS IT IS
ABSOLUTELY. I WAS GIVING YOU A
CHANCE TO BE BACK. TOUCHE. THIS
IS A QUESTION MEMBERS THIS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING. THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
MEMBERS. ANY OBJECTION I SEE
NINE OZ THIRTY NINE KNOWS IS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM THREE TWENTY
FOUR SOONER DORADO SHE'S
PREPARED ME SHE SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIN SIGN AN ACT REALLY INTO
FOSTER CARE. SENATOR DORADO
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT WHEN
CHILDREN UNDER GOAL MULTIPLE
FOSTER CARE PLACEMENTS THEY ARE
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE SEVERE
TRAUMA THIS TRAUMA MANIFESTS
ITSELF BEHAVIOR EARLY
EMOTIONALLY SOCIALLY AND
ACADEMICALLY MAKING IT LESS
LIKELY FOR THESE FOSTER YOUTH
TO FIND PERMANENCE IN ADOPTION
FOR REUNIFICATION. AB SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR WILL ESTABLISH A
TWO YEAR PILOT PROGRAM WHICH
AIMS TO PROVIDE FAMILIES WITH
THE NECESSARY INFORMATION
SERVICES AND TOOLS. TO ENSURE
THE SUCCESS OF THE PERMANENT
SITUATION ADDITIONALLY THE
PILOT WILL ALLOW THE OPTION FOR
COUNTIES TO EXPAND OTHER
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES SUCH AS
TRANSPORTATION AND RESPIRE CARE
THIS BILL ENJOYS UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING AND SEEING ON THIS TWO
IS A CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL TO THIS MEASURE.
SENIOR OBJECTION OZ THIRTY NINE
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM THREE TWENTY EIGHT
CENTER INTERS PREPARED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT OH SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER QUE HAN AN APPLE
AND CAL WORKS IN A CLEARING
THEIR THROATS TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY THROUGH WINNER I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE 2% AB ZERO
SEVEN. THIS BILL WILL REMOVE
INCOME EXCLUSIONS THAT PENALIZE
FAMILIES ON CAL WORKS. FOR
STUDENTS SCHOLARSHIPS AND
RENTAL ASSISTANCE ADDITIONALLY
THE BILL WILL EXAMS ALL U. S.
CENSUS US CENSUS RELATED INCOME
FROM IT OR GOVERNMENTAL OR NON
PROFIT AGENCY TO ENCOURAGE. A
CENSUS PARTICIPATION AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. CAL
WORKS PROGRAM SERVES NEARLY
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND LOW
INCOME FAMILIES BUT BY
PROVIDING FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
FOR HOUSING. FOOD AND OTHER
NECESSITIES. BY THESE FAMILIES
TO TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND RECIPIENTS ARE
STILL LIVING IN DEEP POVERTY.
THIS BILL WILL PROMOTE SMART
SAVING HABITS AT WAL HELPING TO
BREAK. THE CYCLE OF POVERTY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
AND SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES HI BILL BY BURGESS.
BRADFORD HI I COVER HERO I
CHIANG I DALY. DODD I DORADO
AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL. I HUESO. I BY TITLE I
JACKSON. I JONES. NO LEYVA.
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. HI MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK MORALE. HI
NIELSEN. HI PAN HI PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH BY RUBIO. I SKINNER BY
STERN AYE STONE. I AM BURKE OUR
CASSIE BY WINNER BY WILK I.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS PORGES HI. DALY
HI LEYVA BY MORE LOCK. ICE
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE ON THE
URGENCY HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN
KNOWS ONE ON THE MEASURE.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM THREE
THIRTY ONE A. SENATOR GALGIANI
HE'S REPAIRED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FORTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAY AND ACTUALLY MEDI CAL
DINNER GALGIANI THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
EIGHT FORTY EIGHT SIMPLY
REQUIRES MEDI CAL TO PROVIDE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR CONTINUOUS
GLUCOSE MONITORS IT ACTUALLY
JUST REQUIRES THAT THE
REIMBURSEMENT BE MADE THE SAME
AS ALREADY DONE BY THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM COVERED CALIFORNIA THE
MEDICAID PROGRAM ANDMORE THAN
THIRTY OTHER STATES. CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S SERVICES AND 90% OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE PLANS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. MEMBERS THIS TOO IS A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO
THIS MEASURE. JEAN NINE EYES
THIRTY NINE. NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON NOW
TO ITEM THREE THIRTY NINE
SENATOR HILL IS PREPARED MISTER
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL EIGHT NINETY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO NECK
RELATED STATE GOVERNMENT.
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AB EIGHT NINETY FOUR
WILL INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL EXEMPT
POSITIONS WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THIS WILL
PROVIDE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WITH THE FLEXIBILITY IT
NEEDS TO MANAGE ITS PERSONNEL
ON OPERATIONS THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
COLLEAGUES. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HERE NINETY NINE SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I HER SHE
LED A- I ATKINS BATES. BELL HI
PORGES NO BRADFORD. I CABALLERO
TIED CHIANG NO DALY NO DODD. HI
THERE ALSO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI GLAZER.
GROVE NO. HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO AYE OR TITLE I
JACKSON BY JONES NO LEYVA I
MCGUIRE MITCHELL. BY MONNING
I'M MORE LUCK NUMBER RAIL. NO
NIELSEN NO. PAN HI PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
I STERN AYE STONE NOVEMBER OUR
CASKEY I WINNER. HI WILK. NO
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS BATES NO.
GLAZER BY. AUGUST TWENTY EIGHT
NOS ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW I'M MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM THREE FIVE FIVE
SENATOR PAN. THE SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD AND ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
SENATOR PAT. GIVE US PRESENT
CENTERS EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY EIGHT
WILL PREVENT LOW INCOME SENIORS
AND PEOPLE DISABILITIES ONE
ROLE TO BOTH MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID OUT FROM LOSING THEIR
MEDICARE COVERAGE WHEN THE
STATE BEGINS PAYING THEIR
MEDICARE PART D. PREMIUMS AB
TEN EIGHTY EIGHT MAKE SURE THAT
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN BY HOLDING
PEOPLE IN THE SAME PLACE THAT
THEY WERE WHEN THEY APPLIED SO
THEY DON'T BOUNCE OFF OF
MEDICARE COVERAGE I SUSPECT WE
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. UNION MEMBERS THIS
IS ACCOUNTED FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL TO IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THE SIDE OF. THE NINE OZ THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MOVING ON ITEM FILE ITEM
THREE SIXTY. SENATOR SKINNER
YOU PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE RATE
FILE ITEM THREE SIXTY. SO. SOME
OF ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER QUE HAN
AN ACCOLADE TO CHILD CUSTODY
SKINNER. THANK YOU I MISSED
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB ELEVEN
SIXTY FIVE REQUIRES PEOPLE THAT
ARE TASKED MONITORS IN THE
LEGAL TERM WHO ARE TASKED WITH
SUPERVISING CHILDREN IN COURT
ORDERED VISITATION FOR CUSTODY
MATTERS TO PASS BACKGROUND
CHECK AND TRAINING REQUIREMENTS
CURRENTLY PEOPLE THAT SERVE IN
THIS ROLE. THERE'S NO CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECK REQUIRED FOR
THEM. AND THE ONLY VERIFICATION
THAT IS REQUIRED IS A
DECLARATION THAT STATES THEY
HAVE UNDERGONE TRAINING AND
I'VE NOT BEEN CONVICTED OF
CERTAIN CRIMES FOR EXAMPLE
CHILD MOLESTATION OR CHILD
ABUSE. SUCH JUST SELF
CERTIFICATION DOES NOT MEET THE
TYPE OF STANDARD WE WOULD WANT
FOR MONITORS WHO MUST
SUPERVISED VISITATION BETWEEN
PARENTS IN A CUSTODY ISSUE. SO
THE PURPOSE SEVEN ELEVEN SIXTY
FIVE IS TO PUT IN PLACE
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS BACKGROUND
CHECKS IN IN PERSON TRAINING IN
WITH THAT. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF.
HEARING NONE THIS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR YOU NATURAL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING THE UNITS ROLL CALL TO
THIS MEASURE. C. NINE HAI'S
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON NOW
MEMBERS TO FILE ITEM THREE
SIXTY TWO SENATOR WILL ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR. THIS ITEM. THREE
SIXTY TWO. WE ARE DONE THAT.
ALL RIGHT IT'S IS STILL ON THE
SLOPES OCCUR. THREE SIXTY THREE
SENATOR PAN. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WITH AN ACT RELATING TO
MEDI CAL FINGERPRINT THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT SENATORS AB
LEVIN SEVENTY FIVE IS A TWO
PART BILL THAT WOULD IMPROVE
HOW MEDI CAL MENTAL HEALTH
FUNCTIONS FIRST TO IMPROVE CARE
COORDINATION AND TREATMENT BY
REQUIRING THE EXCHANGE OF
INFORMATION ABOUT PEOPLE BE
TREATED BY SEPARATE PLANS
SECOND IT WOULD ESTABLISH A
TIME FRAME FOR THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES TO ISSUE A
DECISION WHEN THERE'S AN
UNRESOLVED DISPUTE BETWEEN A
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLAN. AND
A MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS
THAT ARE STRICTLY ASPEN EITHER
TO BE HAVE A SIMILAR WOOD. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE.
HEARING SEEING NINE THIS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS MEASURE. I JUST THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
THREE EIGHTY ONE. DOCTOR PAN IS
PREPARED TO DO THAT. THREE
EIGHTY ONE THIS IS SECRETARY
YOU MAY READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA AN ACT REALLY INTO
ELECTIONS DOCTOR SIGMUND
SENATOR PAN WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
CENTERS PLEASE THE RIGHTS
PERCENT EIGHTY THIRTEEN NINETY
ONE BY SOME MEMBER BONTA EIGHTY
THIRTEEN I WENT APPROVED
ACCESSIBILITY OF TRANSLATED
VOTING MATERIALS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT VOTERS. CALIFORNIA'S
THE MOST IMMIGRANT AND MOST
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
VOTERS IN THE NATION
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION VOTERS MEET THIS
CATEGORY AB THIRTY NINETY ONE
REQUIRES VOTER NOTIFICATION
CARS TO SPEAK THE LANGUAGE OF
PREFERENCE AND INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO CHANGE IT ALSO REQUIRES
ONLINE OR PAPER VOTE BY MAIL
APPLICATIONS INCLUDE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INDICATE
LANGUAGE PREFERENCE OTHER. THAN
ENGLISH WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. THIS
IS A CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS OF REJECTION WE
HAVE AN OBJECTION MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL ROLE
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA. I ATKINS.
BATES HI BILL. BY BURGESS I
BRADFORD. I COME HERE ALL BY
CHANGE. I DALY I DODD. BY THE
RAZA I GALGIANI. I GLAZER. I
GONZALEZ I GROW BY HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO AYE HER
TITLE I JACKSON. JONES BY LEYVA
HI MCGUIRE HI. JACKSON AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING. HI MORE
LOCK I AM A REAL. NIELSEN I PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO. I SKINNER BY STERN AYE
STONE AYE AMBERG I HAVE A
COUNTY BY WINNER BY WILK. BY.
SURGERY PLEASE CALL UPS A
MEMBER ATKINS MERRELL. ICE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
THREE NINETY SENATOR JACKSON IS
PREPARED MISTER SECRETARY YOU
MAY READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
TEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND
ECHOING TO SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
AND CLING THEIR THREATS TO
EXPECT ME THE. JACKSON THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
I THINK WE'RE ALL FAIRLY AWARE
AND FRANKLY WE'RE PROBABLY ALL
PRETTY HORRIFIED. BY LEARNING
OF THE EGREGIOUS ACTS OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT THAT OCCURRED FOR
ALMOST THIRTY YEARS ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS. ON USC'S CAMPUS
BY FORMER SOUL SOUL FULL TIME.
GYNECOLOGIST DRUG DOCTOR GEORGE
TYNDALL. THIS BILL ALLOWS THE
VICTIMS OF DOCTOR TYNDALL ONE
YEAR TO FILE THEIR CASES IN
COURT THAT OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE
BEEN BARRED PRIOR TO JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY. THIS BILL
INCLUDES AN EMERGENCY CLAUSE SO
THAT VICTIMS CAN BE PROVIDED
WITH EFFECTIVE RELIEF AT THE
EARLIEST POSSIBLE TIME VICTIMS
HAVE UNTIL NOVEMBER SEVENTH OF
THIS YEAR TO OPT OUT. OF US
SHE'S FEDERAL SETTLEMENT AND
THIS ALLOWS THEM TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL TIME TO MAKE THE
BEST DECISION ABOUT THEIR OWN
RESPECTIVE. LEGAL OPTIONS.
COLLEAGUES IT IS VITAL THAT
SURVIVORS ARE PROVIDED WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THEIR DAY
IN COURT SHOULD THEY SHOULD SO
CHOOSE. AND THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL YEAR FOR
SURVIVORS TO SEEK THEIR
JUSTICE. THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE HAVE
REMOVED U. S. SEES OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SENATOR GROW. AND
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
SUPPORT THIS BILL BUT I AM
EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTED THAT WE
ONLY ALLOW THE WOMEN AT THE UC
SYSTEM OF THIS AT THE U. S. C.
SYSTEM BE BE PROTECTED AND NOT
THE CS USE OR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. SO I THINK IT WOULD
BE BETTER SERVING THE YOUNG
WOMEN THAT WILL COME UP BEHIND
US AND HOPEFULLY ONE DAY BE
LAWMAKERS TO CHANGE THIS AND
JUSTICE AGAINST THOSE WOMEN SIR
ATTENDING TO OTHER TYPES OF
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEMS IN OUR
STATE. AS WELL AS YOUNG MEN.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ARE
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SORRY ALL
SENATOR CHECK. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN TEN WE
SHOULD ALL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL MOST COLLEGE AGE WOMEN
WOULD NOT HAVE MUCH EXPERIENCE
IN GOING TO COLLEGE SCHOOL
EXAMS FOR MANY THAT IS THEIR
FIRST TIME EXPERIENCING A
PUBLIC IS THEM AND WE ARE
TAUGHT TO TRUST OUR DOCTORS.
WHETHER IT'S ASIAN AND AN
EXPERIENCE OR LANGUAGE BERRIER
SO MANY FACTORS CAN MAKE
SPEAKING UP EVEN HARDER FOR
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT THE
STUDENT VICTIMS OF DOCTOR TO
KNOW DESERVE TO HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD WHAT THIS MAN DID
TO THEM IS OUTRAGEOUS. I SHOULD
NOT HAVE GONE ON FOR THIRTY
YEARS. IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DEALT WITH IMMEDIATELY. THE
SURVIVORS DESERVE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND JUSTICE AND
THIS BILL GIVES THEM THAT I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. SENATOR
PORTANTINO THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN TEN AND I
ALSO WANT TO COMPLIMENT THE
AUTHOR AND ALL OF THE FOLKS WHO
WORKED ON THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE TAKEN IN THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS IT IS A JUST
RIGHTEOUS BECAUSE- THESE
VICTIMS. DESERVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SEEK THE REMEDIES THE THEY
ARE DESERVE FOR THE HORRIBLE
THINGS THAT HAPPEN TO THEM AND
I JUST COMPLEMENT EVERYBODY FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD IN THE
MANNER IN WHICH IT WAS BROUGHT
FORWARD AN- URGE AND I VOTE.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. YOU'RE
INSANE NONE SENATOR JACKSON
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU AND TO MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD IT
ISMY HOPE THAT WE HAVE LEARNED
FROM THIS AND WILL TAKE
AGGRESSIVE STEPS THROUGHOUT OUR
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE AND OUR
NATION TO MAKE SURE THIS KIND
OF ABUSE DOES NOT. HAPPEN GOING
FORWARD I THINK IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO THAT THIS
IS A MEASURE THAT ADDRESSES A
KNOWN PROBLEM IT'S ONE FOR
WHICH EGREGIOUS BEHAVIOR NEEDS
TO BE RECTIFIED THE VICTIMS
NEED THEIR MOMENT FOR THEIR
JUSTICE IN VINDICATION. AND
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS BATES. HI
BILL I PURCHASE. HI BRADFORD
AREN'T I CAMBIADO I CHIANG. I
DALY AYE DODD ARE RUSSELL AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. I HERTZBERG. I
HILL AYE HUESO. HI TITLE I
JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA. I'M
ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL BY MORNING
I'M MORE LOCK. I AM A REAL. BY
NELSON. BY PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
BY STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG
OUR CASKEY AYE WIENER AYE WILK
BY. SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE UPS
A MEMBER ATKINS. JONES. OUR
EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON
THE URGENCY OZ THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO ON THE MEASURE. MEMBERS
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM. THREE NINE NINE. DR FAN
YOU BEEN BUSY TODAY YOU'RE
PREPARED ONCE AGAIN MISTER
SECRETARY YOU MAY RATE ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD AN ACT
RELATING TO MEDI CAL THIRD PAN
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATORS THIS YEAR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
RELEASED TO CRITICAL OUT IT'S
ON THE MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE
PROGRAM. THIS BILL WOULD
ENHANCE ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY
AT THE DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES BY INCREASING THE
PENALTIES FOR DIFFERENT TYPES
OF MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS
IN ADDITION THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE PLANTS TO ASSIST THE
PATIENT TO FIND A CLOSER
POSITION SPECIALIST WHEN THE
PLAY SHOULD HAVE TO TRAVEL A
GREAT DISTANCE THAT. I EXPECT
WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON
BEHALF OF SOME NUMBER WOULD.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
BYERS LETTER BY ATKINS BATES.
BELL. I PURCHASED HI BRADFORD I
CABALLERO. JANE I DALY. DODD.
HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. HI
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO BY
OUR TITLE I JACKSON BY JONES.
LEYVA BY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL.
BY MONEY. I'M MORE LUCK.
MORRELL. AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN
AYE PORTANTINO. HI ROTH I RUBIO
I SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE AYE
HAMBURG IA CASKEY BY WINNER BY
WILK BY. SIX THREE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS BATES.
BY. GABRIELLE HI DOLLY I. JONES
NO MORE LOCK HI. PRICE THIRTY
EIGHT KNOWS ONE THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM FOR OLD THREE.
SENATOR JACKSON ARE YOU
PREPARED SHE IS MISTER
SECRETARY YOU PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN EIGHTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW MOAN AN ACT
RELATING TO COASTAL RESOURCES.
OKAY. SENATE JACKSON EUROPE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES THIS
MEASURE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
MONN RESPONSE TO GOVERNOR
BROWN'S CALL TO BRING
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER TO
DEVELOP A NEW COASTAL ACCESS
PROGRAM FOR THE PUBLIC AT
HOLLISTER RANCH WHICH IS A
FOURTEEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
ACRE SUBDIVISION IN MY DISTRICT
THAT INCLUDES EIGHT AND A HALF
MILES OF PUBLICLY OWNED
SHORELINE. THE GABBY TO COAST
ONE OF THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
PRISTINE PLACES LEFT IN
CALIFORNIA. OF WHICH HOLLISTER
RANCHES A SIGNIFICANT PART IS
AMONG THE LEAST ACCESSIBLE
STRETCHES OF COASTLINE IN
CALIFORNIA. WITH LESS THAN TWO
MILES A PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE
SHORT IN MORE THAN SIXTY MILES
OF COASTLINE. OVER THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS AGO IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE COASTAL COMMISSION
ADOPT TODAY HOLLISTER RANCH
PUBLIC ACCESS PROGRAM HOWEVER
THIS PROGRAM WAS NEVER
IMPLEMENTED AND IT THUS
PREVENTING THE PUBLIC FROM
ENJOYING THE NATURAL TREASURES
OFFERED BY THIS EXTRAORDINARY
COASTLINE. AND AGAIN THIS IS
COAST LINE WHICH IS OF COURSE
OWNED BY THE PUBLIC. THIS BILL
REAFFIRMS OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
COMMITMENT TO THE PUBLIC'S
RIGHT TO ACCESS THE BEACHES AT
HOLLISTER RANCH BY SPECIFICALLY
DIRECTING AGENCIES TO REPLACE
THAT NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO ACCESS
PROGRAM. SAID DEADLINES WITHIN
WHICH TO DO SO AND INCENTIVIZE
IS ALL PARTIES TO WORK TO A GET
TOGETHER TO ACCOMPLISH THIS
GOAL. WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY ADDITIONAL DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING SEEN NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES. BELL BY BURGESS.
BRADFORD HI KELLY HERO. BY
CHANGE. DALY DODD. HI THERE
ALSO AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ BY GROW. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO BUYER TADO I
JACKSON BY JONES NO LEYVA. BY
MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL HI MONNING
I'M MORE LOCK. REAL NO NIELSEN.
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH BY
RUBIO I SKINNER. BY STERN AYE
STONE. NUMBER FIVE AKOWSKI BY
WINNER BY WILK. HI SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS. BATES GORGEOUS. CHIANG
DALLY GROWTH. MORE LOCK NIELSEN
STONE. HI IS TWENTY NINE A NOSE
TO THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM. EIGHTY ONE. SENATOR BILL
ALL ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THAT
THIS ITEM. YEAH MISTER
SECRETARY. THREE ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION FIFTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM RELATIVE TO
SECTION TWO OH TO SUPPORT OF
HOUSING FOR THE ELDERLY
PROGRAM. ZERO WHEN YOU'RE READY.
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS THESE.
THIS RESOLUTION STATES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORTS THE ANNUAL
FEDERAL FUNDING OF THE SO
CALLED SECTION TOOL TO SUPPORT
OF HOUSING FOR ELDERLY PROGRAM
CALLS ON THE PRESENT UNITED
STATES IN THE SECRETARY OF
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT
TO REINSTATE FUNDING THAT WAS
CUT FEW YEARS AGO DURING THE
RECESSION THEY CUT SIX HUNDRED
MILLION. DOLLARS OUT OF THIS.
IT'S A MINOR AMOUNT BUT THIS
PROGRAM ACTUALLY HELPS FINANCE
A LOT OF OUR OF SENIOR HOUSING
IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SCENE NINE
MISTER SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES HI BILL I BURGESS
I BRADFORD I KELLY AT ALL HI
JANE I DALY AYE DODD. ARE THERE
ALSO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW I HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO I OUR TITLE I
JACKSON. I JONES BY LEYVA. AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. BY
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK I'M A
REAL. BY NELSON. HI PAN I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
AYE AMBERG. IOWA CASKEY BY
WINNER I WILK. HI. PRICE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
APPROVED. SOONER TITLE FOR WHAT
PURPOSE THE RICE. I RISE UP FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AB REQUEST
RECONSIDERATION ON FILE ITEM
TWO EIGHTY A. B. TWO ONE ONE.
THERE'S A MOTION TO RECONSIDER.
ITEM TWO EIGHTY. AB TWO AB TWO
ELEVEN. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO RECONSIDERATION. SEE NO
OBJECTION I APPRECIATE
RECONSIDERATION HAS BEEN
GRANTED. ICE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI.
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS BATES. HI
BILL HI PORGES. BRADFORD. HI
KELLY AT ALL. WORDS I.
COPYRIGHTS CHIANG HI DOLLY I
DODD. HI THERE ALSO. I GALGIANI.
HI GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH
HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
BY TADO HI JACKSON. I JONES. BY
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
AYE MONNING. HI MORE LOCK.
CARRILLO. NIELSEN. BY PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH BY RUBIO. I
SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE. HI.
NUMBER OUR CASSIE BY WINNER HI
WILK OKAY. WILK NO I AM WILL
NOTIFY. ONE MOMENT
. BUT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS THANK
MORE LAW REAL MORRELL AYE. I
JUST THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOT MEMBERS
WERE MOVING. WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE OFF I'M SORRY
SENATOR MITCHELL FOR WHAT
PURPOSE MOST OF THE RESOLUTIONS
PLEASE. SENATOR METACRITIC YOU
VERY QUICKLY COLLEAGUES I HOPE
THAT YOU WOULD JOIN ME ON THE
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY BIRTHDAY AT
THE CITY OF ANGELS LOS ANGELES
OUR CITY OUR CONTROLLER ONE GAL
FRIEND AND HIS PART PARTNER BYE
BYE ZAC SHAPIRO WELCOME TO
TWINS INTO THE WORLD A RABBI
SHAPIRO AS- THE RABBI OF TEMPLE
CUBA IN CULVER CITY MY
DISTRICT. AND THEY WELCOME TO
THE CITY OF ANGELS MAYA AND ELI
SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
TWINS THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR. REGULATIONS TO OUR
CONTROLLER. WE'LL BE BACK TO
FILE ITEM WE'RE MOVING BACK TO
FIVE I OWN ONE OH FIVE SENATOR
BATES ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THIS
ITEM. WHEN YOU PASS TEMPORARILY.
ALRIGHT MOVING DOWN TO FILE
FILEITEM. TWO TO FOUR TO
TWENTY FOUR. SENATOR PORTANTINO
HE'S NOT AT HIS DESK TO EITHER.
AUG VARIAS. HE'S NOT HE'S NOT
PREPARE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY.
WE HAVE NEXUS FILE ITEM TWO
EIGHT SIX. SENATOR STERN ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM FILE
ITEM TWO EIGHT SIX. I GUESS NOT
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON THEN FILE
ITEM TWO NINE FIVE SENATOR
ARCHULETA. I THINK WE HAVE A
WINNER. BASS ON FILE NO WE
DON'T. NEXUS FILE ITEM THREE
SEVEN FOUR SENATOR CAFIERO. NOW.
IF YOU PREPAREDNESS PORTANTINO
WILL WILL TAKE TWO TO FOUR. OUR
I'LL DO MY BEST. MISTER
SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE READ
FILE ITEM TWO TO FOUR A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON AND THAT
GOING TO JUVENILE COURT SCHOOL
PEOPLE'S SOONER PORTANTINO
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
FIFTY FOUR IS AN OUTGROWTH OF A
BILL SEVERAL YEARS AGO THAT
CREATED RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
STUDENTS IN COURT SCHOOLS AS
THEY TRANSITION OUT OF THOSE
SKORTS SCHOOLS. THIS BILL
REQUIRES COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION TO ENSURE THAT A
STUDENT ENROLLED IN A JUVENILE
COURT SCHOOL FOR MORE THAN
TWENTY DAYS TWENTY SCHOOL DAYS
HAS AN TRANSITION PLAN FOR HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO TRANSITION
FROM THE COURT SCHOOL INTO
OTHER SCHOOLS AND SO REQUIRES
THOSE PLANS TO BE DONE FOR ANY
STUDENT IN TWENTY DAYS IT'S A
GOOD BILL I ACTUALLY WENT
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE LAST
YEAR THE GOVERNOR VETOED IT
IT'S BACK AGAIN AND IT WAS AN
OUTGROWTH OF A STUDY SO. OFTEN
TIMES WE DO STUDIES AND WE SAY
WHAT'S IT WHAT'S THE STUDY GOOD
FOR THIS STUDY CAME UP WITH
THIS RECOMMENDATION. WE SHOULD
PASS THIS BILL AND IMPLEMENTED
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING NINE A
MR SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS BATES.
NOBEL I PURCHASED. NO BRADFORD
AYE AYE CARRY AT ALL I CHIANG.
DELHI NO DODD. HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI. GLAZER. GONZALEZ BY
GROW NO HERTZBERG I HILL AYE
HUESO. HIGHER TADO I JACKSON BY
JONES NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. HI MONEY I'M MORE
LUCK. MORRELL NO NIELSEN NO PAN.
HI PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER. I STERN. I
STONE NOVEMBER. FIVE A CASKEY
BY WIENER BY WILK. HI HI.
SECTOR POLICE CALLED UP TO
MEMBERS ATKINS. CHIANG BY
GALGIANI. HI GLAZER BY MORE
LOCK. I JUST THIRTY KNOWS EIGHT
THE MEASURE PASSES
. IT WAS A
MINUTE MEMBERS AS WE- GET
THINGS IN ORDER
. OUR MEMBERS
WERE MOVING TO FILE ITEM THREE
EIGHT TEEN. SENATOR BORDERS ARE
YOU HE'S NOT AT HIS BEST. WE'VE
ALREADY DONE THAT SO. WE HAVE
TO NINETEEN. FILE ITEM TO
NINETEEN. WELL THEY KEEP. THIS
IS
. ALL RIGHT. MEMBERS WERE NOW
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
EIGHT SENATOR GONZALEZ ARE YOU
READY. AB NINE. THIS IS
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RACE AN ACCOLADE TO IMPLEMENT.
SALAS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING ACT IS DESIGNED TO
PROTECT EMPLOYEES FROM
WORKPLACE HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION AND RETALIATION.
DUE TO PROTECTED CHARACTERISES
SUCH CHARACTERISTICS SUCH AS
SEX AND GENDER SEXUAL
ORIENTATION GENDER IDENTITY
RACE AGE RELIGION DISABILITY
AND MORE TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU
AB NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RADIUS THIS BILL WOULD EXTEND
THE FILING REQUIREMENT. FROM
ONE YEAR TO THREE YEARS FOR
BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
EMPLOYEES TO COME FORWARD WITH
EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION
CLAIMS THIS BILL STATES THAT
IT'S CHANGES SHALL NOT BE
INTERPRETED TO REVIVE LAPSED
CLAIMS. IT CAN TAKE SIGNIFICANT
TIME FOR VICTIMS TO COME
FORWARD AS A MAY FEAR
RETALIATION THIS EXISTING
DEADLINE HASN'T CHANGED SINCE
IT WAS CREATED IN NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE IT IS TRUE ARE
TRULY CRUCIAL THAT VICTIMS
HAVE. ADEQUATE TIME TO HEAL AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. IN ADDITION DESCRIPTION
OF THE RATE ON THIS ITEM. CENA
NAINA MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
NO BILL HI BURGESS. BRADFORD HI
CAVEA I CHIANG. DELHI DOT. I
DORADO I GALGIANI. I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROVE. HERTZBERG. I
HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TITLE. I
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA. I'M
ACQUIRE. MITCHELL HI MONNING.
MORE LOCK NO MORALE NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN. BY PORTANTINO I ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER BY STERN
AYE STONE NOVEMBER OUR COUNTY I
WINNER BY WILK. HI. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FOR JESS. CHIANG DALLY NO LASER
HI GROWTH. MCGUIRE BY MONEY BY.
ICE THIRTY NO SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES NOT. MEMBERS WERE NOW
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE NINETY.
AND SENATOR NELSON ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY. THE SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FORTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER AND ACCOLADES
TRANSPORTATION. INTERNAL THAT
IS DONE THE SENATE I'M GLAD TO
RESENT THIS BILL AB FOUR FOUR
NINE. BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE
THE SOMEONE GALLAGHER FROM THE
CITY AREA. THIS HELPS THE
DEVELOPMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
DEVELOPING REGION. AND REDUCES
THE STATE'S RESPONSIBILITY TO
DEVELOP ALONE IN OTHER WORDS AN
ASSERTION OF. COMMUNITY HEALTH.
IT ALLOWS YOU THE CITY. YUBA
AND SUTTER COUNTIES TO KEEP
FUNDS FROM THE SAILOR
PROPERTIES AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION HAD ORIGINALLY
ACQUIRED THE BILL THE THIRD
BRIDGE ACROSS THE FEATHER RIVER.
AGAIN THAT WAS PUT IN BY
CALTRANS FOR THIS PARTICULAR
PURPOSE. SIMILAR TRANSFERS OF
THIS SORT HAVE OCCURRED IN
PREVIOUS YEARS MOST RECENTLY
EIGHT AND THIRTEEN. IT PASSED
OUT OF THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WAS STRONG SUPPORT.
AND I WOULD REQUEST. AN AYE
VOTE THERE IS NO HARM FOR THIS
IT ACTUALLY IS A BENEFIT AND IT
HAS BEEN DONE BEFORE. I WOULD
ASK YOUR ARRIVAL. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HEARING CHAIN
NINE MISTER TERRY WE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES. I
BILL BY BURGESS I BRADFORD I
CAN BE AT ALL. I CHIANG. DALY
AYE DODD. HI DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO BUYER TADO. I
JACKSON I JONES BY LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. BY
MORNING I'M MORE LUCK I'M REAL
AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE. THE
I. AMBERG OUR CASSIE NO NUMBER
LIKE OWSKI NO WINNER. BY WILK
BY. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CHANGE BY GROWTH. I
CERTI EIGHT KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY TWO. ENTER GLAZER YOU'RE
PREPARED MISTER SECRETARY YOU
MAY READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SIXTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AN ACTING TO
STATE RECORDS MANAGEMENT.
SENATOR GLAZER I THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS SAID
THIS BILL BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS. I SPONSORED BY
THE SECRETARY OF STATE. WHO
BELIEVES WE CAN DO A BETTER JOB
OF MANAGING OUR RECORDS AND
THAT'S WHY THE BILL'S BEEN PUT
FORWARD. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NINE VOTE. ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SCENE NINE MS SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES AYE BILL I BRIDGES. I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO. I CHIANG
BY DAILY I DOT. BY THE RAZA. HI
GALGIANI. HI GLAZER HI I
GONZALEZ BY GROW. HERTZBERG I
HILL. BY HUESO AYE OR TITLE I
JACKSON BY JONES. LEYVA HI I'M
ACQUIRE. HI MITCHELL. BY
MORNING BY MORE LUCK I'M REAL
BY NIELSEN. I PAN HI PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG BOB
AKOWSKI AYE WIENER BY WILK HI.
PLEASE CALL AB TO MEMBER GROWTH.
JONES HI. ICE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO FALL
ITEM TWO TO THREE. SENATOR HILL
YOU'RE PREPARED TO PRESENT THIS
ITEM MISTER SECRETARY YOU MARY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER
QUE HAN AND THAT GOING TO
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT AB
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR WHICH WILL
PROVIDE CRITICAL CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS TO SAFEGUARD THE
NEARLY ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ENROLLED
ONLINE AT FOR PROFIT OUT OF
STATE INSTITUTIONS. IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE TOOK STEPS
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS FROM POSSIBLE
PREDATORY OUT OF STATE ONLINE
BUSINESSES BY REQUIRING THEM TO
REGISTER WITH THE BUREAU OF
POST SECONDARY PRIVATE
EDUCATION OR BE PP HOWEVER
CURRENT LAW APPLIES ONLY TO
SCHOOLS PHYSICALLY LOCATED
WITHIN CALIFORNIA NOT
INSTITUTIONS BASED OUT OF STATE
THAT AND ROLL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ONLINE AB THIRTEEN
FORTY FOUR EXTENDS THIS
PROTECTION TO STUDENTS WHO
CHOOSE TO ENROLL IN ONLINE OUT
OF STATE INSTITUTIONS. IT WILL
REQUIRE DISCLOSURES AND
ADDITIONALLY OFFER A COMPLAINT
PROCESS FOR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
AS WELL AS CREATE KEY
ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS IT WILL
CLOSE THE GAP BETWEEN STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN STATE INSTITUTIONS
AND THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO ENROLL
ONLINE IN PROGRAMS LOCATED OUT
OF STATE THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I'VE COLLEGE. ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HERE AND SEE NONE
THE SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES BY BILL I BRIDGES AYE
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO BY
CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD AYE
THERE ALSO BY GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. AYE
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO HI
FOR TITLE I JACKSON BY JONES.
LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I'M MORE
LUCK. BY. MORRELL AYE NIELSEN.
I PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH.
I RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN AYE
STONE. HI NUMBER ABA CASSIE BY
WINNER BY WILK. ICE FORTY NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
. NEXT
MEASURE MEMBERS IS FILE ITEM
TWO FIVE NINE SENATOR PAN THE
SECRETARY. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
TWENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US AND THAT CLING TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE SENATOR
PAN THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATORS ON BEHALF ASSEMBLY
WOMAN RIVAS AND PLEASED TO
PRESENT EIGHTY NINE TWENTY NINE
WHICH INSURES COVER CALIFORNIA
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO COLLECT
THE DATA IT NEEDS TO VILLAGE TO
FULLY EVALUATE IN A HEALTH PLAN
IS NUMBER ONE LOWERING COSTS
IMPROVING QUALITY. IN REDUCING
HEALTH DISPARITIES THIS BILL
ALSO REQUIRES THAT THE DATA IS
AGGREGATED AND PUBLISHED BY
HEALTH PLAN CURRENTLY COVERED
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DIRECTLY ACCESS THE
DATA IT NEEDS TO SEE IF HEALTH
DISPARITIES ARE ACTUALLY BEING
REDUCED AND WITHOUT ACCESS TO
THIS TO THIS DATA COVER
CALIFORNIA CANNOT DEMONSTRATE
WHICH HEALTH PLANS ARE
DELIVERING ON THE PROMISES. OF
QUALITY IMPROVED CARE
ADDITIONALLY THIS IS DATA THAT
PLANTS ARE READY REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE UNDER THE CONTRACTS OF
COVERED CALIFORNIA NUMBER TO
PARTICIPATE AND SELL HEIR
PRODUCTS IN THE EXCHANGE THE
AUTHORS OFFICE HAS WORKED WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
RAISED IN THE SENATE HEALTH
POLICY SO SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. AND THEY REMAIN
NEUTRAL AND AMENDMENTS WERE
ALSO TAKEN TO REMOVE DATA
COLLECTED FROM LARGE GROUPS AND
MAKE EXPLICIT PRIVACY
REFERENCES TO HELP US AND THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL INFORMATION
ACT THESE AMENDMENTS SHOULD
ADDRESS. SOME OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE HEALTH PLANS THE
PROCESS OF ELIMINATING HEALTH
DISPARITIES IN EQUITY STARTS
WITH HIGH QUALITY DATA AND
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY NINE IS THE
FIRST STEP AND CERTAINLY THIS
IS SOMETHING WE WANT TO SEE AND
ARE. COVERED CALIFORNIA PLANS I
EXPECT WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IN ADDITION DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SEEN NINE MEMBERS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION OF
USING YOU KNOW THROW CALL ON
THE SIDE OF. SHE NINE ITEM EYES
FORTY. NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES
. I AM. YOUR BILL ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY TWO. WHILE IS PREPARING
THE SECTOR WE PLEASE RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FORTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES SENATOR BILL THE FLOOR
IS YOURS MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THIS BILL CREATES THE
NEW BEGINNINGS CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM. WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT AND THE PURPOSE OF
THIS PROGRAM IS TO INCENTIVIZE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO THE PURSUE
A HOMELESS EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM
OF THEIR OWN OR EXPAND. AN
EXISTING ONE HAS NO OPPOSITION
IT WILL FUNCTION AS A GRANT
PROGRAM. AND GOV GOVERNMENTS
COMPLY FOR MATCHING FUNDS THEY
WOULD HAVE TO MATCH SO I
ORIGINAL VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. IN
NINETEEN NINE THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
HI BILL I BRIDGES. BRADFORD HI
KELLY HERO I CHIANG I DALY.
DODD HI THERE ALSO. I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ BY
GROWTH. HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE
HUESO AYE OR TITLE I JACKSON I
JONES. LEYVA I'M ACQUIRE.
MITCHELL HI MONNING. I'M MORE
LOCK. BY RAIL. NIELSEN BY PAN.
I PORTANTINO. I ROTH BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NUMBER. OUR CASKEY BY WINNER HI
WILK HI. SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS PORTIS BY. DELHI.
I GROWTH. JONES. I MCGUIRE BY
MORALE. STONE BY. HIGHS THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES
. SENATE ALLEN YOU
PREPARED FOR FALL INTO EIGHTY
FIVE. MISS SECTOR PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AN
ACT RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING MEMBERS I DEDICATE
THIS PRESENTATION OF BURNED AT
AND RISES A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF
THE V. TWO EIGHTY FIVE BY SOME
MEMBER FRIEDMAN. THIS BILL HAS
TO DO WITH A CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION PLAN AND
BASICALLY IT REQUIRES THAT THE
D. O. T. INCORPORATE CURRENT
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION GOALS
SUCH AS THE SB THIRTY TWO IN
THE STATE THEIR QUALITY PLANS
INTO. THE PLAN ALSO REQUIRES OF
THIS REGION GROWTH COUNCIL
CONDUCT A REVIEW OF THE C. D.
P. IN CONSIDER WAYS TO BETTER
COURTNEY THE STATE'S GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION PROGRAMS HI THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT UPDATE THE BILL
HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES IS
SUPPORTED BY. COVERING
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
UTILITIES THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION. COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR MANY MORE. AND I
RESPECT FOR US FROM ABOUT. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. CENTER STONE.
THERE'S STILL THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT FELLOW COLLEAGUES ARE
AS IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWO
EIGHTY FIVE WHICH IS JUST OTHER
TEMP BY THIS LEGISLATURE TO
TELL THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
HOW TO LIVE THEIR LIVES IT'S
REALLY AS SIMPLE AS THIS IS
LEGISLATURE SET ARBITRARY NON
REALISTIC GREENHOUSE GAS AND
OTHER CLAMOR RELATED TARGET
DATES AND THE ONLY WAY TO EVEN
APPROACH THOSE GOALS IS TO
FORCE THE BASSNUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS TO DO WHAT THEY
HAVE SHOWN TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
AND THAT IS THAT ARE NOT
INTERESTED IN DOING THEM THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO MAKE
FUTURE TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS ALIGNS WITH THE
GOALS OF REDUCING VEHICULAR
TRAFFIC AND TRAVEL AND SHIFTING
FUNDING PRIORITIES AWAY FROM
SYSTEMS PEOPLE ACTUALLY USE
LIKE ROAD REYES AND FREEWAYS
TOWARDS TRANSIT INDUSTRY IN A
BICYCLE INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH
MOST CALIFORNIANS BY CHOICE
EARNERS SAYS CITY DO NOT USE
SHOULD THE GOVERNMENT BE USING
ITS OWN AGENDA THE FORCE PEOPLE
TO DO WHAT THEY DON'T WANT TO
DO OR SHOULDN'T LET INDIVIDUALS
PURSUE LIFE LIBERTY AND THE
PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS BELIEVE
ME. IN MY DISTRICT RIVERSIDE
COUNTY WHERE PEOPLE COMMUTE
FIFTY PLUS MILES A DAY EACH WAY
TO WORK PURSUING HAPPINESS IS
NOT WRITING ON A BIKE FOR HOURS
EACH DAY TO GET TO AND FROM
THEIR JOBS CALIFORNIA'S BEEN A
LEADER IN DEVELOPING
ENCOURAGING ALTERNATIVE FUEL
VEHICLES ENERGY OUR CITIZENS TO
BUY THEM BY OFFERING REBATES
AND OTHER INCENTIVES
CALIFORNIA'S VEHICLES ARE JUST
GETTING CLEANER EVERY YEAR. NOW
JUST AS THIS TECHNOLOGY IS
REALLY STARTED TO TAKE HOLDEN
FLOORS THE SALE OF ALTERNATIVE
FUEL VEHICLES CONTINUE TO GROW
THIS BILL SEEKS TO REPLACE THE
VERY ROSE THOSE VEHICLES ARE
SUPPOSED TO DRIVE ON EVER
ASKING THE PUBLIC TO ADOPT
THESE EXPENSIVE TECHNOLOGIES
FOR THEIR ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFIT
WHY AREN'T OUR FUNDING
DECISIONS REFLECTED THAT BY
INCREASING THE CAPACITY OF THE
ROADS AT THESE VEHICLES WILL
NEED WE ALL WANT CLEAN AIR TO
BREATHE. AND WE ALL WANT CLEAN
WATER TO DRINK PLANNING FOR THE
FUTURE FOR OUR CHILDREN OUR
GRANDCHILDREN IS IMPORTANT ROLE
OF THE LEGISLATURE BUT WHILE IT
MAKES SENSE TO CONSIDER ALL THE
ELEMENTS OF PLANNING
FUNDAMENTALLY THE ROLE OF
PLANNING. IS NOT AND SHOULD
NEVER BE TO FORCE PEOPLE TO
BEHAVE. HAS THE GOVERNMENT
WANTS THEM TO BUT RATHER TO
PROVIDE PEOPLE WITH THE TOOLS
TO BEHAVE AS THEY SEE FIT
CLEARLY. THIS IS A NOTION
THAT'S BEEN LOST ON THE
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL. AND
FOR THOSE REASONS I URGE A NO
VOTE. ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
MORLOCK. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT QUESTION FOR THE OR
MANAGER RECENT TRENDS IN ORDER
TO I THINK. IT'S A QUESTION.
PLEASE SIDE OF COURSE WOULD YOU
ACCEPT A QUESTION I WILL TRY MY
BEST. BIGGER CINEMA YOU'RE
DOING A GREAT JOB. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER.
WE'RE SEEING A DECLINE IN THE
USE OF TRANSIT IN ORANGE COUNTY
AND LA COUNTY IN FACT WE'VE
BEEN REDUCING BUS LINES WE'VE
BEEN. NO JUST LOOKING AT THE
DATA THE TREND LINE IS NOT GOOD
SO. WHAT WHAT ARE WE DOING TO
INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE OTHER THAN.
NOT BUILDING ROADS. WHICH IS
KIND OF A COMPANY IN APPROACH
BUT WHAT WHAT ARE WE DOING TO
INCENTIVIZE THAT'S QUESTION ONE
NUMBER TWO IS. IF WE'RE GONNA
TALK ABOUT TRANSIT AND MAYBE
BECAUSE YOU'RE ONE. RAPID
TRANSIT. THERE'S OR AN IDEA OF
PERSONAL RAPID TRANSIT WHICH
WOULD BE ON A ON A REAL LINE
BUT BUT NOW WITH CARS BEING
ABLE TO DRY THEMSELVES. SHOULD
WE BE LOOKING. AT THAT IS A
TRANSIT OPPORTUNITY WHERE YOU
CAN JUST ON YOUR IPHONE.
REQUEST A VEHICLE TO SHOW UP AT
YOUR HOUSE AT A CERTAIN TIME TO
TAKE YOU TO A CERTAIN
DEFINITION JUST LIKE WE'RE KIND
OF DOING WAS SCOOTERS AND
BICYCLES. AND I'M JUST
WONDERING IF WE NEED TO START
THINKING DIFFERENTLY ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING. YEAH I APPRECIATE
ACTION VERSION THE QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY IT'S INTERESTING I ON
THE FIRST QUESTION THAT YOU
ASKED. ON ONE OF THE MOVE LA
HAS DONE A STUDY ON THIS ISSUE
OF DECLINING TRANSIT AND IT
APPEARS AT LEAST FROM WHAT
THEIR POSITING. THAT AS IN OURS
IN OUR IN OUR BIG METROPOLITAN
AREAS AND FOLKS GET ORE
RESOURCES THEY'VE TENDED TO.
GET CARS AND THE POVERTY RATES
IN CERTAIN AREAS OF THE OF THE
CITIES HAVE ACTUALLY DECLINED
AND THAT HAS IN ECONOMY COURSES
BEEN STRONG. AND SO FOLKS HAVE
OPTED FOR PERSONAL
TRANSPORTATION I THINK IN THE
END OF THE DAY WHAT WE HAVE TO
DO WHEN YOU ASK ABOUT
INCENTIVIZING IT'S ABOUT
BUILDING CLEAN RELIABLE SAFE.
PUBLIC TRANSIT OPTIONS AND YOU
YOU KNOW WOULD YOU GO TO PLACES
LIKE LONDON OR NEW YORK AND
YOU'VE GOT. YOUR FOLKS IN IN IN
SUITS WHO ARE GOING TO YOU KNOW
SEVEN FIGURE JOBS WERE SITTING
RIGHT NEXT TO SCHOOL KIDS AND
FOLKS IN POVERTY ALL TOGETHER
BECAUSE- THIS IS IT IT'S PART
OF THE CULTURE THEY'RE SAFE
THEY'RE CLEAN THE RELIABLE
PEOPLE ACTUALLY KNOW THEY CAN
GET TO. WORK JUST AS FAST IF
NOT FASTER ON THE ON THE TWO
MORE ON THE SUBWAY AS THEY CAN
IN THEIR IN THEIR PERSONAL
VEHICLE. AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED TO STRIVE FOR ITS
PART OF WHY WE FOUGHT TO GET
PUBLIC TRANSIT FUNDING INTO SB
ONE AND MAKE SURE THAT THERE'D
BE SIMPSON FUNDING FOR SAFE
CLEAN RELIABLE TRANSIT. I WOULD
SAY THE NOTHING IN THE. I THINK
WITH THIS WITH THIS SEEKS TO DO
WITH THIS BILL SEEKS TO DO IS
FOCUS ON. TRYING TO MEET OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS AND TO AND
POLLUTION REDUCTION GOALS. ARE
I THINK ACTUALLY I DON'T CENTER
SKINNER AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN
WORKING QUITE A BIT ON TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT AS WE DO.
MOVE INTO A TRANSPORTATION.
REVOLUTION WITH THE GUARDS
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES AND OTHERS
WE DO SO MINDFULLY AND WE DO
SO. IN A WAY THAT THE THAT
SEEKS TO REDUCE POLLUTION AND
THAT COULD BE DONE. BY MAKING
SURE THAT THOSE VEHICLES ARE
LOWER ADMITTING THAT THEY MADE.
ELECTRIC THAT'S ALL PART OF THE
CONVERSATION RIGHT NOW SO. IF
THEY'RE IF THEY'RE ALL THE V.
FOR EXAMPLE. YOU KNOW THAT'S A
WAY TO GET PEOPLE AROUND WHILE
ALSO REDUCING OUR OUR EMISSIONS
SO. THAT WOULD CERTAINLY BE
SOMETHING I THINK WE
APPROPRIATE FOR THE FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION YOUR GOVERNOR
BERMAN OF TRANSPORTATION AND
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL TO
LOOK AT. AS THE IMPLEMENT THIS
BILL AS A DRAFT THE NEXT
ITERATION OF THE COVERAGES
VISION PLAN NOW I DON'T THINK
IT'S ANYTHING. A CONFLICTING IN
SOME IN WHICH YOU ASKED ABOUT.
THANK YOU. MISTER PRESIDENT
JUST THE CLOTHES I THINK WE
NEED TO START THINKING A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY THAT IT FOUR
BUILDING CARS. WITH THAT LOTUS
ZERO EMISSIONS. AND THAT HELPS
THE- ENVIRONMENT MAYBE WE OUGHT
TO BE LOOKING AT. HOW TO MOVE
PEOPLE QUICKER MAYBE IT TO
LANES NOT TRAINS. AND WE JUST
NEED TO MAYBE. RETHINK HOW WERE
REVIEWING OUR FUTURES. AND OUR
OUR MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE TO. JOBS.
PLANNING PROCESS TO MAKE OUR
ROADS. WORK BETTER. TO MAKE
TRANSIT WORK AND TO MAKE TRAVEL
BETTER FOR. THE PUBLIC WE
CAN'T. IN MANY CASES PROBABLY
MOST CASES IN URBAN AREAS. BILL
MORE LANDS ON A FREEWAYS HOW
YOU GOT A- HOW YOU GOT A
COMPLETE YOU CAN'T JUST KEEP
ADDING LANES IN THE URBAN AREAS
YOU HAVE TO MAKE AS THE SYSTEM
WE HAVE WORK MORE EFFICIENTLY.
AND THAT'S A COMBINATION
TRANSIT HIGHWAYS OF OTHER
EFFICIENCIES WITH FREIGHT
MOVEMENT. AND I'D LIKE TO QUOTE.
AS I DID WHEN WE DEBATED SB
WANT I LIKE TO QUOTE. THE BIBLE
IF I COULD MISTER MISTER
PRESIDENT WE WERE TOLD TO MAKE
THE ROAD THE CROOKED ROAD
STRAIGHT. AND THE ROUGH ROADS
MOVE. AND I THINK WE OUGHT TO
CONTINUE THE SP ONE DICTUM THAT
WE SAID DURING THE DEBATE ON SB
ONE HERE IN THE SENATE CHAMBERS
I DON'T USE THAT QUOTE AGAIN
QUICKER ROAD STRAIGHT. AND THE
ROUGH ROADS MOVE THAT'S WE'RE.
GOING TO DO. I REGION I HERE'S
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS MATTER. ANY
ADDITION IS DESCRIPTION OF IT
ON THE SIDE ON SCENE ON. CENTRE
ALLEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
BY APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE
TAKEN IS TO SEARCH. OR
SYNAGOGUE OR TEMPLE MOSCOW WITH
REGARDS TO THE THAT COMMON
THAT'S ACTUALLY A WONDERFUL
PORTION OF THE MESSIAH HANDEL'S
MESSIAH. THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S
RIGHT SO I BUT I DO APPRECIATE
THOSE COMMENTS I JUST YOU KNOW
TO KIND OF ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ISSUES WERE RAISED BY MY-
FRIEND FROM TO MACULA I'M IN
THE END OF THE DAY WHY WOULD WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
TAKING. POLLUTION INTO ACCOUNT
AIR QUALITY INTO ACCOUNT WHEN
WE'RE MAKING OUR TRANSPORTATION
DECISIONS. I MEAN THE END OF
THE DAY ALL THIS IS AN UPDATE
TO THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION PLAN IT DOESN'T.
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE
PLANNING INFRASTRUCTURE BUT IT
JUST SAYS THAT THERE ARE SOME
ADDITIONAL THINGS THAT ARE TO
BE TAKEN ACCOUNT ONLY. MAKE
THESE DECISIONS I MENTIONED
EARLIER TODAY I'M SOMEONE WHO
GREW UP IN LOS ANGELES WHERE WE
HAD TERRIBLE AIR QUALITY AND WE
STILL HAVE A BETTER QUALITY IN
CERTAIN AREAS BUT THERE WAS IT
WAS A POINT WHERE I THINK SOME
MEMBERS ARE RULES REALLY
REMEMBER. WHEN YOU CAN BARELY
SEE THE HOLLYWOOD SIGN. JUST
JUST DRIVING THROUGH LA BECAUSE
THE SMOG LEVELS ARE SO BAD
THANK GOD WE HAD THE FORESIGHT
AS GOVERNMENT. TO SAY YOU KNOW
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH WERE ACTUALLY
COMMITTED CHILD ABUSE AGAINST
THE CHILDREN OF LOS ANGELES
WE'RE GONNA TAKE POLLUTION INTO
ACCOUNT AND WE START MAKING
DECISIONS. ABOUT THE WAY WE GET
AROUND AS A AS A REGION. AND
THAT'S ALL. THIS BILL IS DOING
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY LOOK. SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS. AYE BATES.
NOBEL HI GORGEOUS NO BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO CHIANG NO DALY NO
DODD I DORADO I GALGIANI. HI
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ BY GROVE. NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
BUYER TADO I JACKSON BY JONES.
NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL I MONEY I'M MORE LOCK
NO MORALE NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. NO BURKE. TYLER CASKEY
BY WIENER AYE WILK. NO. SECTOR
PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBER
CAPITAL. NO. ICE TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS TWELVE THE MEASURE PASSES
NUMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM THREE OLD FOR SENATOR
GONZALEZ ARE YOU. AIRED FOR
THAT ITEM. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FORTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE
MON AN ACT RELATING TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION CENTER
GONZALEZ THANK OU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS AB FIVE
FORTY HIGH BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MONIQUE LIMON ESTABLISHES THE
CALIFORNIA DREAMER SERVICE
INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION THIS SUPPLEMENTAL
GRANT WILL PROVIDE ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPLORE. AND GAIN EXPERIENCE IN
THEIR SELECTED CAREER PATH
THROUGH VOLUNTEERING AND
COMMUNITY SERVICE WE STILL KNOW
THEIR SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL AT
EIGHT GAP EXISTS WITH AB FIVE
FORTY STUDENTS WHO QUALIFY FOR
LIMITED. WHO QUALIFY FOR ONLY
LIMITED IN STATE FINANCIAL AID
THANKS TO ALL WHO RECOGNIZE THE
VALUE DREAMERS BRING TO
CALIFORNIA FUNDING FOR THIS
BILL HAS BECOME A REALITY A
RECENT CLARIFYING AND TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS WILL MAKE SURE
STUDENTS WILL GET THE BEST
VOLUNTEERING EXPERIENCE
POSSIBLE WITH THIS IN MIND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. SHEEN
HEARING NINE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES NOBEL AYE
PORGES NO BRADFORD I CAN BE AT
ALL I CHIANG NO DELHI. NO DODD.
HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI. HI
GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI GROW. NO
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO I
TACO I JACKSON BY JONES NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
BY MONNING. BY MORE LOCK NO
MORALE NO NIELSEN. NO PAN BY
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER I WILL COUNTY I WINNER
BY WILK NO. SECTOR PLEASE CALL
OUT TO MEMBER. GLAZER HI. ICE
TWENTY NINE KNOWS ELEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON NOW
MEMBERS TO FILE ITEM THREE
THIRTY SENATOR HILL YOU'RE
PREPARED. WITH SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. ASSEMBLY THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AND
ACKLINGTON NON VEHICULAR AIR
POLLUTION. SENATOR HILL THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AS WE ARE
ALL AWARE WILD FIRES IN THE
RECENT YEARS. HAVE HAD
DEVASTATING IMPACT IN OUR STATE
IN ADDITION TO BURNING OVER ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION ACRES OF
LAND RECENT WILDFIRES IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
HAVE DEMONSTRATED HOW WILD
FIRES HAVE IMPACTED THE AIR
QUALITY FOR RESIDENTS WHO LIVE
HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY FROM THE
BURNED AREAS. CONTAMINATED AIR
CAUSES PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES AS
A CONTROL THE LENGTH OF THE
STATE AND CAUSE NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS TO CHILDREN ELDERLY AND
INDIVIDUALS WITH EXISTING
RESPIRATORY PROBLEMS. TO
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THESE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERN FROM
CONTAMINATED AIR AND POLLUTION
IDENTIFIED CLEAN AIR CENTERS
WOULD PROVIDE HEALTHIER INDOOR
ENVIRONMENTS DURING PERIODS OF
UNHEALTHY AIR QUALITY. AB EIGHT
THIRTY SIX WOULD ESTABLISH A
PILOT PROGRAM TO IDENTIFY CLEAN
AIR CENTERS AND ESTABLISH A
GRANT FUND TO RETROFIT
FACILITIES AND UPGRADE
VENTILATION SYSTEMS THIS BILL
HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE COLLEAGUES. ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OF IT ON
THE SIDE ON. YOUR INSANE NINE.
MEMBERS THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL HER. THREE
NINE. EYES FORTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES
. MEMBERS
REMOVING BACK TO MOTIONS READ
RESOLUTIONS. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE FOLLOWING MEASURES WILL BE.
PLACE ON TODAY SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDARS ITEMS. 242-526-2720.
EIGHT TWENTY NINE THIRTY THREE.
343-637-3940. ONE FORTY TWO
FORTY THREE FORTY FOUR. PLEASE
HAVE THE SECRETARY READ THOSE.
SENATE BILL FIVE OH SEVEN THIRD
SECTOR PLEASE ROUTE. SENATE
BILL FIVE OH SEVEN SIX A.
1-780-216-4150 ONE TO THIRTY
TWO TO SIXTY SEVEN THREE OO.
635-569-6796 EIGHTY ONE SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO AND SENATE BILL
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR. NO
OBJECTIONS. ICE FORTY KNOWS IS
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SPECIAL CONCERT CALENDARS
APPROVED. NOW WE'RE GOING TO
COMMIT ANY ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE
THERE COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
HOW SENATOR WIENER I THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT OVER HERE ON
THE CORNER. BY THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE WILL MEET IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE FIFTEEN
MINUTES AFTER GERMAN. NOTED
HOUSING COMMITTEE FIFTEEN
MINUTES AFTER GERMAN. ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS
. IF THERE'S NO
FURTHER BUSINESS INTERACTIONS
TO DISS COLOR. MISTER PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR AN
INCREDIBLE PRESIDING OVER
SESSION TODAY LET ME. I THINK
THAT'S WORTH I THANK YOU. AND
TO MY COLLEAGUES EVERYONE HERE
I HOPE YOU GO HOME AND GET A
GOOD NIGHT'S REST I WANT TO
THANK THE FLOOR TEAM FOR YOUR
EFFICIENCY AND THE WORK TO GET
US THROUGH THIS WE DID WELL
OVER A HUNDRED BILLS TODAY MR
MAJORITY LEADER. SO WHILE WE
MET YOUR GOAL AND WITH THAT WE
WILL. I WILL SEE YOU NEXT
TOMORROW TOMORROW WOULD BE
THURSDAY SEPTEMBER FIFTH AT TEN
AM THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
MEMBERS THE SENATE WILL BE
ADJOURNED IT WE WILL RECONVENE
AT THURSDAY TOMORROW AT TEN AM.
WE STAND ADJOURNED